Chat, geht Hard-Windows wieder an den Audio-Settings um?
Ne, ne, geht alles.
Excellent, so, ich muss noch kurz was trinken.
Ich hab heute große, wie viel passt denn da rein?
37 Ounces große.
Ja, auf dieser Trinkflasche steht, das sind Ounces.
Was sind 32 Ounces?
32 Ounces in Liter, in Milliliter, in Milliliter?
Ähm, okay, es passt ungefähr in Liter rein in die Flasche.
Warum eigentlich auf Ounces, bitteschön, ja?
Warum trinken die da, naja, egal, das ist Kokona-Trinkflasche, keine Ahnung.
Also in Liter, ungefähr.
Ich werd was trinken.
Hast du die im Ami-Laden geholt?
Hast du die im Ami-Laden, ne, über Amazon.
Aber ich hab die nicht.
Aber ich gebatet.
Da steht auch nebendran noch was in Liter.
Ja, da steht, da steht 1000 Milliliter, da drunter steht 32 Ounces, 900 Milliliter, irgendwann 26 Ounces.
Excellent, dass ich ordentlich was zu trinken hab.
Also in letzter Zeit gemerkt, ich hab ziemlich, ziemlich trockenen Hals.
Ich weiß nicht, daran, dass ich die letzte Zeit irgendwie ein bisschen wenig getrunken hab, glaub ich.
Und ich hab mein Kopium-Gerät lange nicht mehr benutzt.
Ich hab doch so nen...
Ich hab doch so ein Ding gekauft, so ein Inhalierteil.
Nur, aber nur Salzlösung, nicht irgendwie, was ihr jetzt vielleicht denkt, ja, nur Salzlösung.
Und das hilft gegen so trockene, das beugt vor gegen Erkältung und vor allem gegen trockene Atemwege und so, ist das sehr nice.
Kommst dir natürlich vor, wie, weiß ich, als hast du superschwere Krankheit, weil dir da, ne, aber ist ja Schwachsinn.
Das ist eines der besten und nebenwirkungsfreisten Sachen, die man machen kann.
Als Erkältungs-Vorbeugung, generell, wenn man einen trockenen Hals und sowas hat.
Ja, eine Nebenwirkung, dauert sieben Minuten oder so, dann ist es durch.
So, ich mach mal kurz meine VM an.
Und...
Ich glaub, das ist die richtige, ja.
Ich hab so viel Zeug hier.
Und mach mal Update.
Oh, oh, fuck, hab ich jetzt gerade gesagt, ich möchte VM-Ware updaten?
Hab ich jetzt gerade gesagt, ich will VM-Ware updaten?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich will nicht VM-Ware updaten.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen...
Piss dich, Aldo!
VM-Ware, Mann.
Was soll das?
Ja, Chat, ich guck gleich, guck gleich in den Chat.
Ich starte mal kurz die Updates.
Weil Arch, by the way.
Leading Edge am Start.
Am Arch, sozusagen.
Da gibt's nix.
Was?
Nur 15 Pakete?
Was ist denn da los?
Ich komme überhaupt nicht aktuell genug vor.
Mit nur 15 Paketen, die sich geupdatet...
Was?
Was ist mit meinem Emote los?
Wenn nur 15 Pakete upgedatet werden, hab ich ja den einen...
Da hab ich ja fast den...
Weiß nicht, da komm ich mir richtig outdated vor.
Wir haben übrigens noch Stellenanzeigen vom letzten Mal auf.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie...
Diablo 2 Sorg oder PoE 2 Release?
Wie jetzt?
Was jetzt?
Also meine Sorg in Diablo 2 hab ich schon wieder eingestammt.
Das hier resurrected ist einfach...
Haben sie verkackt das Game.
Hab ich keinen Bock mehr zu spielen.
Also wenn schon, denn schon PoE 2 Release.
Aber das dauert ja noch ein bisschen.
Es gibt jetzt eine neue Season in einem Diablo 2 Mod.
25. Oktober oder so.
Aber das spielt wahrscheinlich kaum einer von euch.
So, dann lass mal gucken.
Was hab ich denn im Chat gesehen?
Wie hieß nochmal die Seite, wo die Jays...
Ja, ich weiß was du meinst.
Das hieß irgendwas mit Components.
Component Party.
Das meinst du?
Das ist richtig nice.
Guck, da kann man Frontend-Frameworks benennen.
Da kann man da vergleichen.
Es ist Welt 4, es ist Welt 5.
Wir können auch sagen, okay, wie sieht das Ganze in React aus?
Es ist Welt 5 versus React versus Vue.
Und da haben sie halt immer so unterschiedliche Sachen.
Und zeigen halt, wie das in den unterschiedlichen Frameworks geht.
Die Seite ist richtig nice.
Die ist, um es nicht zu sagen, die ist richtig...
Hog.
So, Riiiit.
Beste.
Kannst du einfach bei dir in den Lebenslauf schreiben.
Twitch, äh, Twitch, Alter.
Twitch Wubbler Subscriber.
Wutsch, schreibt, schreibt Twitch Subscriber rein.
Da wissen sie auch, wen sie besser nicht einstellen.
Äh, das ist nicht leise, was ich hab.
Also wahrscheinlich mit Kompressor.
Das ist richtig laut.
Irgendwann, ich hab mal übelstes Gehusste im Stream.
Irgendwann hab ich das Ding auch mal benutzt im Stream.
Just Wuff.
Und die Leute haben sich gedacht, was ist da los, äh?
Das war richtig laut.
Weiß nicht, zwei, drei Monate, so hab ich das Ding mal im Stream eingeschaltet.
Haben sie alle gedacht, ich kratz jetzt ab.
Da kommt mal ein Garten-Update.
Ja.
Das hat sich echt angehört, glaub ich, für die Leute.
Jetzt kratz ich fast ab.
Das letzte...
Im Schnee...
Das stimmt.
Das ist schon eine Weile her.
Das letzte im Schnee war gar nicht aus dem Garten.
Das letzte Video im Schnee ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Aber das war unterwegs.
Von irgendeiner Wanderrunde.
Also ganz so krass laut ist das nicht.
Und...
Ja.
Am Wochenende.
Das war eine Standardantwort, wenn einer nach einem Video fragt.
Ich sag immer am Wochenende.
Diesen Winter wieder.
Es kommt drauf an, wie viel Winterstelz ist.
Letztes Jahr gab's ja nicht so viel Winterstelz.
Ja, also da muss es schon mal ein bisschen kalt sein.
Und ein paar Tage Schnee.
Der Pepo ist am Kacken.
Den hab ich...
Den hab ich nicht, noch nicht gesehen, den Hintergrund.
Also gesehen hab ich ihn schon.
Ich hab den ja als Repo eingecheckt.
Aber...
Der ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Gibt es eigentlich...
Gibt es dort eigentlich irgendwelche Issues oder irgendwas?
Nee, ne?
Keine Issues.
All die Battlefield 3 Leute sind am Start.
Siehst du mal hier.
Da sind Leute am Start.
Ihr habt bestimmt auch immer auf der Privatkäserei...
Wie hieß dieser Server in Battlefield 3 nochmal?
Privatkäserei Schumann oder so.
Da gab's mal einen.
BF3 Server Privatkäserei.
Privat...
Irgendwie Schumann oder so.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Da gab's so einen Server, der hatte so einen richtig dummen Namen.
Den hab ich mir gemerkt.
Den Rest konnte ich mir nicht...
Irgendwie Privatkäserei Schumann oder so.
Warum auch immer dieser Server so hieß.
Was?
COD Remote Permaban Exploit.
Juckt mich alles nicht.
Wobei ich wahrscheinlich mit dem Fabian tatsächlich ein paar Runden Black Ops 6 spielen werde,
wenn es rauskommt nächste Woche.
Jetzt kommt er hier um 25.
Jetzt kommt das raus.
So, hab ich jetzt...
Chat, hab ich schon rebooted?
Ja, ich hab rebooted.
Ja, da ist er.
Ja, genau.
Den Server meine ich, Alter.
Nee, das ist ein Platoon.
Es gab auch einen Server, der so heißt.
Da steht's doch.
Hier.
Da stand doch der Name gerade.
Hier unten.
Privatkäserei Alois Schumann.
Hieß der Server.
Genau.
Servername, Alter.
Ist das wirklich der...
Nein.
Ich weiß...
Also, glaube ich nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die auf den Servernamen gekommen sind.
Kein Schimmer.
Der war aber so prägnant, dass der mir bis heute, also quasi mindestens 10 Jahre später,
noch im Gedächtnis geblieben ist.
Schade, dass es den Server nicht mehr gibt.
Was?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich hab einen Fiat 500e.
Hatten wir schon.
Ich muss mal kurz die alten...
Die Sachen hier zumachen.
Und, ähm...
Weil wir müssen die alten Stellenanzeigen mal schließen, die ich noch offen hab seit drei Monaten oder so.
Die sind da wahrscheinlich schon outdated, overrated, cheapated.
Das juckt ja eh keinem mehr.
Ja, Leute.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich weiß, die Uhrzeit ist vielleicht etwas untyp...
Was sind hier schon...
Oh, Windows-Stell ist, Alter.
Die Uhrzeit ist etwas untypisch, aber ich hab grad nix, was ich sonst irgendwie machen könnte.
Normalerweise schrieben sich sowas eher abends.
Delta Force mal getestet.
Nein.
Das hat mich sehr abgeschreckt, dass die mit Bots auffüllen.
Da hab ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Ja, normalerweise bin ich ja eher abends am Start.
Aber, grad ruhig hier, dachte ich mir, wir machen jetzt mal Streams oder schon am Mittag.
Und vielleicht, ist ja optional, ne?
Weil abends ist immer so Deadline, 22 Uhr spätestens, 23 Uhr.
Da hab ich Zeit.
So.
Trinken.
Max, schaust du Seven vs. Wild?
Nein, schau ich nicht.
Ich hab auch nicht das...
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob das das Vorbild ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Es gab doch mal so eine Serie mit...
Wie heißt der Typ?
Bear Grylls oder so.
Das war doch auch sowas.
Ähm...
Das hab ich auch nicht geguckt.
Da kenn ich nur Ausschnitte aus YouTube.
Ich leg grad im...
Aber das Letzte, was ich geguckt hab, fällt mir jetzt...
Also nicht, was ich rewatcht hab, sondern Neues.
Also gerade nix.
Da muss ich mal länger drüber nachdenken.
Fällt mir grad so aus dem Kopf nicht ein.
Zumindest hab ich mal wieder mein Netflix-Abo auslaufen lassen.
Also ich mach ja...
Netflix hab ich ja eigentlich so gut gemacht.
So gut wie nie.
Ich starte immer das Netflix-Abo.
Und das Erste, was ich mach, nach dem Starten des Netflix-Abos,
ist das Netflix-Abo wieder zu kündigen.
Dass ich's nicht vergesse.
Übrigens, ich hab's geschafft, Leute.
Wo wir grad beim Kündigen sind.
Ich hab's geschafft.
Ich hab endlich O2 gekündigt.
Nach über eineinhalb Jahren sinnlos Geld bezahlen.
Ich hab den jetzt...
Keine Ahnung, 18 Monate oder so.
Jeden Monat 30 Euro überwiesen.
540 Euro.
Nee, Ende 2022.
Eher...
Eher zwei Jahre.
7...
Ich hab den 720 Euro quasi überwiesen insgesamt.
Für nichts.
Für gar nichts.
Kannst du auch HTML programmieren?
Ja, nur mit If-Schleifen, aber...
Passive Ausgaben, ja.
720...
Also, das Ding ist, warum ich überhaupt...
Also, ich hab ja immer noch ein Handy mit einem Mobilfunk...
Funktionierenden Mobilfunkrahmen drinnen.
Ja, funktioniert.
Von Aldi.
Warum von Aldi?
Ursprünglich war mein Plan, ich geh zur O2.
Dann hab ich mir von O2 was bestellt.
Irgendwie 30 Euro im Monat.
Flatrate, bla, blub.
Was es so gegeben hat.
Nix, nix Tolles, ja.
Warum ich mir O2 bestellt hab damals war,
weil du quasi bis zu sieben SIM-Karten zusätzlich bekommen hast.
Und ich so quasi auch Tablets und alles hätte...
mit ausstatten können.
So war der Plan.
So.
Und dann hat es O2 nicht geschafft,
wochenlang...
mich freizuschalten.
Ich hab mich da angemeldet, alles gut, aber beim Einloggen kamen immer Fehler.
Ich hab die zugespammt auf Twitter, weil das Ding war, ich hatte es damals eilig.
Ich wollte damals meine Rufnummer portieren.
Ich hatte nämlich eine Rufnummer von meinem alten Diensthandy, vom alten Arbeitgeber.
Und die musste ich umziehen bis zu bis Ende 2022, weil ich hab da gekündigt.
Und O2 hat es nicht gebacken bekommen, bis ich dann eines Tages einfach in Aldi bin.
Und hab mir so eine Aldi...
Wie heißt der Kram?
Aldi Starter-Set gekauft.
Und Aldi hat es innerhalb von einem Tag geschafft, das umzuziehen.
So.
Und seitdem hatte ich diesen O2-Vertrag sinnlos laufen.
Und hab es nicht einmal benutzt.
Also ich hab 720 Euro umsonst bekommen.
Easy.
Passives Einkommen für O2.
Oder passive Ausgaben für mich.
Und ich hab es jetzt endlich auf die Reihe gekriegt, Alter.
Die zu kündigen.
Irgendwann.
Hat lange genug gedauert.
Ich bin bei solchen Sachen übelst faul teilweise.
Deswegen bin ich auch bei Abos eigentlich immer hinterher, dass du quasi...
Also immer wenn ich Abos abschließe, bin ich immer am gucken, ob es schon Optionen gibt, das gleich wieder zu kündigen.
Weil von den meisten Sachen, die willst du entweder nur mal ausprobieren und stellst dann fest, das ist nix.
Oder aber du willst eh nur mal einen Monat die 1-2 Sachen, was ist bei Service X?
Was auch immer das jetzt ist, ne?
Gibt angucken und dann...
Willst es gar nicht mehr haben.
Also Abo...
Abos sind wirklich das Schlimmste zum Geldloswerden.
Vor allem, wenn man so planlos und faul ist, wie ich, wenn es ums Kündigen geht.
Ja, übrigens zum Thema passive Ausgaben.
Wisst ihr, wer mich seit...
Boah, bestimmt...
Keine Ahnung, sechs, sieben Jahren wieder angeschrieben hat, dass sie Geld von mir wollen.
Heh.
Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich gerade ESP ist, ja.
Ey, woher weißt du das?
Woher weißt du das?
Woher weißt du, dass es die IHK ist?
Ist das Fakebrief vom Twitch-Chat, den ich bekommen hab, oder was?
Ja, die IHK hat mich angeschrieben.
Die IHK ist aber auch sehr nett.
Die schickt mir jetzt...
Also normalerweise ist es ja so, ja.
Sobald du ein Gewerbe anmeldest, bist du Zwangsmitglied...
Weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das rechtlich so hundertprozentig korrekt ist, was ich erzähle, aber so ungefähr in der Richtung ist es, ja.
Sobald du ein Gewerbe anmeldest, bist du quasi Zwangsmitglied bei der IHK und musst Zwangsmitgliedsbeitrag bezahlen.
Das waren die ganze Zeit immer quasi mindestens 50 Euro im Jahr.
Und ab diesem Jahr sind es 60 Euro im Jahr.
Ja, das macht auch...
Die Inflation macht auch vor der IHK nicht halt.
Allerdings...
Wenn man weniger als, glaube ich, 6000 Euro verdient mit seinem Gewerbe...
Also verdient ist das falsche Wort.
Einkommen...
Nee, Einkommen ist auch falsch.
Einnahmen.
Einnahmen ist das Richtige.
Wenn man weniger als 6000 Euro Einnahmen hat im Jahr, ist man, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, Mitgliedsbeitrag befreit.
Und nachdem ich ja schon seit Jahren quasi nur rumgammel...
Was...
Was meine Influencer-Tätigkeit angeht, war ich da eigentlich lange Zeit drunter.
Das Problem ist nur, dass ich immer mal wieder Jahre hatte, wo es mich gepackt hat und ich viel gemacht habe.
Und anscheinend war es so, dass ich im Jahr 2021 tatsächlich über 10.000 Euro hatte.
Oder fast 11.000 Euro hatte.
Und...
Das haben die wohl jetzt nachgeguckt.
Und sind...
Und sind netterweise davon ausgegangen...
Die sind ja immer sehr zuvorkommend, die Leute, bei sowas.
Die sind natürlich auch dafür ausgegangen, dass ich 2022 und 2023 und 2024 die exakt gleichen Einnahmen hatte.
Logisch.
Ne?
Was sonst?
Und dementsprechend haben die mir zur Rechnung geschickt, dass ich doch gefälligst mal Beitrag bezahlen soll für 2021, 2022, 2023, 2024.
210 Euro.
Das Ding ist, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich zumindest 2023 und vor allem 2024, aber da habe ich die Steuererklärung noch nicht gemacht,
weniger als 6.000 Euro Einnahmen hatte.
Aber da müsste ich jetzt quasi das mit dem Steuerberater klären und dann da hinschicken und 2022...
Wobei 2022 weiß ich nicht.
2022 habe ich auch noch ein bisschen Sellout-Stells gemacht.
Wann mal...
Wann habe ich meinen Genshin Impact...
Sellout-Stells gemacht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Das könnte 2022 oder so gewesen sein, ja?
Da habe ich wahrscheinlich...
Da war ich wahrscheinlich auch drüber.
Und jetzt wollen die wieder.
Für welche Leistung?
Ja, das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Ich bin...
Ich bin Zwangsmitglied in der IHK.
Ich habe von denen noch nie was gewollt oder irgendwas von denen in Anspruch genommen.
Willst du nicht mal Sellout für die IHK machen?
Kommt drauf an, was die IHK bezahlen will dafür, dass ich Sellout mache.
Ich glaube, ich habe bisher nur negativen Sellout für die IHK gemacht.
Gerade wenn...
Wenn ich mich über Abschlussprüfungen und so ausgelassen habe.
Da habe ich, glaube ich, gutes Haar.
Zu Recht.
An der IHK gelassen.
Ja.
Hier ist der Zettel.
Die wollen wieder Geld.
Ey, wie wollen sie alle Geld?
Ich weiß nicht, wie die da ausgerechnet jetzt drauf gekommen sind.
Ja.
Und übrigens, noch eine Sache, die mir aufgefallen ist.
Chat.
Wer von euch kann sich noch an die Intel CPU...
Wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Wobei, da kann sich jeder, der sich damit beschäftigt, auch dran erinnern.
Äh, dieses...
Äh...
Die Craven.
Wie heißt denn das?
Ähm...
Abnutzung.
Die zu schnelle Abnutzung von Intel CPUs.
Der 13. und 14. Generation.
Da könnt ihr euch ja sicherlich noch dran erinnern.
Das war ja die letzten...
Na, vier Monate.
Überall.
Ja.
Der Bauer hat sich drüber ausgelassen.
Ähm...
Englischsprachige Technik Channel haben sich drüber ausgelassen.
News-Seiten haben sich drüber ausgelassen.
Also, letztendlich ist es ja so, die verschleißen schneller aktuelle Intel-CPUs.
13. und 14. Generation.
Genau das.
Aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Ich krieg's grad aus dem Kopf nicht mehr so genau zusammen.
Irgendwie, manchmal waren die Kupferlayer irgendwie zu dünn.
Und dann war irgendwie der Takt zu hoch und die Spannung zu hoch.
Und es gibt verschiedene Gründe.
Letztendlich...
...hab ich heute mal nachgeguckt, was man machen müsste,
damit Intel einem eine neue CPU schickt.
Weil, ich hab ne 13.900K.
Und der ist halt...
...das ist...
Ich hab einen der ersten.
13.900K und das ist halt so ne CPU-Serie.
Die ist da halt wirklich sehr häufig von betroffen.
Ich hab aber keine, keine...
Zumindest keine...
...extrem offensichtlichen Probleme.
Ich hatte jetzt letztens ein Game, was öfters gecrashed ist.
Das lag ja wahrscheinlich an dem Game.
Und ich musste mein XMP-RAM-Profil abschalten.
Aber das hab ich schon vor zwei Jahren, quasi kurz nachdem die Rechnung war.
Weil ich das ja gekauft hab, wieder abgeschaltet.
Weil es nicht hundertprozentig stable war.
Also ist eigentlich alles soweit okay.
Und ich hab mal geguckt, was man machen muss.
Und es gibt so eine Intel-Warranty-Ticket-Page.
Und da steht...
Hast du mitbekommen, dass die Chinesen angeblich einen Backdoor in allen Intel-CPUs gefunden haben?
Ne.
So.
Das Problem ist, wenn man...
Hab ich schon mal gesagt, ich hasse Seiten, die die Rück- und Vorwärtsfunktionen im Browser überschreiben.
So, das Problem ist, wenn man jetzt checken möchte, ob seine CPU betroffen ist, dann braucht man die Batch-Number und die ATPO.
Und wisst ihr, wo das steht?
Das hier steht auf der CPU.
Und das hier steht auf der Verpackung.
Alternativ kann man sich die hier wohl auch aus der Verpackung, aus Nummern auf der Verpackung ableiten.
So.
Man braucht die Verpackung also dafür.
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten, wer die Verpackung von seiner CPU nicht mehr hat.
Also, RMA mit meiner CPU kann man wahrscheinlich vergessen.
Die IHK, die hatte ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Ich habe meine Verpackung für die CPU nicht mehr.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich für eine Batch-Number habe.
Und ich habe auch keine Ahnung, ohne dass ich die CPU ausbaue, was ich für eine ATPO habe.
Hast du die Rechnung noch?
Die Rechnung...
Ich habe zumindest...
Zumindest klicke ich über meine E-Mails raus, wo ich die gekauft habe.
Und dann klicke ich vielleicht dort im Shop raus.
Ja, also, Rechnung werde ich noch haben.
Rechnung werde ich noch haben.
Zumindest im Zuge dessen...
Im Zuge dessen habe ich gestern mal wieder geguckt.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen...
Ich habe ja BIOS...
Ich habe ja einen BIOS-Update gemacht für diese Probleme mit Intel-CPUs.
Ja.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen...
Ich habe ein AERUS Elite X...
AXZ790 Mainboard.
AORUS.
Nicht AERUS.
Von Gigabyte.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, als ich da gestern ein bisschen News gelesen habe,
dass es mit diesem BIOS-Update nicht getan ist.
Ich habe im August...
Ich habe im August, nachdem das bekannt geworden ist mit dieser Intel-CPU-Geschichte,
die quasi kaputt gehen mit der Zeit,
habe ich dieses BIOS-Update gemacht und habe das Problem bei mir im Kopf abgehakt.
Was ich nicht wusste ist, dass vor drei Wochen Intel nochmal ein Micro-Code-Update released hat
und nochmal ein BIOS-Update fällig ist.
Und da denke ich mir, wenn ich das schon mitkriege...
Ich bin jetzt ja, was Technik-Sachen angeht, nicht ganz uninteressiert.
Ich meine, ich verfolge gerade, was CPU-Entwicklung angeht...
Ich verfolge das jetzt nicht unbedingt daily.
Aber ich habe das nicht mitgekriegt.
Und ich bin schon relativ technikinteressiert.
Was macht denn der Durchschnitts-Intel-CPU-Käufer?
Der hat weder das hier mitgekriegt, noch hat er das hier mitgekriegt.
Bei einem Micro-Code-Update ist doch kein BIOS-Update nötig, doch?
Das wird nicht mit Windows-Updates oder so verteilt.
Die wissen das gar nicht.
Bei denen geht einfach nach, keine Ahnung, drei, vier Jahren die CPU kaputt
und die denken sich, oh scheiße.
Der kauft jetzt AMD.
Ne, der kauft jetzt nicht AMD.
Der weiß doch gar nicht, woran das liegt.
In der Regel war das bisher ja auch nie nötig.
Es gab noch nie CPUs.
Ganz im Ernst, jetzt mal seriously.
Oder wie der Kaboom früher gesagt hat, eine Hand aufs Herz.
Wem von euch ist tatsächlich schon mal eine CPU kaputt gegangen?
In einem Rechner, den ihr so benutzt habt.
Ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass ihr die mutwillig zerstört habt, so beim Köpfen oder so.
Oder dass ihr die absichtlich gegrillt habt oder sowas.
In all den Jahren, mir ist noch nie,
noch wirklich nie eine CPU irgendwie durch Überlastung oder zu langes Benutzen kaputt gegangen.
Ich habe das natürlich im Enterprise-Sektor,
gerade in der Zeit, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe und täglich in Rechenzentren in Frankfurt unterwegs war,
da waren öfters mal CPUs kaputt.
Das habe ich schon gesehen, aber bei mir privat.
Ich hatte noch nie CPU-Fehler.
Noch nie.
Weiß ich nicht.
Noch nie, sind noch nie kaputt gegangen.
Und dementsprechend habe ich im Kopf jetzt auch gar nicht gedacht,
dass es da Probleme gibt, bis ich das mitbekommen habe.
Und jetzt gab es doch nochmal einen BIOS-Update.
Wer soll denn da noch den Überblick behalten?
Aber hat er denn auch RAM?
Der das kann?
Weil ich meine, der meiste RAM, der das kann, kann das nicht.
Weil das ist DDR4 und das ist...
Ne, Moment, Moment.
Was für einen RAM habe ich?
Moment.
Kann man das immer nicht merken.
Ich bin da übelst planlos.
Was...
Was habe ich für einen RAM?
6400, ah ja, okay.
Dann geht es aber hier eher um DDR3 und zu DDR4 oder sowas, ne.
Okay.
Stimmt, das ist aber auch schon ewig her.
So, und zumindest, was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist,
ich habe jetzt das BIOS-Update.
Heute Morgen habe ich das neue BIOS-Update nochmal eingespielt.
Und danach habe ich mir gedacht, okay Max, teste doch mal irgendwie deine CPU.
Ob die irgendwie kaputt ist.
Ne.
Das ist natürlich von Intel kein offizielles Testing-Tool oder sonst was in der Richtung,
um zu gucken, ob die CPU kaputt ist.
Ist aber auch schwierig, verstehe ich.
Was ich gemacht habe ist,
ich habe hier meine morgendliche Wanderrunde abgeschlossen.
Bin heimgekommen.
Hab Cinebench, Cinebench.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich?
Cinebench.
Wie spricht man das eigentlich richtig aus?
Wie spricht man Cinebench aus Cinebench?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Lassen wir uns das mal erklären.
Also wir.
Cinebench.
Oh, das ist der Beste hier.
Der hat erstmal sein Mikrofon eingeschaltet, während er schon gesprochen hat.
Cinebench.
Cinema.
Ah ja, stimmt.
Die stellen doch auch so ein 3D-Render-Ding her.
Cinema 4D, ne?
Achso.
Ja, ja.
Nee, 4D, nicht 3D.
4D.
Stimmt.
Ja, dann ergibt es Scan.
Okay, Cinebench.
Cinebench.
Macht Sinn.
Ja, ihr habt Recht.
Da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, dass das der gleiche Hersteller ist.
Ja.
Habe ich, also ich bin von meiner Morgenswanderrunde heimgekommen.
Cinebench angeschmissen, halbe Stunde laufen lassen.
In der Zwischenzeit ein Crossoir gefoddert und mich umgezogen.
Dann war eine halbe Stunde rum.
Multicore, ohne zu crashen, ohne was gelaufen.
Ich hatte HW-Info offen, geguckt, Spannungen und Temperaturen.
Na gut.
Temperaturen sind bei Cinebench natürlich ab und zu mal immer ein bisschen am Limit,
trotz Wasserkühlung.
Das geht gar nicht anders.
So bei so 96, 97 Grad, ja.
Mein Limit ist 105, aber das ist eigentlich ganz normal.
Also Multicore, halbe Stunde durchgelaufen, ohne Crash, ohne Probleme.
Dann habe ich Singlecore angeschmissen, halbe Stunde.
Bin rennen gegangen, ca.
45 Minuten.
Bin heimgekommen und das war fertig und ist nicht gecrashed.
Also das Ding hat jetzt quasi halbe Stunde Cinebench Singlecore und halbe Stunde Cinebench
Multicore laufen gehabt.
Ich würde einfach mal sagen, wenn die CPU das mitmacht und nichts crasht und es keine
Probleme gibt oder irgendwas.
Also die Werte, also die Cinebench Werte am Ende auch okay sind.
Also ich glaube, meine CPU ist fein.
Ja, ich habe aber auch Glück.
Weil.
Ich habe zwar den ultra krassen High End Rechner gekauft vor zwei Jahren, aber ich habe damit
wenig ultra krasses High End Zeug gemacht.
Da wurde nicht so richtig gestresst und großartig ausgelastet.
Also ich denke mal, ich denke mal, meine CPU ist fein.
Nachdem ich meine Box nicht mehr habe, wird es halt schwierig zu RMA.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob man sowas mit CPUs vergleichen kann.
Bei CPUs geht es ja meistens schleichend und die Probleme werden immer mehr.
Ich könnte auch sagen, bei Log4j sah es auch lange Zeit gut aus.
Nein, kann man nicht.
Kann man nicht abfragen.
Dann Chatgib.
Also.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir heute.
Ich kann nicht reden, Alter.
Three Head.
Wo haben wir unsere.
Wo habe ich?
Habe ich irgendwo mein?
Ich habe hier mein Six Head Emote.
Five Head.
Wir haben doch irgendwo auch.
Low IQ Three Head.
Ja.
Yeah.
Khit-Khin von Three Head Emote.
Chat, helft mir mal suchen, ich habe.
Ich habe zu viele.
Ich habe zu viele Emotes.
Wo ist.
Wo ist?
Three Head?
Gibt es.
Hier.
Ich kann nicht richtig reden, Leute.
Also eigentlich, um den Satz jetzt noch mal zu verstehen.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir heute Stellenanzeigen mit euch angucken.
Das heißt, wenn ihr irgendwas habt.
Einfach nur, was's lustig ist Was, wo ihr euch vielleicht bewerben wollt, vielleicht
auch.
Und das machen wir tatsächlich in letzter Zeit immer öfters.
Hatten wir am Anfang auch nicht so viel.
Wenn ihr in einem Unternehmen arbeitet, das gerade Leute sucht oder wenn ihr selbst eine Stellenanzeige geschrieben habt, könnt ihr auch schicken.
Da bin ich immer ein bisschen netter zu, wenn das was ist, wo persönliches Interesse im Chat besteht, als wenn wir uns einfach nur Sachen angucken.
So, aber ich glaube, wir haben ja noch Sachen vom letzten Mal übrig.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die überhaupt noch irgendwie aktuell sind.
Wir werden mal kurz drüber scrollen.
Ja, hier ist die Intel-CPU-Problematik.
Wir schließen jetzt einfach mal alles.
Alle Tabs schließen nach rechts.
Ging das nicht irgendwie?
Ja doch, geht doch.
Das steht so da.
Neuer, nur Tabs rechts.
Was?
Ne.
Na gut, was auch immer.
Da machen wir einfach hier so zu.
Ist nicht mehr verfügbar.
Sätschke.
Ja, das habe ich auch gesehen.
Wusste ich bis heute gar nicht, dass dieses Tool existiert.
Das habe ich auch in irgendeinem YouTube-Video gesehen.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Aber ich verstehe Intel.
Weil, in dem Fall, das ist, glaube ich, sehr schwer zu testen, ob die CPU so weit kaputt ist.
Es gibt da, glaube ich, kein, ist hundertprozentig kaputt und es garantiert nicht kaputt.
Das ist so ein schleichendes Ding.
Du packst immer alle Hardware-Boxen in den Gehäusekarton.
Das ist schlau.
Hätte ich auch machen sollen.
Aber es ist halt einfach bei Hardware so, in der Regel geht da nichts kaputt großartig, wenn es erstmal in Betrieb ist und eine Woche gelaufen ist.
Und meistens braucht man auch zumindest nichts mehr von der Verpackung.
Aber bei Intel ist das so.
Ich habe alles weggeschmissen.
Ich habe nichts mehr an Verpackung von meinem Rechner.
Es ist eh, also eins muss man jetzt mal wirklich sagen, ne, so schlecht, ganz ehrlich, so schlecht wie diesmal, war Hardware noch nie.
Jetzt mal, jetzt mal, guckt mal.
Jetzt guckt euch das mal an.
Fangen wir mal hier an.
Also, gut, mit dem Netzteil gibt es keine Probleme, mit der Erkühlung gibt es keine Probleme, mit dem Gehäuse gibt es keine Probleme.
Ähm, das Mainboard ist okay.
Damit gibt es prinzipiell auch keine Probleme.
Aber hier geht es schon los.
Grafikkarte ist eine der ersten 4090 RTX gewesen.
Das sind die, die dafür bekannt waren, dass der Adapter, genau der, genau, genau der, das sind die Grafikkarten, die dafür bekannt waren, dass der mitgelieferte Adapter den Rechner zum Brennen bringen kann.
Der mitgelieferte Poweradapter für die Grafikkarten, der konnte ankokeln und anbrennen.
Also, Fail.
Ja, weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Machine Learning Engineer, ML6.
Oh, das ist aber hier richtig agile.
Ist das was von dir oder was ist das für, ich kenne die Seite nicht.
Ist das dort, wo du arbeitest oder ist das was, was dich interessiert?
So, also, Grafikkarte, schon mal fundamentale Probleme gehabt.
Ja, ich glaube, dass man Rechner kann anfangen zu brennen, durchaus als fundamentales Problem bezeichnen kann.
Ja.
Ja, die müsste ich bewerben, okay.
So, nächstes, RAM.
Ich habe mir den hier gekauft mit diesen Settings und diesem Takt, schafft er nicht.
Auch geil.
Random Rechner Crashes.
Wenn man das wirklich entforst, dieses Profil.
Auch geil, top.
Intel CPU.
Da müssen wir, glaube ich, nicht von reden.
Das haben alle mitgekriegt, wie im Arsch das Ding ist.
Der Link von...
Das kann das aufmachen, was?
Puppet.
Das da.
Puppet Konfiguration.
Es gibt noch Leute, die Puppet verwenden.
Weißt du noch, was du für die Grafikkarte bezahlt hast?
Ey, ich kann nachgucken.
Lass mich mal kurz...
Also, wenn du Glück hast, habe ich die bei Amazon bestellt.
Weil ich habe den Rechner bei drei unterschiedlichen Shops damals zusammengestellt.
Nein.
Dann gucke ich mal in meinen E-Mails, ob ich da das noch finde.
Zotac.
Search in Trash Folder.
Nein.
Einfach ganz normal.
Zotac.
Aha, hier.
Versandbenachrichtigung.
Rechnung zu ihrer Bestellung.
Was ist das für ein komischer Shop, wo ich das bestellt habe?
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Aber Hauptsache...
Ich habe die Grafikkarte und die CPU.
Ah, was ist denn das?
Steht da etwa die Boxnummer auf meiner Rechnung drauf?
Post Champ?
Ist das die Boxnummer?
Da steht so eine random...
So eine random...
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14-stellige Nummer drauf.
Moment.
Intel Warranty Page.
Wie sieht es aus?
Das ist so eine...
Okay.
Intel Badge Number.
Wie sieht sowas aus?
Das ist nicht die...
Das ist nicht das, was bei mir auf der Rechnung steht.
Ne.
Ganz was anderes.
Sad.
Pech gehabt, Max.
Keine RMA für deine CPU.
Aber da steht drauf, was die Grafikkarte gekostet hat.
Also, zu deiner Frage.
Die Grafikkarte hat damals...
Wo habe ich das denn jetzt?
MonkaS?
Es ist...
Ich habe einfach zu viele...
Ich habe einfach zu viel auf...
Äh...
Die Grafikkarte, um deine Frage zu beantworten.
Die Grafikkarte hat damals gekostet...
2249 Euro.
Das ist schon...
Das ist schon eine Stange Geld für eine Grafikkarte, oder?
Und die 5000...
Die 5090, die jetzt irgendwann demnächst rauskommt, die kostet wahrscheinlich nochmal 500 Euro mehr.
Ich ja von mir fand es aber spannend.
Also...
Weiß.
So.
S...
Äh...
SAP MonkaW.
So, um das jetzt Ganze nochmal abzuschließen.
Also...
Ähm...
Grafikkarte, fundamentale Probleme.
RAM hält nicht das, was er verspricht.
Intel CPU...
Sage ich einfach nur noch dazu.
Und dann kommen wir zu SSD.
Erinnert sich da vielleicht auch noch einer dran?
Dass die neuen Samsung SSDs damals Firmware-Probleme hatten bei Release?
Kann sich da noch einer dunkel dran erinnern?
Oder vielleicht erinnere ich mich da auch nur dran, weil ich so ein Ding hatte?
Die...
Die Samsung...
Die Samsung Ssd...
Die Sam...
Dafür kannst du 3x mehr O2 bezahlen.
Nice!
Passives Einkommen für O2 generieren, ja.
Die hatten Firmware-Probleme am Anfang, dass die auch sich viel schneller abgenutzt haben.
Wobei abgenutzt falsch ist, dass das Rear-Leveling nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Funktioniert hat und die SSD viel, viel, viel, viel schneller verschlissen ist, als eigentlich gedacht.
Also, ich halte fest.
Vier und davon nicht unbedingt unwichtige Teile meines PCs, die auch locker die Hälfte des Preises ausgemacht haben,
zwei Drittel des Preises ausgemacht haben, hatten fundamentale Fehler.
Geil!
Geile, geile Hardware-Qualität.
So will man das haben, wenn man 5000 Euro für einen neuen Rechner ausgibt, oder?
Alle wichtigen Komponenten im Arsch.
Super.
Also, so schlecht, ganz ehrlich.
So schlecht.
So schlechte Hardware hatte ich noch nie.
Noch nie in all den Jahren, seit ich Hardware kaufe.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wann ich meinen ersten Rechner gekauft, schrägstrich, bekommen habe.
1995 oder so.
So schlechte Hardware-Qualität durch die Bank weg.
Noch nie.
Grafikkarte kann abfackeln wegen dem Adapter.
RAM hält nicht das, was ich gekauft habe.
CPU ist komplett im Arsch.
SSD ist mit der Firma auch im Arsch.
What the...
Was haben die gemacht?
2022 hatten die alle noch Corona.
Und die alle hier, so, die Hardware hergestellt, oder wie?
Ja, die, okay, die Festplatte hat kein Problem.
Ja, super.
Die ist okay, die funzt ohne Probleme.
Das Mainboard funzt auch ohne Probleme.
Der Thermal Grizzly Kontaktframe funktioniert auch ohne Probleme.
Er hat bestimmt der Bauer handgefräst, selbst.
Das Gehäuse ist auch top, kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Die Wasserkühlung ist auch okay, funktioniert auch ohne Probleme.
Und das Netzteil funktioniert auch.
Und das Netzteil funktioniert auch ohne Probleme.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, das hier, vielleicht das Mainboard aus...
Das sind schon mit die Hauptkomponenten in dem Rechner.
Und die hatten alle das Problem.
Disappointing Tour 2022.
Ja, das passt wirklich ganz gut.
Der, komm, ich will...
Lass uns mal mit DHL anfangen.
Irgendwie will ich mal wissen, was DHL mit SAP macht.
Bei SAP suche ich ja eh schon immer das Weite, wenn irgendwo das Wort SAP auftaucht.
Bei den Kühler...
Der hat auch Kühler?
Beziehungsweise...
Ja.
Der hat ja keine...
Der Name von ihm steht da drauf.
Also, ich hatte bisher noch keines von den, der Bauerprodukten.
Ich hatte nur so Kleinkram immer.
Ich hatte Wärmeleitpaste und Flüssigmetalllegierung.
Ansonsten...
Ich wollte mir, ich wollte mir von ihm...
Was heißt von ihm?
Von der Firma, die den Namen benutzen darf, ja?
Von ihm den...
Dieses Köpftool für 8700K-CPUs damals kaufen.
Das gab's aber nicht.
Dann hab ich mir ein anderes bestellt.
Das ist halt so ein Tool, das braucht man genau einmal.
Und gut ist, wie hart die Anforderungen sind.
Du meinst die Anforderungen an die Mitarbeiter?
Oder du meinst, wie hart die Anforderungen sind, dass eine Hardware überhaupt durchgeht?
Also, da frage ich mich halt, bei Intel kann ja die Kontrolle nicht so geil gewesen sein.
Ach ja, und Schätke.
Ich hab, ich hab nochmal.
Noch, bevor wir anfangen mit den Stellenanzeigen.
Ist ja normal, dass ich fast eine Stunde labere, bevor es richtig losgeht.
Ich hab, ich hab nochmal eine Frage an euch.
Und zwar, vielleicht hat da einer eine chlorreiche Idee.
Ich wurde letztens, weil letztens bei mir an der Tür waren zwei Telekom-Scammer.
Weiß nicht, haben wir hier, genau, Paintschamp.
Zwei Telekom-Scammer.
Die haben geklingelt und haben, da bin ich an die Tür gegengesprächt, Anlage drangegangen.
Achso, ja, das...
Das, das, ehrlich gesagt, ich, ich frage mich auch, wie das gehen kann.
Gerade 2022 war ja so viel im Arsch.
Da frage ich mich, frage ich mich, ja, zumindest, ja, ich hatte zwei Telekom-Scammer an der Tür.
Die, die, ich bin an die, die haben geklingelt, ich bin an die Tür gegengespräch, Anlage gegangen, haben gesagt, ja, hier ist, was weiß ich, bla bla bla, von der Telekom.
Da hab ich gefragt, was will denn die Telekom?
Da meint, ja, bei ihnen wurde jetzt Glasfaser ausgebaut.
Und wir haben jetzt nur hier exklusiv.
Die neuen tollen Verträge, da hab ich mir schon gedacht, aha, Scammer am Start.
Als ich das gehört hab, wusste ich, das sind irgendwelche Scammer.
Und was heißt Scammer?
Es sind keine Scammer im eigentlichen Sinne, dass die dich komplett...
Die verkaufen dir schon Telekom-Verträge, aber das ist weder exklusiv noch sonst irgendwas.
Die haben auch, das sind auch irgendwelche Marketing- oder man kann man die Marketing-Vertriebsunternehmen, die von der Telekom beauftragen.
Also Scammer ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben, aber es wirkt schon etwas Scammy, Scammig, das Ganze, ja.
Zumindest.
Da haben die gesagt, ja, das wurde jetzt hier ausge...
Ranger Market, und die Firma heißt so, ja.
Das wurde jetzt hier aus...
Die wurde jetzt hier auf...
Wurde jetzt hier ausgebaut.
Und wir haben jetzt nur hier die tollen Verträge.
Da hab ich gesagt, ach, das ist ja nice.
Da kann ich doch auch mal online gucken, ob das jetzt im Verfügbarkeits-Check drinne steht.
Da wurde der schon misstrauisch an der Tür und meint so, äh, ja, das können sie machen.
Aber nur wir hier haben jetzt die exklusiv tollen neuen Verträge.
So, naja, passt schon.
Ich guck dann online.
Oh, ganz schnell wieder weg.
Dann hab ich online geguckt bei mir.
Weder Glasfaser ausgebaut, noch Ausbau geplant.
Aber...
Und jetzt kommen wir mal zu meiner Frage zurück.
Vielleicht ist ja da doch was dran, dass wenn die hier rum...
Ich frag mich allen Ernstes, was die mir verkauft hätten.
Die hätten mir wahrscheinlich einen stinknormalen DSL-VDSL-Anschluss verkauft.
Mit, wird später mal Glasfaser, sobald es das gibt, oder sowas.
Weiß auch immer.
Was auch immer die mir verkaufen.
Was auch immer die mir verkauft hätten, ja.
Ich bin ja froh, ich bin ja froh, dass ich, dass ich daheim gewesen bin, ja.
Stell dir grad vor, meine Mutter hier, wär, äh, Fenster im Erdgeschoss aufgemacht.
Und, und hätte dann jemand mit der Telekom-Jacke vor der, vor der Haustür stehen gesehen,
die hätte die wahrscheinlich reingelassen und hätte sich da sonst was erzählen lassen.
Zum Glück war ich da.
Ja, die, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Zumindest hab ich mir jetzt gedacht, vielleicht ist ja da insofern was dran.
Ähm, Aura, mein, Aura ist Uni-Wort des Jahres, wirklich?
Ich hoffe, die Tagesschau hat auch wieder so ein schönes Video, wo sie die Sachen vorliest.
Aura, Aura.
Ist Aura sowas wie Karma-Punkte?
VDSL ist auch irgendwie Glasfaser.
Wo ist denn VDSL, bitteschön, Glasfaser?
Das musst du mir jetzt einmal mal erklären.
Welcher Teil von VDSL soll Glasfaser sein?
Du meinst der Teil im Provider?
Der Backend, ja gut, der ist Glasfaser.
Ja, genau, ja, das ist Glas, das stimmt wohl.
Weil VDSL ist sowas von Oldschool-Kupfer, mehr Kupfer wird's, mehr Kupfer gibt's nicht.
Zumindest, um jetzt mal eigentlich auf die Sache zurückzukommen, die ich sagen wollte.
Ich hab mir gedacht, wenn die jetzt schon anfangen, hier die Leute mit Glasfaser-Sachen zu scammen,
vielleicht bauen die ja wirklich bald Glasfaser bei mir aus.
Und da hab ich, da bin ich bisschen, bisschen ins Grün.
Und da bin ich bisschen ins Übeln gekommen.
Wenn die bei mir Glasfaser ausbauen, dann wird das ja so laufen, so nach dem Motto, hier gibt's bald Glasfaser.
Sie können sich das jetzt ins Haus legen lassen.
Das kostet dann irgendwie 700 Euro oder sowas, mach ich natürlich sofort.
Sobald hier irgendwie einer vor der Tür steht und sagt, hier, wir haben einen Bagger, wir legen Ihnen Glasfaser,
sag ich, jawoll, hier, nimm mein Geld und fang an zu graben, Alter.
Ich lasse mir das sofort ins Haus legen.
Aber die legen das ja im Endeffekt quasi einfach nur von mir, im Endeffekt von dem Rohr.
Ja, in der Straße, gerade durch und dann kommt man bei mir im Keller raus.
So, und jetzt ist das Ding.
Jetzt hab ich mir, jetzt hab ich mir überlegt,
ich hab dann ein Glasfaserkabel im Keller hängen.
Stimmt, sind, stimmt so genau genommen natürlich nichts.
Ist kein Glasfaserkabel, was im Keller hängt, sondern ist irgend so ein,
wie, wie, wie auch immer man sich das nennt, so ein Glas, so eine Glasfaser-Endbox.
Aber, die, die hängt dann da unten im Keller.
Okay.
Und dann, und dann, was mache ich mit der im Keller?
Weil, sowohl, sowohl für Coax-Kabel, also Vodafone jetzt gerade,
als auch für Telefonkabel DSL,
habe ich mir damals vom Keller bei mir hier im Technikraum den ersten Stock legen lassen.
Was ich nicht habe ist, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so ungenutzte Glasfaser,
die da, Leitung, zumal das eh wahrscheinlich die falsche wäre.
Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie, meine Erfahrung, sind die da kulant, legen die ja so circa vier,
die legen mir das nicht vier Meter weiter bis zum Router.
Die müssten ja, also guck mal, die müssten bei mir, damit die,
damit die bei mir im Technikraum rauskommen, müssten die von der Straße in den Keller
und dann irgendwie durch zwei Decken in den ersten Stock, das machen die doch nicht.
Im Leben nicht, das kann ich vergessen, die legen das in den Keller und setzen da die Box hin und dann ist Ruhe.
Das nächste Ding ist mein Problem.
Die legen mir das, die legen mir doch, das machen die, Leute, die werden im Leben nicht kostenlos mir irgendwas rauflegen im ersten Stock
und
vor allem nicht so, wie ich das haben will.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So.
Und, also da habe ich mir, habe ich mir Folgendes, Folgendes überlegt.
Ich habe dann quasi diese, diese Abschluss, diese Abschlussbox im Keller hängen.
Wie auch immer, wie heißt denn dieses Ding? Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie das heißt?
So eine Abschlussbox habe ich dann, zumindest Glasfaserabschluss.
Von dort kann man dann zum Beispiel weiter mit, mit Glasfaser auf die, auf eine Fritzbox mit Modem oder auf Glasfasermodem oder sonst was.
So, dann habe ich mir, dann habe ich mir überlegt, was man machen könnte.
O, ja, O-N-T heißt das, nee, O-N-T heißt das, glaube ich, ja.
Ich glaube, O-N-T heißt das.
O-N-T, O-N-T-Box.
So, also was ich mir da jetzt überlegt habe, ist Folgendes.
Was in Keller geht.
Also, beziehungsweise was vom Keller geht.
Was vom Keller rausgeht, ist einmal Coax-Kabel.
Wenn ich dann kein Vodafone mehr brauchen sollte, könnte ich das vielleicht irgendwie verwenden, um damit, fragt mich nicht, irgendwie was weiterzuleihen.
Dann habe ich ein Netzwerkkabel.
K7-Netzwerkkabel sogar.
Das Problem ist nur, das Netzwerkkabel ist eigentlich schon in Use.
Und zwar folgendes.
Da liegt ein Netzwerkkabel.
Ursprünglich war von diesem Netzwerkkabel, das in der 8.
8 Adern drin im Netzwerkkabel.
Von diesen 8 Adern waren ursprünglich nur 2 Adern in Benutzung.
Und zwar für den Oldschool-Telefonanschluss.
2 Kupferadern.
Da war ursprünglich mal, als ich hier 2013 eingezogen bin, DSL dran.
Ich habe dann erkannt, aha, das ist ja ein ganz normales Netzwerkkabel.
Und mittlerweile habe ich dieses Netzwerkkabel zweckentfremdet.
Ich habe, ähm...
Die TAE-Dose oben einfach abgeschnitten und habe einen Netzwerkstecker selbst draufgekrimpt.
Unten im Keller auch.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
Und da hängt jetzt ein WLAN-Accesspoint dran, der per PoE versorgt wird.
Der synkt zwar nur mit 100 Mbit, aber das ist mir auch egal.
Reicht für WLAN.
100 Mbit plus PoE.
Da hängt ein WLAN-Accesspoint dran.
Also, was ich jetzt machen könnte, ist, ich könnte den WLAN-Accesspoint abmachen.
Nochmal neuen Stecker draufkrimpen und das als Gigabit-Kabel.
Und das geht wahrscheinlich auch hoch bis 10 Gigabit verwenden.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich von diesem Glasfaser-Endpunkt auf ganz normales, auf R45-Stecker komme.
Ich weiß nicht, ob so eine Ont-Box oder was auch immer so eine Abschlussbox,
ob die auf der einen Seite Glasfaser rein und auf der anderen Seite Netzwerk raus hat.
Das glaube ich.
Ehrlich gesagt eher nicht.
Weil du brauchst ja noch ein Glasfaser.
Du brauchst ja noch ein Modem im Endeffekt.
Also, wenn sie das hat, dann ist es, dann ist es, dann brauche ich irgendwo brauche ich doch noch ein Modem.
Für die, für die quasi, nennen wir es mal Einwahl.
Okay.
Also sprich, ich kann dann ganz normal das Netzwerkkabel.
Also heißt im Endeffekt, Glasfaser kommt raus im Keller.
Da hängt so eine Ont-Kiste dran.
Von dort kann man dann weitergehen per R45.
Ich stecke über ein normales Netzwerkkabel, zum Beispiel eine Fritzbox und die Fritzbox macht dann PPPoE.
Und das geht auch für Glasfaser-Stells, ja.
Das hört sich jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen nicht so stimmig an, aber ich glaube euch das mal.
So ist es.
Das würde, das würde funktionieren.
Das Problem dabei ist nur, wie bekomme ich da Netzwerk ins Keller?
Ah, das ist alles irgendwie kacke.
Okay, ist das, ist das ganz normales?
Ist das ganz normales, äh, Ethernet, was da drüber läuft?
Oder ist das irgendwie Spezialkram?
Weil, dann könnte ich ja einen Switch hinhängen, den ich, den ich halt einfach, sag ich, okay, Port, äh, Port 1 bis 7 ist ganz normal und Port 8 kriegt dann irgendwie einen extra WLAN.
Da wird der Switch quasi geteilt, ja.
Das geht, ja.
Ja, ja gut, dann, äh, dann wäre das, dann wäre...
Dann wäre das denkbar.
Da mache ich einen Switch unten im Keller.
Da, ich, ich, da kommt quasi dort das, ähm, Kabel dran, was dann hier im ersten Stock geht.
An das Normale kommt, äh, quasi, äh, WLAN-Nexus-Point dran.
Und an Port 8 oder so mache ich dann nur für die, nur für die Einwahl.
Ja, das macht eigentlich Sinn.
Ja, doch.
Ja, doch, das, äh, wenn, wenn das ganz normal ist.
Ja, das macht eigentlich Sinn.
Wenn das dann nicht ist, was diese On-Box da macht auf, auf, äh, auf diesem, auf dem Netzwerkkabel, dann, dann würde das so funktionieren, ja.
Da bräuchte ich unten quasi im Keller noch einen WLAN-fähigen Switch.
Hab ich sogar noch.
Ich hab hier noch ein paar Mikro-Tick-Dinger rumstehen.
Sogar hier welche mit 10 Gigabit, ähm, SFP-Plus-Interfaces.
Da kann ich sogar 10 Gigabit machen zwischen erstem Stock und Erdgeschoss.
Mach ich einfach einen, einen AR45, äh, SFP-Plus-Modul rein.
Hab ich sogar noch welche.
Steckt sogar, seh ich grad hier, steckt sogar schon eins im Switch drin.
Easy.
Eats.
Dann nehm ich einfach den Switch hier.
Ich hab hier so einen 8, 8-Port-Mikro-Tick-Switch.
Den hab ich eigentlich hier an meinem Bastel, Basteltisch stehen, wo wir schon öfters auch Zeug gelötet haben.
Da ist ein, äh, einmal steckt ein Direct-Attach-Kabel gerade drin und ein AR45, äh, SFP-Plus-Modul.
Der hat, der hat 8 Gigabit-Ports, 2 10 Gigabit-Ports.
Der ist doch optimal.
Genau für sowas gemacht.
Genau, ich frag diese Telekom-Leute an, da, da haben die bestimmt großartig Ahnung von.
Ja, dann, dann geht das doch.
Dann konfiguriere ich einfach Port 8 oder so als extra WLAN.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Okay, da haben wir aber schon, ach, ich ruf, seriously, ich ruf keine random Hotline an mit Leuten, die noch weniger Plan haben.
Aber das macht Sinn.
Ja, doch, das, dann ist das easy.
Da brauch ich einfach noch einen Switch im Keller.
An den Switch kommt dann, wie gehabt, der...
WLAN-Access-Point dran.
Also ich brauch quasi einen Trunk-Port.
Da kommt das 10 Gigabit-Kabel nach oben dran.
Dann wird unten ein Port konfiguriert als WLAN-Port.
Für den Access-Point.
Da brauch ich am besten einen Switch mit PoE.
Ein Port wird konfiguriert mit WLAN für diese ONT-Geschichte.
Ja, das klingt eigentlich ganz, ganz passend, ne?
Muss ich sagen.
Warum ist die Musik so laut?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Nice.
Da hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Eigentlich, ich wollte euch nochmal fragen, aber es hat sich doch schon gelohnt.
Der Chat ist wie immer high IQ.
Einfach way too smart, der Chat.
Ja, wird Zeit, sehe ich auch so.
So, dann lasst uns nochmal angucken.
Außer, dass Aura das Jugendwort des Jahres ist.
Schere.
Schere war dabei.
Nicht nur Aura++, sondern auch Intelligenzquotient++.
Das sind halt wieder die ganzen Boomer-Leute.
In Deutschland.
Die dann sagen, ach nee, mir reicht doch das, was wir haben.
Wir lassen bei uns ins Haus kein Glasfaser legen.
Genau der gleiche Shit, wie mein Opa damals mit dem Kabelanschluss.
Wollte er ja auch nicht.
Am Ende, als er in Rente war und viel Fernsehen geguckt hat, ne?
Hat er sich gewünscht, dass er Kabel im Haus hat.
Außer für ordentlichen Fernsehempfang.
Aber nee, das wollte er ja damals nicht.
Manchmal muss man halt echt etwas...
...vorausschauend gucken.
Genau, ich würde mir immer einen Glasfaseranschluss legen.
Auch wenn ich jetzt gar nicht vorhabe, ihn zu benutzen.
Es kann durchaus sein, wenn die vor der Tür stehen, dass ich sage, ey, weißt du was?
Leg rein.
Bezahl da auch die 700 Euro für.
Aber ich lasse erstmal Vodafone-mäßig, so wie es ist.
Ja.
Ja, wenn man Miete wohnt, ist das auch beschissener.
Da ist man auch auf Vermieter angewiesen.
Ja.
So, dann lasst uns nochmal gucken.
Was?
Möchte denn DHL und in Kombination mit SAP.
Wer hat das gepostet?
Savanka.
Willst du dich da bewerben?
Ich habe übrigens ein paar Sachen übersehen.
Kann man das hier aufmachen?
Alles klar.
So, Telekom...
Äh, nicht Telekom.
Passt.
Naja, es war alles mal früher die Post.
Also ist das doch gar nicht so falsch mit Telekom.
Wart mal...
Also...
Ist das tatsächlich das Geschäft, das sollte man immer noch machen?
Die Leute machen das schon immer in Zukunft.
Also das ist natürlich...
Das ist ja jetzt das Problem, wenn man dir dainder geht.
Also
Also das...
Das ist natürlich...
Das ist nicht so schlecht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig verstehe.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das macht man aber auch nicht.
Also wollte ich mal sagen.
Was?
Dein Unternehmen.
Dein Unternehmen?
Das ist doch...
Verständnischts.
Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Problem.
Aber ich kann es nicht anders beurteilen.
Ich kann es wirklich nicht beurteilen.
Ich bin kein Pro.
Ich bin ein Pro.
Wir sind nicht...
noch mal erzählen, weil es auch die Lizenz zum
Gelddrucken ist. Richtige
High IQ Move.
Ich muss nächste Woche eine Schulung auf der Arbeit
machen. Ich sage euch nicht von welcher Software, aber
wobei, das habe ich euch doch letztens erzählt.
Ich muss eine Schulung auf der Arbeit machen.
Sie findet übrigens hauptsächlich unter Windows statt.
Da habe ich jetzt schon richtig
Bock.
Ich muss eine Schulung für eine Software machen.
Und wisst ihr, warum ich die Schulung machen muss?
Weil der Hersteller
in seinen Lizenzbedingungen drinstehen
hat, wenn ihr diese Software von uns
einsetzt, dann müssen alle Anwender
oder Admins für diese Software
eine Schulung von uns gemacht haben, sonst
verstoßt ihr gegen die Lizenzbedingungen.
Es darf quasi nur geschultes Personal
an unsere Software ran.
Das ist wirklich die Lizenz
zum Gelddrucken, oder? Das ist eigentlich
die Best, das ist
Highest IQ.
Der Kopf, der platzt schon.
Das ist
wirklich, das ist schon
viel zu schlau.
So.
Und
ja, SAP
ist ja auch bekannt dafür, besonders
zu vorkommende Lizenzbedingungen zu haben.
Doch je nach Software ist das
durch, ich sag mal, es ist je nach Software
nicht unbedingt unüblich.
Das ist nicht unbedingt unüblich bei
vieler so Business Enterprise-Stellsoftware.
Aber ich find's trotzdem
Next Level Marketing
High IQ Move von denen.
So, zumindest, was will denn DHL haben? Sie will
einen SAP, also Lucian... Wenigstens geht's
schon mal hier richtig los.
Unter 90.000 Euro
macht's ein SAP-Solution-Architekt
in Bonn natürlich nett.
Das kann ich verstehen, wer sich mit dem Schrott
auseinandersetzt, hauptberuflich, und das
dann auch noch volle Ehe mit Überzeugung
und der muss viel Kohle verdienen, so freiwillig macht das keiner.
Also, die suchen jemand.
Achso, ja, ich frage
mal, wer, an denjenigen,
der die Stellenanzeige gepostet hat,
willst du dich dort bewerben? Ist das vielleicht, bist du
bei DHL? Sucht dir da jemand, oder
hast du es einfach nur so gefunden und interessiert dich?
Falls du überhaupt noch da bist.
Und eine halbe Stunde zwischendurch random Zeug
erzählt. Also, was
haben wir denn hier? Also, erste Mal,
erste Mal, muss ich das hier zumachen
und hier öffnen,
dass ich
das lesen kann. Sie suchen
einen SAP-Solution-Architekt
unbefristet
Vollzeit und Teilzeit ab 90.000
Euro. Ja, nice.
Natürlich, ja, nur Teilzeit.
Vollzeit
selbstgebildet.
Ja,
wir sind alle bestechlich, wir sind alle
bestechlich. Ich finde es ja immer
geil, wenn dann in manchen
Vorstellungsgesprächen gefragt wird,
und, warum wollen sie unbedingt zu uns?
Ja gut, ich will einen Job haben, dass ich
nicht unter der Brücke schlafen muss.
Aber das kannst du ja natürlich nicht sagen.
Da musst du sagen, ich liebe
die Herausforderung und möchte in einem
aufstrebenden Unternehmen, bla bla bla.
Wobei, glücklicherweise
war das bei meinem letzten Vorstellungsgespräch
nicht so. Mein letztes Vorstellungsgespräch
war echt nice. Die waren
relativ, wie soll man
das nennen,
die waren eigentlich relativ auf dem Boden
geblieben und haben
gar nicht angefangen, irgendwelchen Business
Enterprise Shit zu labern,
sondern so wie es ist.
Die haben sogar direkt im Vorstellungsgespräch
zugegeben, wir haben so
viele Server und so viele Systeme,
es vergeht eigentlich, also
wir haben zwar einen Duck und wir haben zwar so ein
automatisches
CRM-System, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, muss man auch
sagen, Hut ab, dass sie mir das im
Vorstellungsgespräch erzählt haben, ja.
Sie haben zwar so ein automatisiertes
CRM oder wie heißt das, ne,
CSM,
CMDB-System,
wo alle Server und so erfasst sind,
aber es vergeht trotzdem keine Woche
bei so vielen Systemen, wo nicht mal irgendwo was
gebaut wird und dann nirgendwo auftaucht.
CMDB, genau.
Ja, und das haben die sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch erzählt,
das fand ich nicht schlecht.
Kannst du was zu dem
Beruf IT Compliance Manager sagen?
Muss man da den Leuten sehr hart auf die Hände legen?
Muss man da auf die Eier gehen?
Ja.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was die da wie genau
wollen, aber ich arbeite bei einer
Versicherung und wir haben nicht einen
Compliance, wir haben eine komplette Compliance-Abteilung.
Mir fällt es enorm
schwer, ehrlich gesagt, zu definieren,
was das
überhaupt ist. Letztendlich geht es da
um Richtlinien einhalten.
Oftmals sind es ja auch staatliche Vorgaben
und Gesetze, die eingehalten
werden müssen und da ist die
Compliance-Leute-Abteilung
dafür da, dass ich nach
Möglichkeit alles daran halte.
Und die müssen auch, ja, aber du musst den Leuten
hart auf den Sack gehen. Ja, das ist quasi
der Beruf, ist Leuten hart auf den
Sack gehen.
Service Now Entwickler!
Das kenne ich.
Ich finde es nicht sonderlich toll, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe gerade überlegt, wie ich das verpacke.
Und weißt du,
was das Schlimmste an Service Now ist?
Die Suche ist einfach
abgrundtief Schrott.
Du kopierst, also
die Service Now Suche ist,
stellt euch vor, ihr habt
ein Ticket offen, ja,
in dem Ticket, in dem Ticket,
der Titel des Tickets ist, keine Ahnung,
Serveraufbau
2024.
So.
Das ist der Titel des Tickets.
Ihr nehmt den Titel des Tickets,
copy-pastet ihn
in die Suche von Service Now
und Service Now
findet als erstes
neue
Glasfaserleitungen für Rechenzentren,
in der Kleierstraße
in Frankfurt.
Und da habe ich gesagt, Moment, was?
Ich habe doch exakt
den Tickettitel in die Suche kopiert.
Warum ist das Ticket nicht, und auch viel
schlimmer, das Ticket, was du suchst,
taucht gar nicht in den Suchergebnissen auf,
obwohl 1 zu 1, du kannst es auch
quoten, ist auch egal, obwohl du 1 zu 1
diesen Titel von dem Ticket kopierst.
Also, ohne Scheiß, Leute, die Service Now
Suche ist eines der schlechtesten
Dinger, die ich je gesehen habe.
Das überhaupt Suche zu nennen, ist schon
zu viel.
Also, da ist die Suche von OneNote besser,
und OneNote ist auch schon Schrott,
was die Suche anbelangt.
Ja, genau das hier.
Ja, ja, die sind, die sehen immer alles so
glücklich aus auf diesen Bildern, ja.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie das System wirklich aussieht.
Ah, Bilderservice Now.
Ha! Ja, ja, doch.
Und man kann es ja, man kann es ja
ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, doch, so
sieht das aus, doch, so sieht das aus, genau so sieht das aus.
Man kann es ein bisschen customizen
vom Skin her, ja. Es sieht,
es sieht im Prinzip genauso
oldschool aus, wie es auch ist.
Ja, Incidents, bla, das ist
wirklich grausam.
Ja, auf, ich meine, auf Stockbildern
wirst du bezahlt, dafür glücklich zu sein.
Ey, wir wollten eigentlich eine Telekom-Stellenanzeige
gucken, MonkaS, Alter. So.
Ich habe sogar in der VM noch mal
so viele Tabs offen. Aber ja,
wie gesagt, ich, mit Geld lässt man sich natürlich
immer bestechen, so. Letztendlich arbeiten,
letztendlich ist es immer eine Kombination
aus, wie
sehr bestechen die dich, dass du bereit bist,
ähm,
das zu machen, was die von dir wollen, ja.
Und die hier
scheinen ja zumindest schon mal ganz gut zu bestechen.
Interessant wäre natürlich auch,
ob es die Kombination Teilzeit und
ab 90.000 Euro gibt.
Wenn du, wenn du der super
high-IQ-igste qualifizierte
SAP-Solution-Architekt bist und
sagst, ich will aber nur 80% arbeiten,
ob du dann auch 90.000
Euro bekommst?
Bei DHL, zumindest war es so.
Die Abteilung Application Domain
Management Finance & Billing.
Schon mal krasser Name. Ich wette mit euch,
die werden intern abgekürzt noch. Die heißen intern
wahrscheinlich eigentlich nur
ADMFB.
Wollen wir mal wetten? Intern
heißt das, der Mailverteiler
intern heißt ADMFB.
ADMFB
at DHLintern.de
So große Läden
kürzen unglaublich gerne ab.
Ich verstehe
bis heute, wie gesagt, ich arbeite ja auch in einem
großen Laden. Ich verstehe bis heute nicht,
warum, und davor habe ich auch in einem
großen Laden gearbeitet, warum
so große Unternehmen immer diesen
Abkürzungs-Tick
haben. Die müssen jeden Scheiß abkürzen.
Genau.
So, also.
Die Abteilung Application Domain Management Finance & Billing
steht für digitale Zukunft und Abrechnung
selbst. Okay.
Es geht im Prinzip. Immerhin,
das muss man DHL tatsächlich mal
hier zugute halten.
Die Selbstlobreisung hält sich
in Grenzen und es sind auch nur quasi,
es ist auch nur ein langer Satz zu
sich selbst und zu der Abteilung. Das finde ich vollkommen
in Ordnung. An dem Moment, es geht ja noch weiter.
Unsere Vision,
eine hochmoderne, leistungsstarke SAP
Billing Cloud Plattform.
Moment, wollen die, wollen die
eine eigene Cloud Plattform aufbauen oder
wollen die die SAP Cloud verwenden? Das verstehe
ich jetzt nicht so genau. Ja, das ist
irgendein Marketing Satz.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, wo wir gerade beim Thema Cloud sind,
wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass der
gesamte Storage von der
Apple Cloud von Google kommt?
Ist nicht so bekannt.
Aber wollte ich mal erwähnen gerade.
Apple kauft ihren kompletten Storage
bei Google. Also wahrscheinlich
läuft das dann.
Neben eurem
GCP Kubernetes Cluster, wenn ihr Glück
habt. Irgendwo steht dann das Storage
System, wo hauptsächlich Apple drauf ist.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass
die wahrscheinlich ein paar
Sonderkonditionen bekommen.
Und wahrscheinlich auch ein paar
mehr Möglichkeiten haben.
Was ist der Plan für das Wochenende,
Max? Das Wochenende ist Samstag 15 Uhr.
Ich bin am Streamsauen.
Und danach, also okay,
okay, ich kann es
dir sagen, ich kann es dir sagen.
Ich stream so jetzt.
Danach werde ich, wenn ich fertig Streamsauen
bin, werde ich
entweder versuchen noch eine Runde Diablo zu
grinden oder
irgendwas anderes kreiselgrindiges
zu spielen.
Bis heute Abend.
Dann
hau ich mir wahrscheinlich noch
ein halbes Hähnchen rein.
Guck ein bisschen Twitch oder Youtube
oder irgendwelche, mal gucken
was es so gibt.
Dann gehe ich pennen. Morgen früh mache ich
den Rechner an. Mach aufwachen,
stream bis mittags.
Dann esse ich
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Dann gehe ich eineinhalb Stunden rennen.
Und dann
mache ich, dann programmier ich wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen, weil das wollte ich schon seit Wochen
weitermachen, an meinem ESP32
weiter rum.
Ja. Und irgendwann gehe ich dann wieder
pennen und freue mich, dass wenn ich montags aufstehe
alle arbeiten gehen müssen und ich nicht.
Und dienstags gehe ich dann auf meine komische
Schulung
mit Windows-Rechnern und
dieser
Software.
Programmieren on- oder off-stream,
weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Ich esse doch nur Nudeln mit Lachs, wenn es die
auch schon am Samstag gab. Ja, gab es ja heute auch.
Es gab ja heute auch Nudeln
mit Lachs. Ne.
Ich habe gesagt, ich esse heute Abend
vielleicht noch ein halbes Hähnchen.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, ich habe heute Mittag, ach du hast
gedacht, ich habe heute Mittag das eine halbe
Hähnchen gegessen und esse heute Abend das andere
halbe Hähnchen. Ne. Am Mittag habe ich
Nudeln mit Lachs gegessen.
Das ist quasi meine DPS-Rotation.
Also lass es aber hier mal. Okay.
Also das, die DHL
findet sich selbst geil, das habe ich verstanden.
Aber ich finde das durchaus
in Ordnung geschrieben und das liest
sich natürlich super Business Enterprise mäßig,
aber schon okay. Warum DHL Group?
Deine Vorteile bei uns, attraktive Vergütung,
langfristige Sicherheit, faire
Gehaltsstrukturen, ein sicherer Arbeitsplatz und Homeoffice
das finde ich schon mal gut, dass das gleich mit drinsteht.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt auch, was sie da
hinschreiben.
Ein Stellenanzeigen-Stream wäre nicht
komplett, wenn ich euch zumindest jetzt mal 30 Sekunden
die Story nicht zum x-ten Mal erzähle
von meinem Kollege.
Ein Kollege von mir hat sich beworben,
bei einem Unternehmen, die haben genau das gleiche
geschrieben.
Die suchen jemand, für
Position X bezahlt wird
ab 90.000 Euro.
Oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung stand da.
90.000 Euro stand auf jeden Fall da.
Hat er sich dort beworben
und
die haben sich super verstanden.
Es wurde auch nochmal bestätigt,
ja genau so jemand suchen wir
und 90.000 Euro ist
auch so das, was wir anpeilen.
Dann hat er mit denen noch ein
Vorstellungsgespräch gehabt und sogar mit
denen so ein
Szenario durchgespielt.
Also manche Unternehmen machen ja gerne
in
dem Bewerbungsprozess so
wir spielen jetzt mal ein Support-Szenario
durch oder sowas.
Kundensystem geht kaputt,
es kommt ein Ticket rein,
wie reagieren sie dann und was machen sie dann
und sowas. Sogar das hat er mit denen gemacht.
So.
Danach ging es darum, da waren sie sich
super einig und haben sich gefreut und alles gut
und er hat sogar schon gesagt, ey Jungs
auf geht's,
finde ich super, mache ich bei euch.
Und die haben auch gesagt, super, passt alles.
Ah, es gibt
da aber so ein kleines Problem.
Das Budget
für die Seniorstelle wurde nicht genehmigt.
Jetzt wollen
wir ihnen nur 70.000 Euro bezahlen.
Da hat mein Kollege natürlich gesagt,
ja gut, dann will ich nicht mehr und tschüss.
Ich weiß halt echt nicht,
was mit denen los ist.
Ich meine, denken die ernsthaft,
dass dann irgendjemand sagt,
geil, ihr habt mich schon beschissen,
bevor ich überhaupt angefangen
habe bei euch. Ja, jetzt mache
ich das erst recht. Oder wie?
Oder was denken die sich dabei?
Oder denken die sich dabei, der Bewerber hat
schon so viel Zeit reingelegt. Ich rede jetzt nicht
von DHL, by the way.
Das ist nur, weil da was von 90.000 steht.
Nichts mit DHL, nur weil ich das gerade erzähle.
War auch eine ganz andere Firma.
Oder denken sie sich, ah, vielleicht,
der Bewerber hat da schon so viel Zeit reingesteckt
und fand uns so toll, der macht das trotzdem
auch für 15.000, 20.000 Euro weniger.
Also,
also ich hoffe nur,
die schreiben es hier halt nicht einfach rein, sondern
die machen das auch wirklich.
Ja gut, also was wollen sie denn eigentlich haben?
Attraktive Vergütung, also
wenn das stimmt,
kann man das denke ich durchaus sagen.
So alles ab 90.000 Euro würde ich sagen,
geht durchaus
als attraktive Vergütung durch.
Muss aber sagen,
die letzten Jahre
ist die ganze Sache ganz schön gestiegen.
90.000 Euro heute sind nicht 90.000 Euro
vor drei, vier, zwei,
drei, vier Jahren.
Aber trotzdem würde ich sagen,
ab 90.000 Euro geht attraktive Vergütung.
Kann man das durchaus schreiben.
Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten, gut, dass es drinsteht.
Ist übrigens nach
Nachfrage Homeoffice auf Verhandlungsbasis
mit dem Chef, aber viele machen meinen Max
einen Tag Homeoffice und den Rest
das finde ich gut.
Dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, ist eine ähnliche Regelung.
Es gibt eine Betriebsvereinbarung
mit dem Betriebsrat, aber letztendlich
ist es, sagen wir mal,
Verhandlungssache ist jetzt ein bisschen,
klingt jetzt ein bisschen härter als es ist.
Letztendlich hat mein Chef auch gesagt,
das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Wir haben bei uns im Team
die Regelung, du kannst
quasi einen Tag die Woche ins Büro,
also wenn du im Durchschnitt einen Tag die Woche im Büro warst
und kannst den Rest
Homeoffice machen. Weiß ich nicht,
wie gesagt, ich habe mich ja da nicht beworben.
Also, so wie er mir das erzählt hat,
war die Sache danach vorbei, als sie gesagt haben,
das gibt die Seniorposition nicht. Da habe ich gesagt,
da habe ich keinen Bock.
Work-Life-Balance und Flexibilität. Flexibel und
familienfreundliche Arbeitszeiten. Transparente
Arbeitszeiterfassung und Freizeit. Ja,
ja gut, ich meine,
was sollen sie denn auch sonst schreiben?
Modernste Technologien. Arbeiten mit
State-of-the-Art-Technologien und
profitieren von Neues.
Alter,
wie vage möchte man etwas schreiben?
Profitiere von den neuesten Methoden
und Ansätzen in der IT-Architektur.
Was darf man sich darunter vorstellen?
Gezielte Weiterentwicklung,
Vielfalt und Inklusion, Leben,
ja gut, es ist ja auch für eindeutig
männlich-weiß-deutsch, verstehe ich.
Erstklassige Sozialleistungen.
Profitiere von betrieblichen
Alphabetical-Optionen, umfassenden
Familienservice. Gut, liest sich alles
relativ Standard, aber
attraktive Vergütung würde mir alleine
schon mal reichen.
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich das hier gerade lese,
es gibt bei mir auf der
Arbeit, da haben die letztens groß Werbung
für gemacht, dass das jetzt neu ist,
bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit
Workation zu beantragen.
Allerdings nur innerhalb
von der EU und auch nicht
länger als
auch nicht länger als
zwei Monate, ein Monat,
ein Monat? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
weil danach musst du
Steuern in dem anderen Land bezahlen.
Was ist Workation?
Das ist sehr nice.
Von der Idee her.
Okay, ich gebe zu, das war eine doofe Erklärung.
Damit ist gemeint,
dass du quasi Urlaub und Arbeiten
verbindest. Du fährst zum Beispiel
nach Spanien,
guckst, dass du dort
in
einer Wohnanlage oder in einem Häuschen
bist mit ordentlich Internetversorgung,
du arbeitest vormittags
ganz normal,
aber halt aus Spanien
und
mittags, nachmittags,
wenn du fertig mit der Arbeit bist,
klappst du den Laptop zu und gehst an den Strand.
Du verbindest quasi Arbeit mit Urlaub.
Da haben die jetzt ein bisschen Werbung
für gemacht bei uns,
dass sie das jetzt auch
supporten,
aber nur bis zu einer gewissen Zeit,
weil sonst gibt es steuerliche Probleme.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ein Monat ist vollkommen nice.
Ja, ist mega.
Das ist richtig nice.
Funktioniert bei euch das Konzept Slacktime?
Was ist das?
Also, wenn du mehrere Themen neben deinem Projekt arbeiten darfst,
die du selbst verbleibst.
Bei mir ist es eher so, ich habe so viel Daily-Krempel,
der an bestehenden Services,
um den ich mich kümmern muss,
Projekt ist eigentlich die kleinste
Zeit.
Also Projekt ist so ein Drittel von meiner Zeit ungefähr.
Ich habe mir das tatsächlich überlegt,
ob ich nicht nächstes Jahr mal nach Spanien fahre.
Am liebsten würde ich ja
nach Gran Canaria
oder auf die Kanaren, aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher,
ob das...
Das ist zwar Spanien und EU, aber das hat so eine Sonderregelung.
Vielleicht fahre ich auch nach Mallorca,
da kann man super Fahrrad fahren.
Also ich habe mir ernsthaft überlegt,
das zu machen, nächstes Jahr.
Allerdings nicht allein,
sondern mit meinem Lieblingskolleg
zusammen,
der mit dem ich auch beim alten Arbeitgeber war
und jetzt quasi zum Neuen gewechselt bin.
Der hätte auch Bock drauf.
Weil das glaube ich
die einzige Möglichkeit ist,
wo er seiner Frau erklären kann,
warum er jetzt mal ein paar Wochen weg ist.
Dann sagt er, ja gut, das ist ja auch...
Kein Urlaub, das ist ja quasi so wie Arbeiten.
Kriegt man die Wohnung gestellt?
Nein, nein, das musst du selbst bezahlen.
Kommt der Friseur mit?
Nee, eher nicht.
Aber das ist nice, wenn ich mit meinem Kollegen dahin fahre,
weil, erstens kenne ich den schon lange
und verstehe mich mit dem auch gut,
der arbeitet halt beim gleichen Laden.
Zwar nicht exakt dem gleichen Team, aber das passt halt, ja.
Wir könnten, wir würden uns dann einfach morgens
jeder, jeder hinsetzen,
Notebook,
unsere siebeneinhalb Stunden arbeiten
und nachmittags gehen wir eine Runde
rennen, Fahrrad fahren und gucken uns die
Sache dort an, also...
Ich fände das schon eine coole Sache.
Ja, und das ist die einzige Chance,
die er für sowas hat, mit der Ausrede.
Der wird dann wahrscheinlich erzählen,
er muss nach Spanien arbeiten.
Was ja nicht gelogen ist.
Er muss ja auch nach Spanien arbeiten.
Wer für uns kocht...
Naja, das ist die Frage, wo wir hingehen, ja.
Entweder gehen wir irgendwo hin, wo es halt
Essen inklusiv gibt,
wo es halt dabei ist, ja.
Aber ich denke mal, in Spanien gibt es auch
Supermärkte und was zu essen.
Und ganz ehrlich, es gibt in Spanien sicherlich auch
an jeder Ecke irgendwelche Restaurants,
wo es wahrscheinlich günstiger und besser ist als bei uns.
Das ist aber zusätzlich...
Jaja, das ist kein Urlaub, das ist kein Urlaub.
Du machst ja quasi mobiles Arbeiten
nur aus dem Ausland.
Das ist kein Urlaub, du machst da ganz normale
Arbeitszeit da am Tag.
Nur, dass du danach nicht
Homeoffice-mäßig aufstehst und sagst,
so, ich bin jetzt fertig arbeiten,
es ist 15.30 Uhr und guckst raus
und stellst fest, ah scheiß Wetter, es pisst und es ist kalt.
Sondern du bist, keine Ahnung,
irgendwie in Griechenland oder in Spanien
oder sonst wo und stehst
15.30 Uhr auf, bist fertig arbeiten,
sagst dir, ah nice, schönes Wetter, kommen wir nochmal raus.
Oder sich nochmal irgendwie ans Meer legen
oder sonst was. Das ist schon nice, ja.
Und ich weiß, also ich kann mir auch durchaus vorstellen,
eine Firma unterstützt das ja nicht
rein aus,
ja, wie soll man sagen, aus
reiner Nächstenliebe. Da gibt es bestimmt
Untersuchungen zu, dann
eben Griechenland.
Griechenland nach Mykonos
wollte ich schon immer mal.
Die unterstützen das,
es gibt garantiert auch,
aber da ist bestimmt auch teuer,
es gibt garantiert auch Studien zu,
dass das einfach dafür sorgt, dass langfristig
die Leute entspannter, ausgeglichener
und weniger krank sind und sowas.
Die machen das ja alles nicht immer aus reiner Nächstenliebe,
ja.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn man schon in einem Job arbeitet,
wo das geht, weil ob ich
jetzt bei mir daheim am Rechner sitze, in der Firma am
Rechner sitze oder in Spanien am Rechner sitze,
für 90% oder für 99%
der Sachen ist das vollkommen egal.
So. Aber eigentlich
waren wir immer noch bei der Telekom, äh,
bei DHL, ich komm immer noch ganz so...
So, also.
SAP Solution Architekt, was wollen wir sagen?
Gestaltest du cloudbasierte SAP
Lösungen zu unterstützenden... Das war ja klar.
Was ich noch nicht ganz verstanden hab, ist die,
wollen die, dass man quasi
dort... Was genau,
was genau suchen die eigentlich?
Suchen die jemand, der SAP Software
in irgendeiner Cloud betreiben kann?
Wollen die gar
so eine eigene SAP
Cloud Sachen aufbauen?
Oder wollen die Sachen in der SAP
Cloud nutzen?
Das sind ja drei komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, ja.
Also man könnte sagen, okay, wir wollen bei Azure,
wir wollen beispielsweise unsere SAP Software
jetzt äh, verteilt in Azure laufen
lassen. Wär eine Sache.
Dann ist die nächste Sache, ja, wir
wollen eigentlich unsere Software gar nicht
mehr selbst betreiben, sondern bei SAP, in der SAP
Cloud laufen lassen.
Ja, und das dritte wär, wir wollen
sogar selbst eine, ja, sagen wir mal so
Cloud verteilte
ähm,
Architektur aufbauen, auf der wir dann
unsere SAP laufen lassen.
Also so genau weiß man's jetzt nicht so.
Das sind ja schon mal zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe, ne? Berätst du
Fachbereiche und Realisierungs-
Realisierungspartner?
Das ist ein Business Enterprise
Wort. Was genau sind
Realisierungspartner?
Ich hab
keine Ahnung. BWLer.
Ja, das hört sich alles sehr BWL-mäßig an.
Bewertest du Anforderungen und
stimmst sie auf die Gestaltung? Okay, bla bla.
Analyse optimierst du bestimmte SAP Systeme
und Prozesse?
Schulz unterstützt du Anwender IT Teams?
Okay.
Das ist wenig, das hat wenig mit
So viel mit
Technik hat das jetzt gar nicht mal zu tun, oder?
Ich weiß immer noch nicht
genau, was die eigentlich wollen.
Außer, dass du langjährige Erfahrung haben sollst.
Tiefgreifende Kenntnisse in mindestens
einem SAP Modul.
SAP SD oder SAP Brim?
SAP H- Das kenn ich!
Das ist das einzige, was mir was sagt von der
Abkürzung.
Das heißt doch jetzt gar nicht mehr so.
Das wurde doch jetzt umbenannt. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen. In was?
Das heißt jetzt anders.
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Irgendwas hat
SAP erst letztens umbenannt.
Einschlägige
Erfahrungen im Projekt?
Teilprojektleitung?
Ne, ich glaube das haben die nicht so geschrieben, dass
sie nicht viel bezahlen müssen. Die bezahlen ja schon mal nicht schlecht für.
Die wollen damit sagen, dass du
Projektleitung und Teil über Projektleitung
nimmst.
Fundiertes Wissen von Architekturprinzipien
und Methoden im Softwareentwicklungsprozessen.
Aha.
Daily Scrum ohne Hinsetzen.
Ausgeprägte Analysekonzepte
Also, ehrlich
gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung von SAP, muss
ich dazu sagen. Ich habe die Stellenanzeige gelesen
und ich verstehe immer nicht so hundertprozentig,
was die jetzt eigentlich haben wollen.
Die wollen einen Projektleiter
für neues...
Keine Ahnung, also...
Ich glaube aber, dass DHL
prinzipiell kein schlechter Arbeitgeber ist.
Also so genau
checke ich es nicht. Was aber durchaus sein
kann, dass das sehr...
wenig Technik und Business Enterprise
Sprache ist. Aber eins muss man
schon mal sagen, wie gesagt, ich glaube DHL ist kein
schlechter Arbeitgeber. Und wenn das hier
stimmt, kann man sich ja mal
bestechen lassen, ja. Also aus...
Also man... sich zumindest das Ganze angucken,
wenn man auf sowas Bock hat. Warum
nicht? Ja.
Ich kann damit wenig anfangen, sag ich dir
ehrlich. Zu abstrakt alles.
Wen haben wir hier als nächstes?
GKVI
Unternehmensynergien.
Ist derjenige, der das gepostet hat, noch da? Ich bin so lahm.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Irgendwas mit Puppet hier. Puppet
Konfigurationsmanager. Ich find's schon mal
cool, dass es überhaupt noch Leute gibt, die Puppet
verwenden. Falls
jemand nicht weiß, was Puppet ist, wovon ich mal
ausgehe, weil die wenigsten Leute haben davon gehört,
das ist quasi sowas
wie Ansible, nur älter.
Und
anders.
Hat ein paar coole Sachen, ja.
Zum Beispiel kannst du in Puppet
nen Tri-Run machen. Richtig echten Tri-Run.
Also da nennt sich das
No-Op-Run.
Das geht ja in Ansible so direkt out of the box
nicht.
Aber es ist halt bei weitem nicht so verbreitet
wie Ansible und
auch...
Ich finde auch komplizierter als Ansible.
Puppet ist teilweise das Problem. Weiß gar nicht in welcher
Reihenfolge was ausgeführt
wird und so.
Was würdest du empfehlen? Ansible, Puppet
oder PowerShell?
Ich würde empfehlen Ansible und PowerShell.
Weil Puppet und Ansible kann man gut
vergleichen. Da würde ich Ansible
empfehlen, allein schon aus Grund der Verbreitung
und dass es sehr easy ist einzusteigen.
PowerShell ist
würde ich sagen, was das ganze unterstützen
kann. Du kannst ja auch durchaus
sagen, okay,
du benutzt Ansible zum Verwalten von allen deinen
Servern, aber wenn du auf
Windows System was konfigurieren möchtest,
dann schmeißt du im Endeffekt dort
ein PowerShell-Skript an, was du allerdings mit Ansible
verteilen kannst und starten kannst.
Also ich würde die zwei Sachen, die kann
man schon ziemlich direkt miteinander vergleichen
und vorbeien würde ich, gibt es ja noch mehr
Ansible, Puppet, Chef,
SoulStack, CFEngine, falls
einer mal Glück hatte, was mit CFEngine machen zu dürfen,
gibt es ein paar solcher Konfigurationstools.
Terraform nicht, Terraform ist wieder
was ganz was anderes, auch wenn es
ein bisschen Überschneidungen dazu hat. Es gibt nämlich online
immer die Diskussion, was soll ich
nehmen, Ansible oder Terraform?
Die Frage ist eigentlich verkehrt, weil
die Tools haben zwar minimale Überschneidungen,
aber ansonsten ist Ansible und Terraform
also komplett
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Aber Ansible und Puppet kann man gut vergleichen.
Und dafür würde ich eindeutig sagen,
nehm Ansible und für Windows-Automatisierung,
um dort irgendwas zu konfigurieren,
dann nimm PowerShell.
Und du kannst
ohne Probleme wunderbar Ansible und PowerShell
verbinden. Wobei ich nicht weiß, wie gut
sich Ansible für Windows eignet. Ich kann dir
nur sagen, wir haben mal beim alten Arbeitgeber
Puppet plus Windows probiert und das war
Schrott. Ist aber auch schon ewig her.
Ansible und Windows
weiß ich nicht, wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich würd mal drauf tippen, es geht, aber
Freudensprünge macht man damit wahrscheinlich nicht.
Hältst du es für sinnvoll, sich Angebote
auf LinkedIn und Xing genauer
anzusehen?
Also auf LinkedIn
jetzt gerade auf Xing, keine Ahnung,
aber gerade auf LinkedIn hast du ja
gefühlt die ganzen Headhunter-Azubis
und Neueinsteiger dürfen erstmal random
alle Leute anschreiben.
Also ich würd mir da nicht alles
angucken.
Ich bin aber auch kein großer Xing Benutzer, äh
LinkedIn Benutzer, also
also hier mein
LinkedIn-Profil.
Warum gibt es da eigentlich Fake...
Es gibt Faker von mir.
Das bin ich alles nicht.
Wie, haben die mein...
Nein, das ist der Echte.
Alter!
Warum gibt es so viele Fakes?
Warum gibt es so viele Fakes, Mann?
Das ist der Originale hier.
Das bin ich.
Also ich
in Anführungsstrichen,
ich hab den Account nicht mal mehr.
Ich hab den Login verloren mittlerweile sogar dazu.
Das ist der einzige LinkedIn-Account,
den ich habe, ja.
Ich wundere mich übrigens, dass das noch keinem aufgefallen ist,
dass das kein echtes, wüstendes
Enterprise-Foto ist.
Da folgen mir irgendwelche random Recruiter wahrscheinlich.
Also sich da alles
anzugucken halte ich nicht für sinnvoll.
Ich gehe davon aus, wenn man in diesem LinkedIn-Game
drin ist, dass man dann auch ein gewisses
Gefühl dafür entwickelt,
welche Anfragen sich lohnen, sich näher
anzugucken und welche nicht.
So, also, jetzt wollen wir uns das hier mal angucken.
Puppet-Konfigurationsmanager...
Achso, ich wollte Puppet euch ja mal zeigen.
Puppet Labs heißen die, glaube ich.
Ok, die gibt es
immer noch.
Ich zeige euch mal ein Example.
Manage...
Manage Pseudo-Privileges. Ok.
Das geht nämlich in Puppet, glaube ich,
ganz schön. Guck mal, Puppet hat
mittlerweile einen ordentlichen Package-Manager.
Ja, so sieht eine Puppet-
Konfig aus. Schön
ist was anderes, ja.
Ach, wurden die aufgekauft, oder was?
Recall ist mit dem neuen Update
jetzt automatisch enabled.
Es ist genau das
gekommen, was ich gesagt habe, oder?
In deaktiviertem Zustand
ausgeliefert. Ist das so?
50 GB!
Alter, was ist mit denen los?
Ach, geil. Die fucken mich so
ab, Alter. Ich sagte euch, nächstes Jahr ist das
ja das Linux-Desktop.
I3 kommt drauf an, ob
X oder Wayland.
Ok, also.
Was haben wir hier? Sie suchen einen
Puppet-Konfigurations-Manager und
Automatisierungs-Spezialist.
Ja, vor zwei Jahren wäre das eine Stelle gewesen,
wo ich gesagt hätte, ey, das interessiert mich.
Ich kenne mich mit Puppet aus.
Automatisierungs-Stells,
Verskriptungs-Krams ist genau meins.
Allerdings muss ich sagen,
wirklich Bock auf Puppet habe ich nicht mehr.
Linux und Firefox, ja, was anderes
bleibt dir ja gar nicht mehr übrig mittlerweile.
Der digitale Wandel und
veränderte Kundenbedürftigkeit,
bla bla bla.
Ok.
Zur Verstärkung unseres Teams suchen wir einen Puppet-Konfigurations-Manager
und Automatisierungs-Spezialist.
Ihre Aufgaben. Methodischer
Ansprechpartner für interne Kunden.
Methodischer
Ansprechpartner.
Ich frag mich immer, wer sich diese Formulierung
ausdenkt und ob es
Leute gibt, die das lesen und sofort
wissen, was gemeint ist.
Was versteht ihr unter einem
methodischer Ansprechpartner?
Was soll das sein?
Wir fragen mal ChatGPT.
Was ist ein...
Oh, ChatGPT labert
wieder ewig rum, Mann.
Ein methodischer Ansprechpartner
ist in der Regel eine Person, die als
Berater oder Koordinator
in Bezug auf bestimmte Methoden oder
Vorgehensweisen fungiert. Danke ChatGPT,
jetzt bin ich viel schlauer.
Diese Rolle findet man häufig in Bildungs-
der methodisch anbietet
Unterstützung, Schulung und Ressourcen.
Okay, im Prinzip jemand, um es mal auf
Deutsch zu sagen, jemand, der sich mit dem
Thema auskennt, den man dazu fragen kann.
Betreuung des Beauftragungsprozesses
im Rahmen des internen
ITSM-Tools inklusive Auftragsklärung.
Whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
Beratung von internen Kunden zur
Basis-OS-Konfiguration.
Okay,
das mag
durchaus... Welche Betriebssysteme
geht es denn? Ich hoffe mal
Linux, weil Puppet unter
Windows ist ein bisschen Painstamp.
Aber da unten kommt noch ein bisschen was, ja.
Unterstützung internen Kunden bei der
Verwendung der Puppet
Betriebs... Der Puppet
Betriebswerkzeugen.
Ich kenne mich mit
Bindestrichregeln nicht so aus, aber
ich bin mir relativ sicher,
das ist falsch.
PE-Konsole Puppet Bolt.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Ist ja schon ein paar Jahre her, wo ich Puppet
gemacht habe. Puppet Bolt.
Das ist quasi AWX
oder sowas.
Das ist quasi Puppet-Sachen
per Command-Line ausrollen oder so.
GitLab. Okay. Abstimmung der
Schnittstelleübergabe-Verantwortlichkeiten
bei Konfiguration im OS
mit Providern. Man kann
sich grob denken, was sie meinen.
Ich persönlich mag
Stellenanzeigen, die man liest und auch
versteht, was die eigentlich von einem wollen.
Bei Konfiguration im OS
mit Providern. Was soll
das eigentlich genau bedeuten?
Also ich sag mal so,
so wie ich das verstehe. Ja, Business Enterprise
Deutsch. Es gibt
einmal
Konfiguration im Betriebssystem
und es gibt Leute, die wollen dort
irgendwie, die stellen irgendwas bereit.
So und jetzt brauchen die eine Schnittstelle
und das ist dann quasi der
Automation
Spezialist zwischen
den OS Leuten und den Leuten, die
irgendwelche Software anbieten, die auf dem
OS läuft.
Und das musst du dann vermitteln
dazwischen oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Also das ist ein Satz.
Man versteht es nicht wirklich.
Oder ist euch klar, nachdem ihr den Satz
gelesen habt, was die eigentlich damit wollen?
Pflege und Betrieb der Puppet-Repositories.
Ja, das macht wenigstens Sinn.
Wenn man einen Puppet-Spezialist sucht.
Für die eingesetzten Betriebssysteme.
Windows, SUSE, Red Hat und Verfahren.
Zipper!
Oh!
SUSE! Alter!
Moment! Moment!
Ich find...
Zipper!
Na gut. Was willst du machen, wenn du SUSE verwendest?
Da kommst du nicht drum herum.
Früher hattest du ja Dings verwendest.
JAST!
Wobei JAST ist eher grafisches
GUI, ne?
Für Config und Zipper ist der Package Manager
Nougat.
Also gibt's da dort net Zeug.
Okay.
Monitoring, Betrieb und Pflege der Puppet-Infrastruktur.
Ja gut.
Eine Sache, das passt ja noch irgendwie.
Steht doch schon im Titel.
Primary Replica Compiler Code Deployment
für Produktion und Test.
Entwicklung, Dokumentation und Pflege...
Schon wieder so
Kack-Noobs am Start, Alter.
Einfach fehlerfreie Sachen entwickeln.
Dann braucht man keine Dokumentation. Easy.
Entwicklung, Dokumentation und Pflege
der aktuell im Einsatz befindet.
Puppet-Module und Puppet-Facts.
Facts? Das weiß ich noch, was das sind.
Was das ist.
Facts, das sind quasi so
Informationen über die einzelnen Server.
Also es gibt quasi so ein Fact
Betriebssystem und das
in diesem Betriebssystem Fact
steht dann immer drinnen, auf welchem OS
man sich befindet. Also Puppet kann
diese Facts benutzen.
Im Prinzip sind das
globale Variablen, so kann man sich das
bei Puppet vorstellen. Da heißt es nur Facts.
Du kannst dann quasi sagen
If OS gleich gleich
Linux
und dieses OS
ist dann halt ein Fact.
In Puppet
Sprache.
Und man kann auch Custom Facts bauen.
Wo man dann wiederum
in den Puppet Source Code
drauf zugreifen kann.
Im Prinzip sind das so eine Art globale Variablen,
die halt je nachdem auf welchem
System es ausgeführt wird, anders
sein können.
Zulieferer von Ist-Daten.
Achso, also wie es aktuell
aussieht. Ja, okay.
Bezeugung und Pflege von Puppet Rollen.
Okay, alles klar.
Das ist übrigens, by the way,
keine Vorgabe
in Puppet. Also dass man quasi
Module baut und Rollen verwendet.
Das ist eine reine Custom
Konfigurationssache.
Du kannst auch einfach alles in eine große Datei
schreiben. Beschreibung der
Arbeitsweise und Richtlinien für die Puppet Entwicklung.
Da hätte ich jetzt mal drauf
gehofft zumindest, dass es sowas schon
gibt, wenn die Puppet im Einsatz
haben. Sonst wird das wild.
Stell dir mal vor, die
haben ihre gesamten Sachen mit Puppet aufgebaut
und du kommst jetzt rein und
sollst als Neuer erstmal die Arbeitsweise
richtig beschreiben. Easy.
Erstellen, warten und testen
von Automatisierungslösungen zur
Effizienzsteigerung.
RPA.
Ich hab... Es gibt...
Kann man die Sachen einfach mal
aufhören?
Was ist RPA?
Public Process Automation.
Meinen die das damit?
Und wenn ja,
inwieweit... Keine Ahnung.
Der alte Puppet-Typ hat wahrscheinlich gekündigt.
Könnte man reininterpretieren.
Ihr Profil.
Okay, übliche Sache. Mehrjährige
praktische Erfahrungen in den Themen
Linux, Puppets,
Puppet Coding und Shit.
Grundlegende
Kenntnisse in den Themen...
Ruby. Endlich mal einer der Ruby verwendet.
Gut, Puppet muss man wissen.
Puppet ist in Ruby programmiert.
So alt ist das schon.
PowerShell. Oh, das heißt wir
wollen auch Windows Zeug damit machen.
Shell-Programmierung. Python
Podman-Container.
Warum Pod... Achso,
ja gut. Podman, weil
RedHat stellt's.
UiPath.
Was des? AI at Work.
The Business Automation Platform Leader.
In...
Aha. Das ist ein
Tool für RPA.
Siehst du mal.
Das ist richtig Bleeding Edge Technologie hier.
Ich glaube ich bin ziemlich outdated,
overrated oder? Der Chat weiß das so sofort.
Ich hab davon noch nie was gehört.
Was ist
RPA? Na, wie? Weißt du
nicht was RPA ist?
RPA ist Robotic Process
Automation. Ich wusste das bis eben auch nicht.
UiPath ist für End-to-End
Tests. Also sowas
wie Playwright oder
sowas wie Selenium früher
oder Playwright oder
Puppeteer, so quasi.
Ich skripte einen Webbrowser.
Ich auch nicht, aber der Chat
sagt, das ist das. Und wenn der Chat das sagt,
wir wissen ja alle, also der Chat kann ja prinzipiell
nie Mist erzählen.
Hat der Chat schon einmal Mist erzählt.
Eigenständige und zielorientierte
...
Wir bieten
eine spannende Aufgabe in einem Zukunftsthema.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung, Puppet
ist nicht wirklich ein Zukunftsthema.
Puppet ist ziemlich oldschool
outdated Zeug.
Die Welt verwendet heute Ansible und du findest kaum
Leute, die sich noch mit Puppet auskennen.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach eine Sackgasse,
jetzt Puppets zu lernen.
Und in Zukunft wirst du solche
klassischen Automatisierungen eh
zunehmend weniger brauchen,
umso mehr
stateless
Cloud-Infrastruktur du hast.
Was bei vielen das Ziel
ist. Du bist ein Puppet-Fan
geworden. Warum?
Ich kenne beides.
Ich habe früher viel Puppet gemacht,
jetzt nur noch Ansible.
Mir fällt eine Sache ein, die wirklich ein Vorteil
von Puppet ist vs. Ansible.
Eine Sache fällt mir so spontan ein
und ist auch ein großer Vorteil von Puppet.
Der riesige Vorteil von Ansible ist,
die ganze Welt verwendet Ansible.
Du findest für alles Ansible-Module,
du findest Leute, die sich damit auskennen
und es ist easy einzusteigen.
Hinter Einstieg ist in Puppet deutlich schwieriger.
Was ich mag an Puppet ist,
ist, dass du Puppet machen kannst.
Das geht ja mit Ansible nicht so ohne weiteres.
Das ist tatsächlich cool.
Mit Puppet kannst du No-Up-Run machen,
das simuliert jeden einzelnen Step
und zeigt dir genau an, was passieren würde.
Ja gut.
Container-Technologien.
Cloud- und Container-Technologien.
Da muss ich tatsächlich auch noch mal gerade jetzt reingucken.
Ja.
Ach stimmt, wir haben jetzt vergessen.
Normalerweise wollten wir immer eine Bewertung machen
von 1 bis 10.
Wir wollen ja eine Bewertung machen
von 1 bis 10 immer.
Ne, steht kein Gehalt dabei
und es klappt auch alles ein bisschen.
Also, ein bisschen knapp.
Also die DHL-Stellenanzeige vorhin,
das war halt was,
was mich so überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Irgendwelches SAP-Zeug.
Das ist aber an sich wenigstens ganz Standard.
0815 und so.
Also würde ich sagen, die DHL-Stellenanzeige
war vielleicht eine 5,5 von 10.
Und das hier ist so
ähnlicher.
Immerhin schreiben sie mal ein bisschen mehr
und ein bisschen
klarer, was sie wollen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen,
ist das von der reinen
Stellenanzeige her wahrscheinlich
eher eine 6 von 10.
Aber es spricht mich trotzdem gar nicht an.
Zumal auch für mich 0
drüber irgendwie deutlich wird,
warum ich denn da hingehen sollte.
Also ich persönlich ja eh nicht.
Ihr wisst, ich suche gerade keinen Job, aber
weiß ich nicht.
Also vom Thema her ein bisschen näher dran.
Das ist ein Punkt mehr als die DHL-Stellenanzeige.
Aber so wirklich
gut
finde ich die auch nicht.
Naja, sagen wir mal auch 5,5 von 10.
Bezeugt mich nicht so richtig.
Lass uns mal schnell
das hier durchgucken.
Sie suchen jemand
Machine Learning. Na was denn sonst?
Ausgeprägte
Scripting-Fähigkeiten. Python und Bash.
Erfahrung mit Kontinuisierung,
Orchestrierung von Anwendern.
Muss das
wirklich sein?
Die ist ja noch kürzer und knackiger.
Eigentlich finde ich kürzer und knackiger Anzeigen gut.
Gucken wir nochmal hier.
Kubernetes OpenShift.
Docker,
Helmcharts, etc.
Dachte sie
nutzen Ruby. Ja für Puppet
benutzen die Ruby, weil Puppet
in Ruby programmiert ist. Für alles andere benutzt
ja heute keiner da noch beim Verstand ist Ruby.
Deployment und Betrieb von
bereitgestellten Auslieferungen.
Ist das übersetzt aus dem Englischen?
Das wird doch niemand
irgendwie auf Deutsch so schreiben.
Deployment
und Betrieb von bereitgestellten
Auslieferungen. What?
Das ist eine Kombination aus
Wörtern, die würde mir gar nicht in den Kopf kommen
normalerweise. Bereitgestellten
Auslieferungen.
Was könnte das
im Original?
Ist das was
Continuous, ist das was
Continuous Delivery oder sowas?
Könnte das mal
Continuous Delivery sein?
Im Englischen?
Da ist man der Sache hoffnungslos ausgeliefert.
Was auch immer.
Das dann mit Docker und so.
Das passt im Container und Kubernetes
Umfeld durchaus mit Helmcharts.
Docker dann weniger, weil man hat ja
Kubernetes, da brauchst du keinen Docker.
Automatisierung, Optimierung der Abläufe
und Komponenten. Wie automatisiert
Wer
Wer schreibt diese Dinge?
Automatisierung und Optimierung
der Abläufe und Komponenten
wie automatisierte
CI CD Tool
Pipeline. Okay.
Ich meine du automatisierst die
automatisierte CI Pipeline. Okay, nice.
Vielleicht sollten sie
Weiterentwicklung und Optimierung
schreiben an der Stelle.
Also bei manchen
Bewerbungen
denke ich mir, das haben die Leute doch mit
Chat GPT geschrieben.
Das ist eine Stellenanzeige, wo ich mir denke,
hat da nicht vielleicht Chat GPT
die Stellenanzeige geschrieben?
Soll ich das mal in Chat GPT
reinpasten und Chat GPT fragen,
ob das mit Chat GPT erstellt wurde?
Nicht, dass das irgendwie
sonderlich zuverlässig ist.
Ich frage einfach Chat GPT
nur, ob das mit KI
erstellt wurde.
Fortschreibung der Dokumentation
gemäß interner Richtlinien.
Incident und Problem Manager im Rahmen des
Second Level Supports. Ihr Profil
erfolgreich ausgeschlossen. Ja.
Umgang
Linux Unix inklusive Skript.
Das ist ja noch okay. Das hat jetzt ein Mensch wieder
geschrieben.
Wahrscheinlich vom Fachbereich auf Englisch geschrieben
und von HR aufs Deutsche übersetzt.
Ja.
So liest sich das ein bisschen tatsächlich.
Darüber hinaus wünschen wir uns
Erfahrung, Kenntnisse im Bereich
virtualisierter Systeme und containerbasierter Applikationen.
Grundlegende Kenntnisse über CI,
CD Tools. Grundlegende Kenntnisse
wenn du doch die Automatisierung
automatisieren sollst.
Selbstständige und zielorientierte Arbeitsweise
blablabla.
Wurde die folgende
Stellenanzeige
per KI
generiert.
Mal gucken, was Chat GPT dazu sagt.
Es ist schwierig mit absoluter.
Chat GPT schwätzt wieder, Mann.
Einige
Hinweise, generische Formulierungen.
Ja.
Super hilfreich. Danke Chat GPT.
Ja. Gut.
Next.
Wenn ihr noch irgendwas habt, haut raus.
Wir haben nicht so viel, wobei doch, wir haben viel zu viel.
Machine Learning Engineer.
Guck mal, das ist mal ne schöne Seite.
Die ist schon dunkel.
Dark Mode.
Das ist bestimmt auch was Machine Learning mäßig.
Wenn das schon ML6 heißt.
Oh, das ist ja auf Englisch hier.
Was aber für die
Hardcore Karriere, Crider, jetzt.
We are all sitting
in one boat.
Python stellt's.
TensorFlow PyTorch.
Hugging Face.
Und die Dinger live bringen.
Das Ganze in einer Cloud Umgebung.
Um Business Value zu generaten.
Okay, und die liefern
ihre Produkte aus auf allen
Major Cloud Providers.
Man muss ja mal eins dazu sagen, ja.
Es wird immer gesagt, bei Major Cloud
Providers.
GCP, AWS, Azure.
Im Endeffekt Google,
Amazon, Microsoft.
Realistisch betrachtet
gibt es eigentlich nur zwei große Cloud Anbieter.
Und das ist AWS und Azure.
Google ist klein.
Da ist glaube ich, ich glaube
sogar, dass die Alibaba Cloud
mehr Kunden hat als Google.
Google hat irgendwie
8, 9, maximal 10%
Anteil. Wohingegen irgendwie
Azure frag mich nicht 25 hat
und AWS 30 oder so.
Also es gibt eigentlich
nur zwei große Cloud Anbieter.
Google ist da gar nicht so groß,
wie man denkt.
Dafür hat Google tatsächlich coole Sachen.
Zum Beispiel der Autopilot Cluster
ist eine nice Sache.
Du kannst auch
die Alibaba Cloud verwenden.
Ist ein richtiger
Consultant.
Use Python to deploy production
ready pipelines and
machine learning models on Google Cloud.
AWS oder Azure.
State of the
Art ML Research
collaborated mit anderen
Leuten.
Hilft seinem Team und trägt
dazu bei, dass es erfolgreich ist.
Ja, wenn man auf
Machine Learning
Hype Sachen steht.
Ich kenne
den Laden nicht. Ich kann dazu gar
nichts sagen. Wie es mit
Home Office aussieht, steht da nichts.
Oder wie es mit Remote aussieht.
Okay, sie suchen
was man mindestens haben soll.
Okay, man soll
einen Abschluss in Computer Science haben.
Man soll sich auskennen.
Man soll Erfahrung haben mit Software Entwicklung.
Man soll sich auskennen mit Machine Learning
und AI.
Man soll Expert Advice
geben können zu nicht technischen
Leuten und Kunden.
Man ist
exzellent
in
Sprache und Schrift
quasi.
Niederländisch und
Deutsch sind ein Plus.
Man soll Ahnung von Python
haben. Man soll alleine
vor sich
hinarbeiten können und Ownership
Taken. Da brauchst du
das passende Karriere Mindset.
Leute, ich hätte richtig Bock irgendwie eine Runde
Battlefield Bad Company 2 zu spielen.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich habe gerade
im Kopf daran gedacht. War das
nicht nice? Fragt mich nicht, wie ich
während der Stellenanzeige darauf komme.
Ich habe gerade mich gesehen
im Kopf.
Weil
Paraiso
die Fans mit
dem AT4 den Transporthelikopter
abknallen. Das Game
lebt, naja,
ein Server oder so hat noch Spieler.
Fragt mich nicht, wie ich da gerade drauf komme.
Ich habe
gerade vor mir gesehen, weil
Paraiso AT4
Transporthelikopter fliegt drüber
und du schaffst das den am Anfang
der Runde gleich abzuknallen.
Ja, aber frag mich bitte nicht, wie ich
in dieser Stellenanzeige jetzt auf Bad Company 2 komme.
Okay.
Bevorzugt wollen sie auch noch
Leute, die sich mit Shit auskennen.
Sehr gut.
Leute, die zu Open Source
Objekten contributed haben. Leute,
ich habe nicht nur zu Open Source
Projekten contributed.
Ich habe eigene Open Source
Projekte auf Github. Und ihr werdet
es nicht glauben, der Fiat Champ hat letztens
100 Sterne auf Github geknackt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das jemand verwendet.
Das muss daran liegen, dass er so fehlerfrei
programmiert ist. Und ja,
offensichtlich keinerlei
Issues bestehen.
Fuck, wir haben es geschafft.
Mehr offene Issues als gekloste Issues.
Shit. Alles nur Anwenderfehler.
Funktioniert der Fiat Champ noch?
Ja. Ja.
Jetzt bin
ich schlauer. Also wenn ich den jetzt
bauen würde. Also ich würde den,
wenn ich jetzt weiter daran programmiere, ja.
Dann würde ich den etwas umbauen,
weil das ist etwas
suboptimal, die Architektur des
Fiat Champs. Der kann nämlich
genau ein Auto und
einen Account. Wenn man
jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ey, aber ich habe
einen Fiat und einen Jeep,
dann klappt das nicht.
Es klappt auch nicht, wenn du zwei
Fiats hast mit unterschiedlichen Accounts.
Also die,
das ist etwas suboptimal, die
ähm,
Architektur dahinter.
Refactoring Stream, ja.
Ich glaube, wir müssen den Fiat
Champ nicht wirklich hier factoren.
Wir müssen uns eine
sinnige Architektur, das braucht, das Ding braucht
vor allem ein Web Interface, dass man die ganzen
Accounts und so anlegen kann. Ein eigenes Web Interface.
Nichts, wo
man irgendwie über Home Assistant
konfiguriert. Da brauchst du einfach
einen Button, wo man auf Web Interface kommt.
Und
im Prinzip muss
die Architektur neu gebaut werden, aber wir
können uns die meisten Teile vom Fiat Champ
copy-pasten aus dem alten.
Nämlich wie die Interaktion mit den
Fiat APIs funktioniert.
Das müssen wir ja nicht neu machen.
Hätte schon Bock drauf, da wieder dran rum
zu basteln.
Okay, man soll sich auskennen mit
Data Engine. Also, ich kann
seriously, ich kann diese Stellenanzeige nicht bewerten
und nichts zu sagen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was
die machen. Ich habe von AI Sachen hier zu wenig
Plan. Ich muss sagen, die
Stellenanzeige, also jetzt mal für so Standards
bei deutschen Stellenanzeigen,
finde ich die eigentlich ganz gut geschrieben, denn
am Anfang
Selbstlobpreisung. Du weißt relativ
genau, was
sie vorhaben. Was
die genau machen, weißt du nicht. Aber das ist eh
immer schwierig, auch Stellenanzeigen rauszukriegen.
Du weißt zumindest relativ genau, was sie
vorhaben, was du machen
können sollst und
was sie verlangen. Also
finde ich okay.
Es steht also relativ genau, sie legen
Wert darauf, dass sie sich mit Python auskennt. Sie legen
Wert darauf, dass sie sich damit auskennt.
Sie legen Wert darauf, dass du dich mit Machine Learning
und mit diesen Cloud-Anbietern auskennst.
Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich kann es aber nicht wirklich
bewerten. Ich habe von Machine Learning zu wenig Ahnung und
ich gucke mir auch zu selten
ähm
englischsprachige Stellenanzeigen an.
Was ist das für ein dämlicher Spam,
Alter? Check, wait, wait, ich muss mal kurz
bannen. Moment, warum gibt es denn
hier, warum haben, Block,
Moment, jetzt habe ich den geblockt.
Wenn man, wenn man jemanden blockt,
werden neuerdings nicht
mehr die Nachrichten gelöscht.
What the fuck?
Jetzt wurde es gelöscht, nachdem ich
explizit nochmal Bann eingegeben habe.
Stepstone, ja, da haben wir schon eine Weile
nicht mehr am Start.
Das ist eines der größeren so
Stellenanzeigenportale. Haben wir noch
einer der vorher Sachen gepostet? Ne, das ist
einer von den alten Stellenanzeigen. Da greifen wir
dann zurück drauf. Leute, von den alten
Stellenanzeigen, ne, ist
irgendjemand hier im Chat,
der, der eine noch dieser offenen
Stellenanzeigen gepostet hat vor drei
Monaten und will, dass ich noch reingucke?
Dann mache ich das
jetzt nämlich zuerst.
Weil, das ist immerhin drei Monate alt.
Ja, und zehn Viewer mehr hätten
es jetzt voll rausgerissen, gell?
By the way, heute ist es eigentlich richtig gut, 270
Leute, die zugucken. Das ist sogar noch, das ist
sogar mehr als sonst.
Ja, Codewerk,
okay, wo ist Codewerk?
Das da?
Hol ich mir an. Wenn das von dir ist
und das letzte Mal, weil du wartest
jetzt schon drei Monate drauf, man, wo ich den
letzten Stream gemacht habe in der
Richtung.
Ja, schön, dass
ihr alle am Start seid. By the way, Leute,
ich muss jetzt mal eine Runde Sellout machen. Und nein,
ich will nicht euren Prime-Sub, obwohl ich
gegen den Prime-Sub natürlich auch nichts einzuwenden
habe, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind.
Also, wenn ihr noch Prime-Subs offen habt, aber
da wird gar kein Sellout für Prime-Subs.
Wenn euch der Content gefällt,
dann lasst doch einen Follow da.
Dann kriegt ihr das nächste Mal direkt
eine Message, wenn ich online gehe.
Könnt wieder am Start sein.
Und wenn ihr eine Prime-Sub
habt, sage ich auch nicht nein.
Sellout-Modus beendet.
Business Development Manager
Digital... Alter, was ist denn das
für ein Titel? Ist das immer noch das
richtige, ja? Ist das das
richtige RF-Programmer, was ich offen habe?
Siehste, der ist Pfunst.
Einmal Follow aufgerufen,
zum Follow aufgerufen, ich gucke in den
Stream-Manager rein, Leute sind am Followen.
So ist das nice. So mag ich das.
So ist das
pog.
Excellent.
Ja, wir müssen mal demnächst wieder den
Lötchamp rausholen, oder?
Also, Business Development Manager
Digitalisierung und Datenräume.
Allein schon der Titel ist ja mal
next level. Also, allein vom Titel
hätte ich schon mal gar keine Ahnung, um was es eigentlich
geht. Business Development
Manager Digitalisierung und Datenräume.
Kein Schimmer, aber mal gucken.
CodeWork steht nicht work.
Werk.
CodeWerk.
Steht für Technik, Begeisterung, Innovation
und Zuverlässigkeit mit flachen Hierarchien,
Freiraum und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten.
Ob in Zügen,
Ah. Ob in Zügen
oder Industrieanlagen, wir bringen die
Systeme von morgen dazu, miteinander
zu reden. Neue Anforderungen
wie der European Data Act.
Ich hab noch nie was davon gehört.
Stellt die Industrie
vor neue Herausforderungen. Kennt jemand von euch
den European Data Act?
Max, du brauchst noch einen zweiten Standpunkt
fürs Streamen, für Doppelfollow und Sub.
Das macht aber eigentlich keinen
Sinn, oder?
Einige davon...
Okay, blablabla, wir lassen jetzt mal das Intro.
Ist das DSGVO,
oder wie?
Wir suchen zum
schnellstmöglichen Zeitpunkt einen Business
Development Manager. Okay, also Chat,
die Stellanzeige haben wir vor drei Monaten aufgemacht,
die ist immer noch da, das heißt, die haben noch keinen gefunden.
Wir suchen zum schnellstmöglichen
Zeitpunkt einen Business Development Manager.
Ich hab immer noch
keine Ahnung, was ein Business Development Manager ist.
Ich kann mir da auch
nix wirklich vorstellen. Ist das jetzt eher
ein BWL-Typ?
Oder meinen die mit Development
wirklich Softwareentwicklung?
Du führst Marktanalysen
durch und definierst gemeinsam
mit unseren Experten neue Marktanalyse.
Keck W Business.
Ist das weg?
Wo ist das?
Wo ist das
Businessy Mode? Ist das weg? Guck mal.
Wir hatten doch mal so ein
Keck W Business Emote.
Ja, geh mir nicht auf den Sack, Twitch.
Keck W Bus...
Ne, ist immer noch da, ne?
Ach, Busines
schreibt man das ja.
Nicht Buisnes.
Nicht Buisnes, Busines.
Keck W Business.
Ja, den da hab ich gesucht.
Basierend auf diesen Anforderungen
identifizierst und realisierst du Businesslösungen
für unsere... Das ist aber sehr viel.
Und der Nutzung
digitaler Datenräume.
Was ist damit gemeint?
Ok, ChatGPT.
Ok, was ist ein digitaler Datenraum?
Da gibt es sogar Wikipedia Eintrag zu.
Der digitale Datenraum,
teilweise auch virtueller Datenraum
genannt, ist ein virtueller Raum zur Verwaltung...
Ja, ach, das hätte ich mir auch noch denken können.
So was wie Google Docs
oder wie.
Digitale Datenräume werden bei der Teamarbeit
vermittelt... Ach, das ist
quasi...
wie wenn einer ein Projekt anlegt
in Google Docs oder einen Ordner anlegt
ein Projekt anlegt in Teams
oder einen neuen Teamraum aufmacht
oder...
Ok, meine Güte, man kann das auch alles kompliziert nennen.
Also ein Projekt
Ordner in Office anlegt, so nach dem
Motto und dann die Leute dazu einlädt
mitzumachen.
Du positionierst die Produkte und Lösungen am Markt.
Der Markt regelt das.
Da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
Du beteiligst dich aktiv
an innovativen Forschungsprojekten zur
Digitalisierung der Industrie, zum Beispiel an
Factory X.
Einem Förderprojekt der
Manufacturing X Initiative.
Was?
Ok, heute lernen wir noch was.
Industrie
4.0
Sag mal, das ist ja... Passwort
stellst gerade kaum noch zu überbieten,
oder?
Industrie 4.0
Ok, wa... Ok.
Was war Industrie 1.0?
Dampfmaschinen, oder was?
Ok.
Das interessiert mich jetzt. 4.0
3.0, 2.0,
1.0. Was ist der Unterschied?
Von Industrie 1.0
bis Industrie 4.0.
Historischer Verlauf.
Ok.
Siehste, ich war gar nicht so schlecht mit Dampfmaschine.
Industrie 1.0 ist
Dampfkraft. Webstuhl.
War die Dampfkraft nicht eine ganze
Ecke später als der Webstuhl?
Industrie 2.0
Massenproduktion,
Montagelinie, elektrische
Energie. Ok.
Industrie 3.0
Automatisierung, Computer und Elektronik.
Den Zaun muss ich
wieder überspringen.
Industrie 4.0
Cyberphysikalische
Systeme. Internet
der Dinge. Also wenn schon
muss man cool sein, das IoT abkürzen.
Was? Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Netzwerke.
Moment, das gab's hier
auch schon, oder? Aha.
Ok. Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich
recht hab. Webstuhl
Erfindung.
Ok. 1735.
Der
Webstuhl
Dampfmaschine
Erfindung.
Ah shit, das war wirklich ungefähr ähnlich.
Das stimmt, guck mal, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, was ich erzähle.
Dampfmaschine ist von 1712
und so richtig durchsetzen
konnte sich der Webstuhl ab 1830. Der Webstuhl
war 100 Jahre später.
Oder auch nicht. Oder auch nicht.
1969.
Ok. Die waren
ungefähr dann zeitklar. Ok, das wusste ich nicht.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, Webstuhl
war viel früher als Dampfmaschine, aber
so kann man sich
täuschen, ja.
Industrie 4.0, kompakt erklärt
Entwicklung. Ne, das lese ich jetzt nicht durch.
Alles klar.
Industrie 4.0, wieder was gelernt.
Wer hat das Patent auf Patent?
Bestimmen die Schweizer.
Du unterstützt unseren Vertrieb
mit beim Aufbau neuer Kundenkontakte.
Ok. Du bist ja auch
Business Manager.
Die Basis bringst
du auf jeden Fall mit.
Du erkennst geschäftliche Chancen,
also du erkennst quasi Opportunities,
wie das dann die Business Leute sagen.
Geschäftliche Chancen und treibst
aktiv Lösungen voran, um diese Chancen zu nutzen.
Ok.
Du bringst gute Kenntnisse
in aktueller Cloud Architektur.
Das kommt jetzt aber ziemlich random,
ehrlich gesagt.
Das kommt jetzt ziemlich random.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Der Rest übelste Business
Cagweight Business Enterprise
stellst und zwischendurch kommt
du bringst gute Kenntnisse in aktueller
Cloud Architektur mit.
Nichts davon deutet irgendwie auf
Technik oder gar Softwareentwicklung
oder oder ja,
was Development was mit Softwareentwicklung zu tun hat
zu tun. Und random steht da einfach mal
aktuelle Cloud Architektur drin.
Also, für mich
ist die Stellenanzeige gar nix.
Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Ich kann die auch nicht einordnen und richtig
raten oder so,
weil ich davon überhaupt keinen Plan hab.
RF Programmer.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Das ist eindeutig
zu Cagweight Business.
Zu
zu ihr
ist das.
Hast du schon das Video vom ersten Computer geschaut?
Da gibt es nicht nur ein Video zu.
Okay, endlich mal
was, wo ich zumindest halbwegs was zu
sagen kann. Gehalt anzeigen,
das stimmt doch eh nicht.
Stepstones gebetet richtig krass damit.
Das haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Das ist gebetet.
Den Namen von der Firma,
schwierig.
Sys
GG
Sys.
Soll irgendwas mit Sys heißen?
Oder ist es eigentlich
Sy C G G
Ach du Scheiße.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das...
Syzygy.
Computer aus dem alten Griechenland.
Cagweight Business.
Können wir uns angucken.
14 Minuten ist eine gute...
Morgen früh gucken wir uns das an.
Morgen früh ist...
Wir gucken YouTube Dinger.
Aha.
Die Richtung kommt jetzt gleich.
Ich wusste es doch.
Das muss es jetzt sein zwischendurch.
Okay, nice.
Da waren wir jetzt stehen geblieben.
Frontend Developer.
Oder wie würdet ihr das hier aussprechen
Leute?
Sys
Ich kann das nicht aussprechen, das ist echt...
Wir sind...
Syzygy.
Okay.
Pronunciation.
Syzygy.
Okay, dass wenn die Planeten quasi in einer Linie sind.
Was heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Syzygy.
Okay, top.
Aussprache.
Nein, nein, ich will das auf Deutsch.
Wie man auf Franz...
Oh, auf Französisch.
Ja, auf Französisch muss ich das unbedingt wissen jetzt.
Syzygy.
Syzygy auf Deutsch. Aha.
Einer Wörter, wo ich von der Existenz bis heute
nichts wusste.
Der Duden.
Der Duden weiß da...
Haben die nicht auch mal was zum...
zum Aus...
Ne, haben die nicht, gell?
Syzygy.
Ach du Scheiße. Okay, nice.
Jetzt wissen wir schon mal...
Oh Mist.
Wer auch immer diese Stellenanzeige gepostet hat.
Wenn du dich da bewirbst.
Und du sprichst den Namen
im Vorstellungsgespräch richtig aus.
Hast du schon mal einen großen Pluspunkt.
Ist auch egal, ob du es auf Englisch,
Französisch oder auf Deutsch aussprichst.
Und wenn du dann auch weißt, was es ist.
Nämlich, dass quasi die Planeten
so in einer Linie und so.
Dann sind die glaube ich richtig...
richtig scharf drauf.
Was auf Türkisch.
Ah, da gibt es keine Aussprache.
Max, weißt du, wie man
Kniphex ausspricht?
Ja, man spricht es eigentlich Kniephex aus.
Aber jeder sagt Kniphex.
Okay, Vollzeit, Teilzeit,
Homeoffice möglich.
Da kenne ich
die richtige Aussprache nicht.
Von manchen Sachen Tex, manche Sachen Tech.
Die viel größere und bedeutendere
Frage ist doch, wie man Jason ausspricht.
Und wenn wir das geklärt haben,
müssen wir uns noch fragen,
wie man Gif ausspricht.
Aber Jason finde ich viel,
viel spannender.
Jason.
Ja, Kubernetes
ist auch so ein Ding.
Das hatte ich schon in allen Arten.
Kubernetes, Kubernetes,
Kubernetes.
Da war auch alles schon dabei.
AWS.
Gibt es da
mehrere Aussprachen?
AWS oder AID.
AWS.
Weil W so ein
räudiger Buchstabe
ist im Englischen auszusprechen.
Es gibt,
ist das ein bisschen wie in CS?
Ist das ein bisschen wie in CS,
wo die Leute dann auch nicht sagen,
also auf Deutsch sagen die Leute ja AWP.
Irgendwann ist dann
AWP oder sowas durchgesetzt.
Und AWP sagt
ja auch keiner.
Da sagen dann Leute
AWP und sowas.
Ist das bei AWS auch so,
dass sie dann, wenn sie es auf Englisch
aussprechen, Avis oder so sagen.
Avis.
Ich hoste meine Sachen bei Avis.
SQL
oder SQL? Ich bin für SQL.
Kubernetes.
Das habe ich noch nicht gehört.
So, aber gucken wir uns an.
Die Leute sind wieder super glücklich.
Die arbeiten anscheinend auch noch auf Macbooks.
Super glücklich am Start zu sein.
Ich habe schon wieder
vergessen, wie man es ausspricht.
Wir sind
Syzygy. Ich habe jetzt gelernt.
Syzygy.
Also da hat man echt einen Pluspunkt,
wenn man sich dort vorstellt
und gleich sagt, hi Leute von Syzygy.
Wisst ihr, was geht?
Wow, du weißt, wie man das ausspricht.
Niemand weiß, wie man das ausspricht.
Enterprise IT Spezialist.
Mit agilem Mindset
und Hands-on Mentalität.
Geht schon gut los.
Chat, wir haben noch Agile
Mindset, oder?
Wir crammen uns auch immer
die low-hanging fruits.
Wir haben da einfach das richtige Mindset für.
Und die Synergieeffekte nutzen wir auch regelmäßig.
Das ist eindeutig
der Key zum Success.
Das hilft uns auch auf das
Next Level. Also,
weiter.
Mit mehr als 100 SpezialistInnen
entwickeln und betreiben wir
maßgeschneiderte Softwarelösungen für
große Unternehmen wie Continental,
Deutsche Bahn, Porsche, Samsung oder
O2. Ja, da habe ich heute gekündigt.
Heute stimmt.
Heute stimmt nicht.
Plötzlich. Heute habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich da gekündigt habe.
Kündigt habe ich schon, glaube ich,
Mittwoch oder so.
Wir erstellen individuelle Lösungen, die mitdenken.
Dabei sind wir Hands-on
tech-
Ja, okay, das ist auf Deutsch.
tech-hungrig, ein wenig
nerdy, kommunikativ und echte
Teamplayer.
Meine Erfahrung zeigt eigentlich, dass sich
das und
dass sich die letzten Sachen
also das schließt
sich nicht aus,
aber das und die letzten zwei Sachen
kann sich durchaus
ausschließen.
Also die richtigen Kellerkinder wie ich,
die haben es nicht so mit
ähm
random small talk
mit Leuten, die sie nicht kennen.
Aktuell suchen wir
vor Ort in Bad Homburg
oder Remote
einen Frontend-Developer.
Du bist Frontend-Entwickler.
Anspruchsvolle Aufgaben spornen dich an.
Was mich anspornt ist, Geld zu verdienen.
Das spornt mich an.
Dann bist du bei uns genau richtig.
Deine Aufgaben.
Als Teil eines Cross-
Das ist auch so ein neues Ding, ne?
Das sieht man auch bei immer mehr
Stellenanzeigen, dass da drin steht, dass du Teil
eines cross-funktionalen Teams bist.
Entwickelst du in großen Projekten
State-of-the-Art-Software unter Verwendung
von TypeScript und React.
Okay, das ist eine Kombination,
die wundert mich nicht.
TypeScript ist ein bisschen so Enterprise-Umfeld,
hat sich ja super durchgesetzt
und React ist nicht
ohne Grund von denen gewählt.
Es ist einfach das bekannteste
und meist benutzte
Frontend-Framework und vor allem
das mit dem größten Ökosystem.
Es könnte schlimmer sein.
Es könnte auch Angular sein.
Webdesigns setzt du mit HTML5
und CSS um.
Dazu nutzt du SAS.
SAS ist ein bisschen unbeliebt geworden
so die letzten 1-2 Jahre.
CSS-Modules, das habe ich mal
irgendwo gehört, sagt mir jetzt gar nichts.
Tailwind. Tailwind ist nice.
Tailwind verwende ich auch.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin ja eh der absolute
Frontend-Checker schlechthin.
Das was entscheidet die Kundenseite?
Zum Beispiel aus den Bereichen Automotive,
Banktail.
Okay, das ist ja schön und gut.
Manchmal gibt es allerdings Anfragen,
die machen wenig Sinn.
Das ist halt immer schwierig,
wenn man das dann nicht sagen darf.
Ja, React geht noch.
Ich habe nie etwas Großartiges in React gemacht.
Single-Page-Application.
Schwer zu sagen, aber eine reine
Ja, ich meine, es kann ja durchaus sein,
dass die dort
einige Sachen für irgendwelche Anzeigen
oder so machen und dass man sowas
heutzutage mit JavaScript und einem Browser macht,
halte ich auch für, ich kenne mich da so
in dem Bereich nicht aus.
Also ich weiß, dass von SpaceX,
diese Bildschirme hier bei SpaceX,
das ist alles
JavaScript, was ihr hier seht.
Also die, die
fliegen, um es jetzt mal wirklich
also
wörtlich zu sagen,
die fliegen mit JavaScript
auf den
Mond demnächst.
Das ist alles JavaScript.
Was sollte schon schief gehen?
Erstaunlich wenig, ne?
Hamburger Menü. Ist das jetzt gut
oder schlecht?
Das kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Aber die haben für alles auch physische Buttons.
Waren Kampfchats
nicht auch Kubernetes Cluster?
Also das würde mich wundern.
Das wie entscheiden wir gemeinsam?
Dann haben wir dabei Best Practices,
Coding Guidelines
und ein agiles Mindset.
Chat, da sind wir genau richtig.
Wir sind so agil,
dass wir im Daily Scrum
nicht mal stehen,
sondern direkt laufen schon.
Sitzen ist ja
eh out. Stehen kann jeder.
Wir laufen im Daily Scrum.
Kubernetes und Istio
auf einer
inneren F16?
Was will
eine F16 mit einem Kubernetes Cluster
und einem Service Mesh?
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Sinn
Kubernetes in einem
Kampfflugzeug laufen zu lassen.
Da ist wahrscheinlich sehr viel Low Level
Old School Shit auch noch drinnen an Technik.
Wo man einfach
weiß, das funzt.
Die F16 ist vielleicht
das Basic Modell, aber das ist ja
wird ja immer permanent geupdatet.
Aber ja, ich gehe
immer davon aus, dass viele Sachen
dort wahrscheinlich nicht überhaupt
in der Lage sind Kubernetes laufen zu haben.
Und ich wüsste auch ehrlich gesagt nicht,
was man damit soll.
Das wann, wo und womit entscheidest du?
Windows oder Mac?
Linux steht gar nicht zur Auswahl.
VSCode, Supply, WebStorm oder andere IDE?
1, 2 oder 3, Monitor, Großraum,
Zweierbüro oder Homeoffice? Fast alles ist möglich.
Das finde ich gut.
Das gefällt mir, dass sie das so reinschreiben.
Freie Betriebssystem Auswahl.
Sehr nice.
Aber Chat, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind,
sobald es freie
Betriebssystem Auswahl gibt,
gibt es doch eigentlich gar keine Frage mehr.
Das muss dann Archlinux sein.
Wobei ich jetzt gehört habe,
die richtig coolen Leute,
die auch allen immer erzählen
erzählen wollen,
dass sie Archlinux verwenden,
denen ist das jetzt auch ein bisschen
zu doof geworden, weil
das gibt zu viele Archlinux User,
die sind jetzt auf NixOS unterwegs.
Die sagen jetzt
I use NixOS by the way.
Wisst ihr was noch besser ist?
Einfach weiter Archlinux
verwenden, aber für manche Packages
nix als Package Manager.
Finde ich aber ganz nice, dass sie das so schreiben.
Was du mitbringst.
Du hast bereits einige berufliche Erfahrungen
in HTML, CSS und JavaScript,
TypeScript.
Framework beziehungsweise React
oder Angular
setzt sie
und setzt sie routiniert ein. Agile Methoden
wie zum Beispiel Scrum sind dir bekannt.
Ich bin...
Also Chat, wir sind mittlerweile
sowas von Agile und Next Level.
Wir skalieren
auch schon gar nicht mehr horizontal
oder vertikal, wir skalieren nur noch
prinzipiell diagonal. Wir machen beides
gleichzeitig.
Ich denke da geht Linux auch. Wenn die sagen
Mac oder Windows, dann haben die garantiert
keine zentrale Software
Management Sache und sonst was. Wenn du sagst, du willst
Archlinux verwenden, darfst du das bestimmt auch machen.
Kannst ja fragen, da habt ihr schon ein Thema, worüber
man reden kann.
Wir skalieren in die vierte Dimension.
Wir skalieren diagonal über eine Woche lang.
Dann haben wir ja quasi...
Na gut, diagonal ist 2D
und eine Woche lang ist das dann nur 3D.
3D.
Also wir skalieren quasi
an X, Y und Z Achse und das
über eine Woche lang. Dann haben wir
vierdimensional skaliert.
Auf dich kann man sich verlassen, du bist ein echter
Teamplayer.
Remote Office oder Hybrid?
Du arbeitest am liebsten im Homeoffice,
du kommst gerne jeden Tag ins Büro.
Vorzugs die Mischung bei uns mit
dem Team.
Die Frage ist, ob die auch
bereit wären, sowas in den Vertrag zu schreiben.
Flexible Arbeitszeit
und voller Überstundenausgleich.
Gehaltspaket.
Vermögensfähigkeit, das hat ja fast jeder
mittlerweile. Betriebliche Altersvorsorge.
Eine
Sonderzahlung.
Hier kriegst du dann 300€ nach 10 Jahren
oder so. Weiterbildung,
Trainings, Urlaub und
Workation.
Bei uns gibt es bei
Vollzeit 32 Tage.
Ja, nicht schlecht.
Ach so, ah,
Moment, Moment, nicht 30 Tage.
Hahaha.
Ich hab schon gedacht, sie geben am 32
Urlaubstage. Nee, 30 Tage ist
jahresheilig, so wie Silvester sind arbeitsfrei.
Okay. Sag mal da, wo ich arbeite, auch so.
Ich dachte, sie geben am 32
Arbeitstage.
Das wäre natürlich mal was.
Zusätzlich gibt es für besondere alle Sonne Urlaubstage
temporäres Arbeiten.
Hört schon mal gar nicht so schlecht an. Mental und...
physische Gesundheit.
Mental Health Coaching.
Augenuntersuchung.
Habe ich mal gemacht.
Ist aber schon ein bisschen her. Ich habe eine Augenuntersuchung
gemacht. Da kam raus, ich habe
glaube ich auf dem linken Auge
150% Sehstärke.
Wo es bis zu dem Zeitpunkt
gar nicht, dass das geht.
Dachte aber 100% nicht, Schluss.
Jährliche Grippeimpfung.
Beste Ausgestattet Arbeitsplätze.
Ja, ganz ehrlich,
das war aber schon...
Das war die beste Stellenanzeige heute.
Ich finde die nicht schlecht.
Da ist relativ klar,
was angesagt ist.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
keine autogenerierte Stellenanzeige
von ChatGPT.
Ist auch relativ
wenig
Business Style geschrieben, sondern
man versteht, was die wissen wollen.
Nix genau, nix wo man
denkt, WTF, was ist da los?
Macht keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Das Blöde ist oftmals nur,
ich weiß es jetzt an der Stelle nicht,
das Blöde ist oftmals nur, dass sich gezeigt hat,
dass Stellenanzeigen, von denen ich denke,
oh, die machen ja einen guten Eindruck,
oftmals auch Stellenanzeigen sind, wo es nicht viel Geld gibt.
Also wenn, also
irgendjemand im Chat
hat gesagt, StepStone hat
hier geschätzt 50 bis
65k.
Die sind in Bad Homburg.
Das ist nicht weit weg hier.
Da ist das, würde ich mal sagen,
relativ
normales Gehalt, jetzt nix
übertrieben krasses.
Aber ich finde, es liest sich, liest sich
liest sich gut. Naja, ich würde
nicht 50, ich würde schon sagen 65.
Also für 50 würde ich auch sagen,
bisschen wenig, ja.
Aber insgesamt finde ich, liest sich's nicht schlecht.
Das ist was, was man sich, denke ich,
auf jeden Fall angucken kann. Nicht ich,
wie gesagt, ich such keinen Job und ich bin jetzt
sicherlich auch niemand, der sich als Frontend-Entwickler bewirbt.
Aber ich finde, es liest sich nicht schlecht.
Und wir haben
immerhin was gelernt, was eine
Süssigi ist.
Süzigi.
Oder wie auch immer es auf Deutsch ausgesprochen ist.
Süssigi.
Fand ich nicht schlecht. Rein von
der Stellenanzeige hat mir die bisher heute am besten
gefallen. Also der
geb ich mal 9 von 10.
Fand ich nicht schlecht.
Oder 8,5 von 10. Wir wollen's mal
nicht übertreiben. Da ist ja immer noch Platz nach oben.
Aber, na ne, ne. Kann man schon mal sagen
9 von 10. Die fand ich echt nicht schlecht.
So, next.
Mache auch sie, machen auch sie
Wasser zu ihrer Aufgabe.
Zip by zip.
Best Water Technology.
Machen auch sie Wasser zu ihrer Aufgabe.
Wir suchen engagierte Mitarbeiter MWD.
Moment. Die sagen gar nicht, was sie suchen.
Die sagen einfach, wir suchen Mitarbeiter.
Best Water Technology.
IT Support.
GOD PLEASE NO!
NO!
Das heißt nicht, dass die Stelle
schlecht sein muss. Ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nix
für mich. IT Services
Helpdesk. Wer hat das geschrieben?
Okay. Ich bin
so weit hinten dran mit meinem Chat.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer das geschrieben hat. Derjenige, der das
geschrieben hat, noch am Start.
Sicherstellung eines erfolgreichen und zuverlässigen
IT-Service für unsere Mitarbeiter. Okay, das ist natürlich schon mal
ein gutes Ziel für, oder?
Eigenförderliche Anwendungsbetreuung bei
aufgetretenen Hard- und Softwareproblemen.
First.
Und Second Level zu
Support. Monkeys First
Level Support.
Nein. Please. No.
Schnell weg.
Aber das muss nichts Schlimmes sein.
Nur weil ich das nicht machen möchte.
Kann man
schnell Vorschläge machen? Ja klar, schick
her. Hast du deinen regulären
Job noch? Ich hab den nicht nur noch.
Ich hab seit 1. April letztes Jahr
einen neuen.
Nur weil ich keinen Dock auf IT Support hab,
das heißt nicht, dass das ein schlechter Job ist oder ein schlechter
Arbeitgeber. Also,
ich hätte bloß keinen Bock auf Support.
Analyse, Lösung, Dokumentation,
Anfall, andere Probleme, Unterstützung
der technischen Betriebsführung und
Weiterbildung, ne nicht Weiterbildung,
Weiterentwicklung der IT,
Kommunikation
wahrscheinlich, Infrastruktur,
Aufbau von IT,
Arbeitsplatz. Moment,
du bist, oh ne, das ist ja wirklich richtig
Hardcore
Oldschool First Level
Support inklusive Turnschuh-Admin.
Oh, da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf.
Dann musst du auch Druckerpatronen tauschen.
Dann musst du dem Chef noch das Handy
einrichten, dich um irgendwelche
Videokonferenzsachen kümmern, wenn sie mal wieder
nicht gehen, so Haustechnik-mäßig.
Federtechnose von Peripheriegeräten.
Ja, du tauscht die Druckerpatrone.
Turnschuh.
Mit Turnschuh-Admin ist gemeint jemand, der
halt rumlaufen muss den ganzen
Tag. Ich war
früher beispielsweise auch Turnschuh-Admin.
Nein,
das ist nicht gemeint, was du an hast. Ist einfach nur gemeint,
dass du viel laufst. Ich war früher auch Turnschuh-Admin.
Gerade zu meiner
Ausbildungszeit noch,
da musste ich morgens in drei
Rechenzentrums-Standorte in Frankfurt
jeweils hinlaufen, rein,
einmal rund, gucken, ob noch alles
geht, gucken,
zurück, zumachen, runter,
nächstes Rechenzentrum, hinlaufen.
Das war Turnschuh-Admin.
Turnschuh-Admin
hat was durchaus Nices.
Man ist beschäftigt
und gerade die Sachen früher
noch mit
5 DVDs ins Rechenzentrum
und
Red Hat installiert, Red Hat
Vollinstallation auf alten
Kisten, also
aus heutiger Sicht alten Kisten,
damals normale Kisten.
Das war nice.
Das war eigentlich ganz cool. Ich bin gerne
ins Rechenzentrum. Ich würde auch
gerne öfters mal wieder ins Rechenzentrum.
Oder wieder öfters mal ins Rechenzentrum.
Ich hätte
echt Bock, mich einfach
mal wieder ins Rechenzentrum zu setzen.
Und dort mit ein paar
DVDs
in Red Hat zu installieren. Macht keinen Sinn aus
heutiger Sicht, ich weiß, aber
könnte ja auch von einem USB-Stick sein.
Aber Hauptsache
mit diesem tollen RZ-Wagen, wo da
Monitor und Tastatur draufsteht, wo man dann
hinten in den Gang geht und sich
anstöpselt und vielleicht ist
das Rechenzentrum auch schon ein bisschen advanceder und man hat
quasi einen abgeschlossenen, äh einen
abgeschotteten Raum, wo man sich dann
per Remote-Konsole dran verbinden kann
oder so. Das war... Ich bin immer wirklich gerne
ins Rechenzentrum. Ich konnte
euch damals sagen, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal
erzählt, ja, aber es war halt so.
Ich konnte euch damals sagen,
wenn ich ins Rechenzentrum... Also ich bin Rechenzentrums
Rundgang morgens, habe ich immer im Dunklen gemacht.
Ich habe nie das Licht eingeschaltet im
Rechenzentrum. Ich war schon immer früh in
Frankfurt, so 7 Uhr oder kurz vor 7
teilweise war ich in Frankfurt.
Da war ich dann irgendwie kurz vor 7 schon im Rechenzentrum
bin rein, habe kein Licht
angemacht und bin im Dunklen durchs Rechenzentrum
gelaufen. Und ich konnte euch damals
wirklich von jeder Rack-Reihe
sagen, wenn dort irgendwas
anders geleuchtet hat als normal.
Hat Microsoft bei Azure
immer noch Ubuntu als Hauptsystem?
Du meinst das, was standardmäßig
ausgewählt ist
bei Linux. Kann ich dir nicht sagen, schon
ein paar Jahre her, wo ich Professional-mäßig
Azure verwendet habe. Aktuell ist es
hauptsächlich Google Cloud, aber ich glaube schon,
die waren ja ganz
dicke, Canonical und Microsoft.
Deswegen würde mich wundern, wenn
die Default Selection was anderes als Ubuntu
ist.
Aber du kannst es ja easy umstellen.
3 Jahre Erfahrung, Windows Server.
MonkaS wird ja immer schlimmer.
Workspace, Technologien,
Office-Applikationen.
Okay, Leute.
Wer
für einen
Turnschuh-Admin First Level
Support-Job, liest sich das gar nicht
schlecht. Ich persönlich hätte halt überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es schlecht sein muss.
Es ist, okay, ich sag mal
ich finde die Stellenanzeige nicht
schlecht. Es ist kurz und bündig.
Es ist auch relativ klar,
was die wollen. Es ist auch kein
Business Enterprise Gelaber, wo nicht ganz klar
ist, was Sache ist. Relativ klar,
was sie haben wollen, was gefordert ist.
Was einen erwartet.
Tja, ob das Gehalt gut ist, ist bei so Support-Sachen
immer eh fraglich.
Und ansonsten,
ich denke, da kann man sich durchaus bewerben, wenn man auf
genau sowas Bock hat und weiß, vor allem,
worauf man sich einlässt mit so einem Support-Job.
Also, das Ding ist
kurz und knackig. Klar, was Sache ist.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht die
innovativste Stellenanzeige,
aber die kriegen 7,5
von 10 von mir, weil die Stellenanzeige an sich
nicht übel ist. Wenn man denn
wirklich genau sowas haben möchte.
Sucht.
Gibt es gratis Wasser
als Benefit?
Anscheinend. Weinberge
für Mittagsspaziergänge.
Das gehört denen ja aber nicht.
Kein Obstkorb.
Firmen-Events. Ja, da kann man sich immer drüber streiten,
ob das so ein
Pluspunkt ist.
Also, wenn man wirklich so ein Support-Ding
sucht, liest sich das gar nicht so übel.
Ich hätte da aber keinen Bock drauf, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Als
PDF.
Ich glaube, beim PDF
kann auch mal ein Darkreader nichts mehr machen.
IT-Network-Expert.
Stellenbezeichnung.
Heidelberg-IT.
Ergänzung
unseres Netzwerk- und ISP-Teams.
Internet-Service-Provider
für den Betrieb
unseres Backbones
und der Netzwerk-Infrastruktur
unserer Kunden. Okay.
So wie sich das liest, ist das wirklich ein bisschen
advanced-eren Netzwerkstells.
Leidenschaft
für Technik, sorgfältige, präzise Arbeit,
Teamfähigkeit. Also auch kurz und knackig.
Erfahrungen in den Bereichen Switches,
Router, WLAN,
Firewall,
VPN,
dynamisches Routing,
OSB,
BGP.
Ja, die suchen auf jeden Fall jemanden,
der einen Plan hat für ein Netzwerk.
Da kannst du nicht sagen, ey, ich habe mal
daheim eine Fritzbox installiert.
Weiß nicht, probiert es aus, wo man da rauskommt,
wenn man das scannt.
Soll ich mal gucken, wo kommt man da raus?
Heidelberg-IT.de
kommt man da raus.
Also im Prinzip auf den ihrer Webseite.
Wir bieten abwechslungsreiches
Arbeitsfeld, gemeinsame
Team-Events, Monks,
Individuelle Anwesen. Okay, das ist nur
wirklich sehr kurz und knackig,
diese Stellenanzeige.
Finde ich aber gar nicht verkehrt, ehrlich
gesagt.
Da ist kein, also das muss man ihnen lassen,
da ist kein unnötiges Rumgelabere
dabei. Das ist einfach
Bäm, wir suchen.
Let's go.
Finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Was sagt ihr, Leute?
Das ist wirklich mal kurz und knackig.
Das hast du in zwei Minuten gelesen.
Und allein schon mit dieser Auflistung
hier, weiß man, die richten sich
nicht an irgendwelche Noobs, die daheim
eine Fritzbox installiert haben.
Ja, das so die,
ein paar Details fehlen natürlich schon, ja.
Wie sieht es mit Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten aus?
Wobei Homeoffice ja keiner wirklich schreibt.
Die schreiben ja alle mobiles Arbeiten.
Ein bisschen mehr Infos wie,
wie sieht es mit Kohle aus? Wie sieht es mit
Remote Work-Möglichkeiten aus?
Hände ich schon nicht
schlecht. Aber
an sich finde ich die Stellenanzeige so
schon mal gar nicht verkehrt, ja. Es ist einfach
kurz und knackig. Und man weiß auch,
wenn man aus dem Netzwerkbereich kommt,
spätestens wenn hier was von BGP steht
und dynamischem Routing, dass die,
dass die wirklich Leute wissen, also Leute
haben wollen, die wissen, was sie machen.
Deswegen würde ich mal sagen, es ist vielleicht nicht
so gut wie die letzte.
Aber eine 7 kriegen die trotzdem von mir.
7 von 10. Auf kurz
und knackig, alles klar. Man weiß, an
wen es sich richtet.
Ein paar Kleinigkeiten mehr hätte man durchaus
schon machen können, ja. So.
Wie sieht es mit Kohle aus?
Zum Beispiel. Wie sieht es mit Remote Work-Möglichkeiten
aus? Und solche Sachen. Aber
jo. Jo.
Geht schon klar. Warum es jetzt unbedingt
ein PDF sein muss? Ja, das ist halt echt die Frage.
Gucken wir mal hier. Karriere.
Moment. Warum gibt es hier
Stellenangebote
als PDF
und hier unter Stellenangeboten
Ah ne, Moment. Wenn man da drauf
drückt, kommt man auf das PDF. Aha.
Oh, guck mal.
Wollen wir uns das angucken?
Ja, 38 Sekunden
können wir uns angucken. Ein Image
Imagefilm.
Das hat ein bisschen was von Matrix.
Und was hat der Hund damit zu tun?
Das hat was,
das hat was von
3D-Grafik so.
Okay, das ist nix.
Also,
ein paar Sachen, so wie es da aussieht,
wäre schon nicht verkehrt, oder?
Ein 3D-gedrucktes Serverhotel.
Server...
Quasi ihr Rechenzentrum.
Serverhotel. Events.
Kunst.
Oh,
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an meinen Ausbildungsbetrieb.
Die hatten teilweise auch solche komischen Events.
Bin da nie hin. Ihr kennt mich.
Aber da...
Ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Chatge, mein Hals wird echt trocken langsam.
Ich würde so was trinken.
Ich habe fast den Liter leer gesoffen hier jetzt in der Zeit.
Also, eine Stunde
habe ich noch Zeit.
Habt ihr noch irgendwas Spannendes an Stellenanzeigen?
Was aktuelles?
Wo ihr sagt, ey,
da will ich mich bewerben oder einfach
was, was lustig ist. Oder gar
von euch, dort wo ihr arbeitet.
Da bin ich auch ein bisschen nett dazu dann.
Ich finde, wir hatten heute doch erstaunlich
viele ganz gute Stellenanzeigen.
Aber das eine war komplett für den Arsch.
Aber die anderen
gingen doch eigentlich alle.
Und die letzten paar waren gar nicht so übel.
War meins schon.
Ja, oder?
Was ist deins gewesen?
Was war deins?
Gucken. Arsch, by the way.
Achso, nee, nee, das haben wir glaube ich noch nicht.
Nee, das haben wir noch nicht.
Ach, hier habe ich es ja noch.
Ah, lol.
Habe ich voll übersehen.
Deine Zukunft beginnt mit Z.
So, ZFS zum Beispiel.
Operations Engineer
OpenShift Data Experience.
Alter, wilde
Jobbezeichnung.
Operations Engineer OpenShift Data
Experience.
OEODE.
Zürich Versicherung.
Ich arbeite auch bei einer Versicherung.
Nicht bei der Zürich Versicherung.
Kann ich machen, ja.
Wollen wir uns gleich angucken.
Vacancies Europe.
Gibt es das auch auf Deutsch?
Ich bin besser im, also, wir können uns die angucken,
aber ich kann besser deutschsprachige Stellenanzeigen
raten.
Bist du bereit, mit dem Besten
zu rechnen?
Rheinmetall. Ja, denen geht es gerade
finanziell ziemlich gut. Irgendjemand hat
am Anfang des Streams was zu Rheinmetall gefragt.
Das habe ich übersehen.
Da wollte ich eigentlich was zu sagen. Was war denn das nochmal?
Okay, und was war, was war die Frage?
Der Darkreader macht es kaputt.
Ja, das habe ich auch gerade gesehen. Das war aber nicht schlimm.
Wie gesagt, ich kann deutschsprachige Stellenanzeigen
besser bewerten. Da habe ich einfach mehr Erfahrung
drin, den Kram zu lesen.
Die suchen gerade in Bremen und
meine Frage, Geld oder Moral?
Ganz ehrlich, wenn die,
also, ich sehe
da kein Problem. Wenn
die einen guten Job für dich haben, die
ordentlich bezahlen, du musst gucken, wo du bleibst.
Mach das hin, geh da hin.
Ja, denen geht es ja auch finanziell gut.
Die ähnliche
Frage ist, ja,
so am Anfang,
als man erahnen konnte, dass
es in der Ukraine bald abgeht,
da habe ich mir ja auch gedacht, also Max,
eigentlich müsstest du Rheinmetall-Aktien kaufen. Ich war da so blöd
und habe es nicht gemacht.
Ich habe da auch viele Leute, die gesagt haben, oh, das ist moralisch
nicht vertretbar.
Würde mich jetzt nicht so jucken.
Du hast da keinen Einfluss drauf.
Wenn das für dich ein guter Job ist,
wenn es für dich ein guter Job ist,
sehe ich,
also ich würde da kein Problem
sehen, wenn die sagen, ey Max,
wir suchen jemand, was weiß ich,
bei uns für irgendwelche Linux-Geschichten,
Cloud-Geschichten.
Wir bezahlen dir 250k im Jahr oder
irgendwas total, irgendwas ordentliches.
Da würde ich auch sagen, ist mir doch egal,
ob ihr Panzer baut.
Klassischer IT-Administrator.
Weiß.
Das außerdem, es ist nicht, als hättest du irgendwie
einen Einfluss da großartig drauf, ja.
Okay, lass uns aber gerade mal
die Sache hier fertig angucken, von Zürich
Versicherungen.
Das erwarte dich, als Operations-Engineer
verantwortest du die Betreuung auf unsere IT-Infrastruktur.
OpenShift-Datenbanken, nee,
OpenShift, wollte ich gerade sagen,
OpenShift-Datenbanken, what?
OpenShift, danach kommt Datenbanken in
Azure AWS, sowie Tomcat und
SQL-Datenbanken in der
Private Cloud.
Im Delivery Team Data Experience,
da haben sie nochmal einen dollen Namen für.
Also ich kann euch sagen,
wenn ihr bei einer Versicherung
arbeitet, auch wenn das nicht alles so super
modern und toll und sowas hier ist,
diese Dinger sind, ich
spreche da aus Erfahrung, ja,
das sind Bürokratie,
ähm,
Overload gibt's da.
Da ist auch alles sehr genau
geregelt und bürokratisch.
Was sind Tomcat-Datenbanken?
Die schreiben, sowie Tomcat
und Datenbanken,
SQL-Datenbankinstanz, die sagen nicht
Tomcat-Datenbanken. Weiterhin,
erwarten dich folgende spannende Aufgaben.
Du optimierst den Applikationsbetrieb,
dabei gehört insbesondere CICD-
Strecke zu deinen Tätigkeiten.
Du treibst die Modernisierung
und Automatisierung unserer
IT-Infrastruktur an und bist über
neue Technologietrends
gut informiert. Ja,
das ist ein Punkt,
das finde ich gut, dass sie das reinschreiben,
weil ich der Meinung
bin, ich sehe das ähnlich,
gute IT-Leute
oder gute Techniker, ja,
ich fasse das jetzt mal so unter
Techniker zusammen. Das sind in der
Regel Leute, die sich für diese Sache auch
privat interessieren.
Das meiste sind so Kellerkinder wie ich,
aber die wirklich guten Leute,
auch beim Thema Anwendungsentwicklung,
sind Leute,
die sich privat auch dafür interessieren.
Das sind welche, die
sind fertig auf der Arbeit
und basteln dann erstmal an ihrem Open-Source-Projekt
auf GitHub weiter, so nach dem Motto.
Und
ich habe auch die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass das eben wirklich so eine
Sache ist, die sich bei den meisten
guten Leuten, nicht bei allen, ja, aber bei den
meisten guten Leuten durchzieht,
dass die schon so
einen gewissen Hang dazu haben,
so Kellerkinder wie wir
zu sein. Also ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so, ihr wisst,
was ich meine, ja. Also
quasi auf der Arbeit
vorm Computer und weil einen
die Sache privat interessiert,
dann auch noch vorm Computer und
dort sich dann halt andere Sachen angucken, ja.
So vielleicht, ah, ich habe gehört, es gibt jetzt
irgendwie da ein neues XY
und die probieren, die meisten dieser
wirklich guten Leute, die haben Sachen daheim schon
längst ausprobiert, bevor das auch nur irgendwie mal
drei Jahre später in der Firma zur Sprache kommt.
Also wirklich gute IT-Leute
interessieren sich auch privat dafür.
Das ist so ein roter
Faden, das ist das, aber ich glaube
ganz ehrlich, dass das nicht nur bei IT-Leuten so ist,
sondern das ist generell bei Leuten, die wirklich
richtig Plan haben
von ihrem Bereich, dass es nicht von
ungefähr kommt, sondern,
das kommt hauptsächlich daher,
dass die das schon
immer aus
so, wie sagt man, intrinsischem Antrieb,
aus eigenem Antrieb interessiert hat
und das ist auch oftmals
ein Nebeneffekt ist halt, dass
die jetzt eben auch in einem Job gelandet sind,
ähm,
wo sich das
eben auszahlt, diese Fähigkeiten
zu haben, ja. Also sprich,
die haben sich schon immer dafür interessiert
und irgendwann hat dann auch mal der Arbeitgeber
gemerkt, der zukünftige dann, ey, guck mal,
der Typ hat ja richtig Ahnung davon, aber warum hat er richtig Ahnung
davon? Weil er sich persönlich dafür interessiert.
Ja, das ist
bestimmt in vielen anderen Berufen auch so.
Ja, gucken wir
jetzt mal zu was ganz was anderem rüber, zu irgendwie
Versicherungsmaklern oder so.
Gibt sicherlich Leute,
die wollen den, die wollen da ihren Leuten nur irgendwas
aufschwätzen, aber du wirst auch den
einen oder anderen finden, der da voll
aufgeht drinne und super
interessiert am Start ist, was sich
da wie wo sonst entwickelt.
Ich glaube, es ist durch die Bank weg immer
so, 90%
können ihren Job nicht richtig und sacken
und 10% sind richtig gut.
Diese 10%
muss man halt finden.
Ich sehe genug Leute auch bei uns
auf der Arbeit, die
machen halt seit
30 Jahren so ein Ding und
die wollen auch das, also
die haben außer von diesem einen Ding
eigentlich gar keine Ahnung. Das ist dann
so, dass du sagst, ey,
lock dich doch da mal per SSH ein
und guck mal nach, da sagt
er, wie SSH, ich kann
nur Putti aufmachen.
Er sagt, ja, das ist doch
SSH, was ist? Weiß ich doch nicht, ob das
SSH ist, ich mache immer nur Putti. Da sind dann so
Leute, wo ich mir denke, Alter, was ist mit euch los,
Mann? Das passiert ja einfach
nicht bei Leuten, die sich selbst
aus eigenem Antrieb für
Sachen interessieren.
Ein Technikgebiet ihrer
Wahl. Und umso besser
du dich auskennst in deinem Lieblingsgebiet,
umso höher sind natürlich auch die Chancen, dass du mal
in deinem Lieblingsgebiet arbeiten
kannst. Ja, oder
wir hatten da so einen Kerl
bei uns in der alten Firma,
der hat zu allem Neuen
immer gesagt, das weiß ich
nicht, wie das geht, da brauche ich eine Schulung zu.
Und da waren übelst banale
Dinger dabei, so.
Ich weiß noch, alte, alte
Arbeitgeber, die haben damals Jira
eingeführt, wo ja auch die Frage
ist, wie man es ausspricht,
Hira, Jira,
Jaira, habe ich alle schon gehört,
Hira,
haben die eingeführt
und jetzt mal ehrlich,
Jira ist nicht schwierig zu bedienen.
Das ist eigentlich eines der simpelsten
Ticketsysteme. Das ist easy
zu bedienen. Was viele Unternehmen machen,
ist das komplett zu zweckentfremden und 30 Milliarden
Dinger einzubinden. Aber die grundsätzliche Bedingung ist
wirklich sehr simpel. Jeder
kann Jira bedienen, ohne dass
der erste Mal eine Woche Schulung gemacht
haben. Das ist simpel.
Vor allem, wenn man mal
die Basic Sachen gezeigt bekommen hat, so nach
dem Motto, ich verstehe ja, wenn
nicht jeder JQL oder sowas abfragen
gleich basteln kann oder
wenn mal einer suchen muss, wo ist jetzt der
Button eigentlich zum Ticket verschieben von einem
Projekt ins nächste. Das zeige ich es den Leuten, dann wisst ihr es.
Aber wir hatten einen, der hat wirklich
gesagt, wie Jira, das kann ich
nicht verwenden, da hatte ich noch keine Schulung für.
Mach es auf, lock dich ein, das ist komplett
selbsterklärend, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das Problem
ist. Ne, da hatte ich noch keine Schulung für, das
kann ich nicht. Ich meine, ich bin auch
keiner für, der unbedingt jeden Tag
mit
unvorhergesehenen Dingen
konfrontiert werden muss. Ich bin jemand,
der hat auch gerne alles geplant und
hat noch einen Backup Plan und noch einen
Backup Plan für den Backup Plan und sowas.
Aber mich interessiert
neue Technik einfach extrem.
Und ich habe schon Dinge
ausprobiert und Dinge gemacht,
die waren vielleicht 1, 2,
3 Jahre später mal im Job relevant
oder nie. Aber die meisten Sachen,
die meisten Sachen haben mir zumindest
im übertragenen Sinn in meinen
Job bisher mal was gebracht.
Guck mal, wir haben hier im Stream
so viele verschiedene Dinge schon gemacht.
Wir haben hier alles irgendwie schon gemacht.
Frontend-Entwicklung, Backend-Entwicklung,
Sachen zusammengelötet,
Micro-Control, wir haben sogar mal COBOL
programmiert.
Wir haben alles irgendwie
ganz viel, wir haben sogar Windows Server
uns mal angeguckt und haben uns da mal weggekeckt,
wie man diesen Kack den ganzen Tag verwenden kann.
Ganz viel Linux-Krempel,
unterschiedlicher, HA-Proxy,
Custom Health Checks, Kubernetes,
mit Argo CD,
alle möglichen Dinge.
Wir haben alle möglichen Sachen hier im Stream
schon gemacht. Und natürlich brauche ich nicht
alles davon auf der Arbeit.
Und gerade so eine Sache, die mich persönlich zum Beispiel
interessiert, Heim-Automatisierung und
Micro-Controller-Programmierung.
Das ist was, das hat eigentlich relativ wenig
Schnittmenge
mit meinem Job.
Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um Linux-Systeme,
um Automatisierung,
um Cloud-Deployments,
Setups von irgendwelchen Kisten in der Cloud,
das hat mit Micro-Controller und Heim-Automatisierung
nicht wirklich viel zu tun.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein Thema,
das interessiert mich persönlich,
ich weiß da auch relativ brauchbar Bescheid
mittlerweile.
Und die ein oder anderen
Sachen, zum Beispiel, dass ich weiß,
wie MQTT funktioniert,
ist was, das hatte ich den Leuten
damals voraus,
als es mal um irgendwelche
Messaging-Technologien geht.
Und unter anderem kannst
du dir ja bei AWS
eine, also AWS hat
so einen IoT-Service,
AWS hat
managed MQTT
und das kam auch mal
bei uns beim alten Job zur Sprache
und ich war glaube ich der einzige, der wusste,
was das überhaupt ist.
Und es bringt einem oftmals
Sachen auf unterschiedlichsten Wegen
was.
Und also eine Sache, die mir beispielsweise
ganz viel bringt, ich bin nicht in der Software-Entwicklung,
ja,
also wie gesagt, ich bin nicht irgendwo
als Software-Entwickler oder Programmierer am Start,
aber trotzdem, mir hat es schon
so oft was gebracht,
dass ich programmieren kann,
dass ich vor allem,
und das ist echt was, wo man, wo sich, finde ich,
manche Admins echt mal ein bisschen
auch über den Tellerrand
gucken sollten und auch viele Entwickler
mal auch ein bisschen über den Tellerrand gucken sollten,
man kommt einfach viel besser
klar, auch mit
Entwicklern, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung davon hat,
was sie eigentlich so machen,
ja, und was da so oftmals Probleme sind
und wenn die da irgendwie Probleme haben
mit ihren Dependencies und sonst was,
wenn du das selbst schon mal ein bisschen was damit zu tun hast,
kannst du einfach besser mit den Leuten reden.
Die merken dann auch gleich,
du verstehst, was das Problem ist, ja.
Das bringt, das bringt was.
Auch wenn es was ist, wo man erstmal denkt,
okay, hat gar keinen richtigen Bezug zu
meiner Arbeit, vieles bringt einem
im übertragenen Sinne doch was.
Und letztendlich, selbst wenn nicht,
ist ja auch keine verschwendete Zeit,
du hast was, du hast was,
du hast dich mit was beschäftigt, was dich persönlich sehr
interessiert, das ist ja auch schon was Erfüllendes, ja.
Aber am Ende, irgendwie bringt es dir immer was.
Und mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn mir sogar mal irgendwann meine C++
Skills auf der Arbeit was bringen.
Ich will es nicht hoffen, weil dann müsste
ich irgendwo mal C++ auf der Arbeit machen.
Ich kann mir eigentlich kaum was schlechteres
vorstellen, aber selbst das könnte sein, dass es mir
mal was bringt.
Ich meine, guck mal, wir haben,
ich habe euch das ja schon auf der Arbeit erzählt,
ich bin ja in so einem Projekt, wo es hauptsächlich um
Kryptowerte geht.
Es ist nicht Bitcoin, es ist hauptsächlich
Polygon.
Und wir haben eine Software laufen bei uns
in dem Kubernetes Cluster,
die macht, wie soll ich das,
die ist Teil
von diesem Polygon Blockchain Netzwerk,
okay. Und diese
Software lässt sich sehr schlecht überwachen.
Die hat zwar einen Endpunkt,
wo man Daten abfragt, also die hat einen internen
API Endpunkt, wo man Infos abfragen kann.
Die hat theoretisch sogar einen
eingebauten Prometheus Exporter, nur dass da
keine Werte exportiert werden, die irgendwie
großartig interessant sind.
Und was haben wir gemacht?
Also die Software läuft im Kubernetes
Cluster. Was haben wir gemacht?
Also man möchte ja auch diesen
API Endpunkt nicht irgendwie
public exposen, ja.
Man will den schön intern haben. Und was haben wir
gemacht? Wir haben
super agil,
diagonal skaliert natürlich,
wir haben was gebaut. Und zwar haben wir ein
Go-Programm gebaut,
das die lokale
API abfragt,
von diesem, von dieser
Blockchain Software.
Und das läuft als Sidecar
in Kubernetes. Ein Sidecar ist
Sidecar ist, wenn ihr nicht wisst, was Sidecar
ist, ist das, was es früher für Motorräder
als Anhänger
neben gab.
Das da. So und so und so.
Das ist ein Sidecar. So in einem
Kubernetes Umfeld nennt man das so,
wenn man zu der eigentlichen Anwendung
noch eine zweite Anwendung dazu
packt, aber die quasi im
gleichen Kontext laufen.
In Kubernetes nennt sich das
Pod. Ein Pod ist quasi so die
kleinste, so logisch
managebare Einheit in Kubernetes.
Normalerweise besteht
so ein Pod eben aus der eigentlichen
Anwendung. Das heißt,
oftmals ist ein Pod quasi
gleich ein Container. Das muss
aber in Kubernetes nicht so sein. In Kubernetes
kann ein Pod durchaus mehrere Container
enthalten. Und wir
haben einen Sidecar-Container gebaut.
Das heißt, in diesem Pod
läuft jetzt die eigentliche Blockchain
Anwendung in einem Container.
Und wir haben quasi in dem gleichen
Pod noch einen zweiten Container,
der
die lokale API abfragt. Und da der
im gleichen Pod läuft,
Pod
ist quasi Local Host in beiden
Containern ist das gleiche.
Solange du in einem Pod bist, ist es quasi wie
wenn du in einem Docker-Container
läufst im Endeffekt. Könnte man sich so
vorstellen. Oder in einer VM läufst,
wenn es wirklich eine VM ist. Das ist quasi
der gleiche Kontext. Das heißt, Local
Host auf dem ersten Container ist gleich
Local Host auf dem zweiten Container.
Und da kein Unterschied dazwischen.
Das ist quasi alles in einem Pod. Wir haben
quasi einen Sidecar-Container gebaut,
der die lokale API abfragt
von dieser Blockchain-Software
und das dann aufbereitet als
Prometheus-Exporter
bereitstellt. Im Endeffekt ist
das ein kleines Go-Programm. Da haben wir sogar, glaube ich,
Teile hier im Stream davon entwickelt.
Das ist ein kleines Go-Programm,
was wir in ein
Distroless-Image gepackt haben.
Das Container-Image
ist nur 16 MB oder so groß.
Wir haben quasi, neben der eigentlichen
Software in unserem Cluster, haben wir jetzt noch
im gleichen Pod eine gleiche Software laufen,
die fragt lokal die API ab
von dieser Blockchain-Software,
berechnet dann ein paar Sachen daraus,
zum Beispiel, was ist die
ID des letzten Blocks in der
Blockchain,
was ist der Timestamp dieses Blocks
und wie alt
ist der letzte Block?
Weil das Problem war, dass
diese Software manchmal hing und niemand hat
mitgekriegt, dass die hängt. Du konntest es auch nicht
wirklich erkennen, dass die hängt. Und wir hatten
immer das Problem, wie überwachen wir das?
Die Software selbst gibt irgendwie keine
brauchbaren, monitorbaren Daten
raus, also haben wir uns selbst
ein Monitoring gebaut. Wir haben diesen Sidecar-Container,
der errechnet diese
drei Sachen, also letzten Block,
was heißt er rechnet, fragt das ab
und rechnet dann ein paar Sachen aus,
letzte Block-ID, letzter Block-Timestamp,
letzter Block-Alter und das Ganze
stellt er auf einem Endpunkt
als Prometheus-Daten
zur Verfügung. Und dann wird das
gecrawled von einem Prometheus,
eingesammelt und dann kann man alles
mitmachen, was man will. Kann man sich ein Grafana-Dashboard
bauen oder ein Google-Cloud-Dashboard
oder was auch immer.
Und seitdem wir das gebaut haben,
wissen wir wenigstens, wenn die
Software mal wieder hängt. Glücklicherweise,
hat sich herausgestellt, die neuen Versionen sind deutlich
besser und bleiben kaum noch hängen.
Aber wir haben quasi
Überwachung für eine Software, die man eigentlich nicht,
die sich eigentlich nicht richtig überwachen lässt.
Gerade wenn sie im Kubernetes-Cluster
läuft, haben wir quasi eine eigene Überwachung
dafür gebaut, im relativ eigenen Go-Programm.
Und warum ging das Ganze?
Ja, weil ich halbwegs sinnig
programmieren kann.
Es ist also was, was ich privat
gelernt habe, Go
zu programmieren, weil es mich persönlich
selbst interessiert hat,
und es hat sich auch gelohnt und
wir konnten es auch auf der Arbeit verwenden.
Demnächst darf ich das übrigens presentaten bei uns.
Wir haben irgendwann Ende November
eine Abteilungsversammlung
und
was bedeutet in dem Kontext hängen geblieben?
Das ist jetzt
kein Diss gewesen, dass irgendjemand
hängen geblieben ist. Die Software hing einfach,
die hat einfach nicht weiter gesynct.
Die blieb auf irgendeinem Block stehen und hat einfach nicht weiter
gesynct, ja. Die Blockchain selbst produziert
ja laufend neue Blöcke, aber die hat einfach nicht weiter
gesynct, da hat die keinen Bock mehr.
Wie viel Code ist die Go-Anwendung?
Ja, so 150 Zeilen oder so.
Ist nicht viel.
Letztendlich sind es die
API-Abfragen und dann der
Prometheus-Export. Das sind 150 Zeilen, das ist nicht viel.
Hat ein paar Kommandozeilen-Argumente noch.
Das ist easy, ja.
Woher wisst ihr, dass etwas passiert ist und die Anwendung
wirklich hängt? Ihr wisst ja nur, wann das
letzte Update passiert. Das ist richtig,
aber diese Blöcke werden
in relativ hoher Frequenz
produziert.
Also eigentlich kannst du sagen,
wenn
der letzte Block älter als 5 Minuten
ist, stimmt schon irgendwas nicht. Und wenn er
älter als eine Viertelstunde ist, ist auf jeden Fall
irgendwas verkehrt.
Diese Blöcke werden da wirklich
im
schnellen Takt, ich kann es dir jetzt nicht sagen,
genau wie schnell, werden die generiert.
Und dann
kannst du so einen Filter draufsetzen auf deine Daten
und kannst sagen, ey, das ist jetzt schon eine Viertelstunde
her. Ja, du weißt
es nicht wirklich, aber du kannst es anhand
des Alters ableiten.
Und da kam
halt alles zusammen. Ich habe das GoPro-Programm
entwickelt, ich kannte mich mit
Prometheus-Monitoring aus und ich weiß,
wie man gescheite
Container-Images baut. Ich kenne mich
mit Kubernetes aus. Das ist
das, was man eigentlich so in dieser
ganzen DevOps-Geschichte zusammenfasst
und das ist auch das, was mich persönlich interessiert.
Und da hat man gesehen, Dinger, mit denen
ich mich eigentlich sonst nur privat
beschäftigt habe, weil es mich interessiert,
haben mir auch im Job was gebracht.
Übrigens, wie gesagt, demnächst
darf ich das sogar
präsentieren.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das läuft.
Ich habe da noch nie Präsentationen gehalten in dem Laden.
Ich bin ja da auch erst seit 1.4.
2022.
Also im größeren Stil.
Das ist eine Abteilungsversammlung, da sind 100
Leute da. Bin ich mal
gespannt. Präsentation habe ich schon
fertig. Muss ich noch ein bisschen verfeinern.
2,5
Jahre? Ne. Seit
1,5 Jahren.
2023. 1.4.2023.
Nicht
2022.
1,5 Jahre bin ich jetzt ungefähr da.
Ja gut, nun hängt es und wie läuft
es weiter? Da gibt es erstmal einen Alert,
dass es hängt.
Und dann kann sich irgendjemand der Verantwortlichen für
die Anwendung überlegen, was sie machen wollen.
Läuft
meistens auf dem Restart raus, ja.
Aber weißt du, was noch besser ist?
Weißt du, was noch viel nicer ist?
Dadurch, dass du jetzt die
Informationen hast,
auch abfragbar,
sinnvoll, ja, über
irgendeinen Endpunkt, könntest
du sogar einen Health-Check bauen.
Du könntest einen Health-Check bauen,
in diesem Sidecar, Kubernetes
Health-Check, in dem Sidecar,
dass du sagst, der Health-Check
schlägt fehl, wenn der letzte
Block älter als 5 Minuten ist.
Und wenn der Health-Check fehl schlägt,
startet Kubernetes automatisch den Pod
neu. Also es ist erstmal wichtig,
dass man diese Infos hat.
Wirst du da auch pock und keck sagen?
Das kann durchaus passieren.
Also Lull ist mir schon
rausgerutscht und
einmal
habe ich jemanden dazu verleitet,
Poggers zu sagen.
Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass der auch öfters Twitch
guckt.
Poggers, ja.
Und zwar
kennt ihr diese
Programme,
wo du abstimmen kannst?
Irgendjemand hält ein Thema
so nach dem Motto,
Leute, heute erzähle ich euch,
wie geil es ist, Server in der Cloud
aufzubauen. Und dann sagt er, ey Leute,
stimmt doch mal ab.
Wie findet ihr denn
Server in der Cloud? Stimmt doch mal
oder schreibt mal hier was rein.
Da gibt es verschiedenste Abstimmungssoftware für.
Oftmals kann man dann nur sagen, ich find's geil
oder ich find's nicht geil. Manche dieser Programme
erlauben einem auch quasi
so, wie soll man sagen,
Reaktionen reinzuposten.
Und wir hatten mal eine Präsentation
und da hat dann auch
gesagt, ey Leute, wie findet ihr das?
Und ich hab dann halt reingeschrieben, wie ich das finde
und ich hab reingeschrieben, Poggers.
Und er hat das dann vorgelesen.
Er hat dann vorgelesen, aha, aha, sehr gut,
aha, ich sehe hier Poggers.
Okay,
ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, ob der wusste,
was er da ausspricht oder ob der einfach
nur vorgelesen hat oder ob der auch Twitch guckt.
Und wusste, dass er
Poggers ausspricht.
Also ich habe nicht vor,
dort in Twitch Emotes zu reden,
falls das deine Frage war, ja.
Aber Lull ist mir
öfter schon rausgerutscht.
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Was mir auch schon rausgerutscht ist?
MonkaS
ist mir schon rausgerutscht.
Das
checkt halt gar keiner, der das nicht kennt.
Die denken glaube ich auch mittlerweile.
Okay, beim neuen Laden noch
weniger, aber beim alten Laden haben die eh schon alle gedacht.
Der Max hat sie eh nicht mehr alle, ja.
MonkaS habe ich schon mal gesagt, ey.
Und ganz ehrlich,
wer auf der Welt
kennt bitte MonkaS,
wenn er nicht regelmäßig Twitch
guckt? Vor allem,
ich bin ein 40-jähriger
Kerl, der
dann auch noch vielleicht halbwegs seriös aussieht,
wenn er da vorne steht und was erzählt.
Zwischendurch vielleicht
noch mal kurz aufrufen zum Prime-Subscriben,
ja, das wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Sollte ich jetzt auch machen, ja.
Aber scheiß auf Prime-Sub,
wenn es euch gefällt, lasst mir
lieber einen Follower da, kostet nichts.
Und ich mag es, wenn die
Pfeile in den Analytics nach oben
gehen bei Followern immer schön.
Immer schön steil grün nach oben, das ist immer nice.
Bitte am Ende der Präsentation
lasst mir einen Prime-Sub
da, ja. Ja, also wie gesagt,
das darf ich demnächst dann auch mal vorstellen.
Ich war ja wieder so blöd, oder was heißt
eigentlich nicht, ne? Ich nenn's jetzt mal so.
Ich war ja wieder so blöd, mich da freiwillig für zu melden.
Aber ihr kennt ja meine
Philosophie. Es wird immer eingesammelt,
Themen, ja, für die nächsten
größeren Versammlungen wird
immer Themen eingesammelt. Da bin ich zu meinem Chef
und hab gesagt, hier, was hältst du denn davon?
Ich stell mal die ganze Sache mit unserer
Blockchain-Überwachung vor.
Und er hat gesagt, Max, das ist eine gute Idee, ich trag dich gleich ein.
Das Ding ist,
meine Philosophie
ist ja folgendes, mittlerweile.
Nach, naja,
sagen wir mal, 20
Jahren in der IT. Meine Philosophie ist ja folgendes.
Man muss schon gescheite Sachen machen, ja.
Man kann nicht nur den ganzen Tag rein kacken.
Oder nix machen oder nur Mist bauen.
Aber wenn man was Gescheites gemacht
hat, sollte man
eigentlich mindestens fast die Hälfte
der Zeit, die man dafür gebraucht hat, was Gescheites
zu machen, dafür aufwenden,
allen zu erzählen, dass man was Gescheites
gemacht hat. So blöd das
klingt. Und so sehr man
auch immer sagt, Eigenlob stinkt.
Und so Selbstlobreisung
ist halt irgendwie doof. Ja,
da habt ihr im Prinzip schon recht.
Aber im Enterprise-Business-
Umfeld ist es aber so.
Ja, im
im Keck-Business-
Umfeld,
kann immer noch nicht, dieses
E-Mail-Wort, im
Keck-Way-Business-Umfeld
ist es aber so,
du musst, wenn du was Gescheites gemacht hast,
auch allen erzählen, dass du was Gescheites
gemacht hast.
Anderes Beispiel, ich hatte mal
einen Kollege, das war glaube ich
mit der Wichtigste, den wir im Team hatten.
Der hatte von allem eine Ahnung.
Und er hatte nicht nur von allem
eine Ahnung, der hat auch
den ganzen Tag was gemacht.
Also das war einer, das war einer
der Leute, wenn man
dieses Diagramm hier wieder nimmt,
wie ging das nochmal hier?
Bin gar nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt
zusammenkriege.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Irgendwie
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt richtig mache.
Hier, motiviert.
Alter, was ist das da schon wieder?
Motiviert.
Faul.
Keine Ahnung.
Hat Ahnung.
Hat keinen Plan.
Das ist jemand,
der war hier.
Der hatte Ahnung
und dann mal motiviert.
Also eigentlich so Vorzeigemitarbeiter,
den man haben will.
Der hat aber nie großartig ein Aufsehen
um das, was er gemacht hat, fabriziert.
Dementsprechend hat das überhaupt
keiner mitgekriegt. Wir im Team wussten,
das wäre an der Stelle
eindeutig auch Aufgabe seines Chefes
damals gewesen, das ein bisschen breiter,
ein bisschen besser breit zu treten,
dass der eigentlich geile Sachen macht
und auch super motiviert ist.
Der hatte aber nie großartig drüber geredet.
Und eines Tages hat er gesagt,
Leute, ich kündige,
ich gehe woanders hin.
Und wir waren alle entsetzt.
Wir haben alle gesagt, fuck, Alter, du kannst nicht weggehen.
Du bist der einzige, der das, das und das kennt.
Und alle anderen haben gesagt,
oh ja,
dann ist er halt weg.
Die haben gar nicht verstanden, was die an dem verlieren.
Obwohl es eines der wichtigsten
Leute da war.
Und dementsprechend
ist es natürlich auch so,
wenn ihr irgendwie mehr Kohle haben wollt
oder irgendwie hofft, dass ihr in die nächste Bonuszahlung
was kriegt oder sonst was,
man muss sich,
so blöd es klingt, man muss sein Kram
ab und zu mal ein bisschen lobpreisen.
Man muss es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Man muss ja nicht jeden Furz, den man gemacht hat,
irgendwie an die große Glocke hängen.
Aber wenn man ab und zu mal
was, was besonders cool war,
im größeren Umfeld
vorstellt und zeigt,
das bringt was.
Wenn ihr da unterm Strich mehr,
und das ist der eigentliche Punkt,
eine coole Sache machen,
also sagen wir mal so,
ihr macht drei Monate,
ne das war übertrieben,
ihr macht drei Monate eine coole Sache
und die nächsten drei Monate
redet ihr noch über die coole Sache,
die ihr gemacht habt,
dann habt ihr da unterm Strich mehr davon,
als wenn ihr drei Monate
eine coole Sache macht
und die nächsten drei Monate
noch eine coole Sache.
Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen,
warum will man das aus Sicht
von einer Firma haben?
Eigentlich ist es mit die Aufgabe des Chefs schon,
die Sachen mitzuverkaufen,
aber ein gewisses Eigeninteresse daran,
seine Sachen gut zu verkaufen,
muss man leider haben.
Man muss da
manchmal sich einfach ein bisschen
selbst lobpreisen,
oder die Sachen, die man gemacht hat,
auch ein bisschen zeigen,
sodass es jeder mitkriegt.
Im Endeffekt hat man da mehr von.
Wo würdet ihr euch einsortieren?
Also ich würde mich,
ich würde mich,
also der war eindeutig,
der war eindeutig hier,
also der war super krass motiviert
und hat Ahnung.
Also ich würde sagen,
ich würde schon sagen,
dass ich prinzipiell schon Ahnung habe,
ich würde aber sagen,
ich bin schon eher ein bisschen
auf der faulen Seite.
Du bist bei keinem Plan und faul.
Okay.
Also ich habe diese Tabelle,
oder kann man das Tabelle nennen,
diese Matrix,
habe ich mal in der Präsentation gesehen,
von irgendeiner Konferenz,
irgendeiner Konferenztalk.
Und der hat gesagt,
der Presentator,
der hat gesagt,
okay,
also ich glaube,
der hat sogar das Publikum gefragt,
deswegen frage ich euch mal,
wie sieht das aus, Leute?
Was möchtest du Leute haben,
motiviert und Ahnung?
Ich glaube so offen hat er es auch gesagt.
Was meint ihr,
motiviert und Ahnung?
Ja, also prinzipiell will man die schon haben,
ja.
Also prinzipiell will man das schon haben.
Nein doch,
ich würde schon sagen,
du möchtest Leute die motiviert sind und Ahnung haben.
Doch, möchtest du haben.
Kann man Leute gebrauchen,
die faul sind und Ahnung haben?
effizient und
fehlerfrei. Beziehungsweise
so, dass sie nie wieder genervt werden davon.
Das ist auch ein bisschen was, wo ich mich selbst
wiedererkenne. Manchmal muss ich
mich echt überwinden, was zu machen. Aber wenn ich's
mache, dann mache ich's meistens so, dass ich mich nie wieder mit
beschäftigen muss. Äh, faule Leute
sind übrigens, ich will nicht sagen, dass
Führungskräfte faul sind, ja, falls jemand
Führungskräfte unter euch ist, ja, Führungskräfte
unter euch ist. Aber faule Leute sind
oftmals auch gut im Delegieren. Das heißt,
sie sind prinzipiell gar nicht mal schlecht als Führungskraft
geeignet. Wie sieht das
aus mit, mit
äh, motiviert und hat keinen
Plan? Was meint ihr? Will man motivierte
Leute haben, die keinen Plan haben?
Die sind wahrscheinlich auch billig, ja?
Nein, die willst du auf gar keinen Fall haben.
Die, die willst du auf gar keinen
Fall haben.
Weil motivierte Leute, die
keinen Plan haben, bringen nur Chaos.
Die machen
viel und machen viel kaputt.
Ja. Und willst du
faule Leute, die keinen Plan haben? Ich kann jetzt
schon mal
spoilern, in gewissem Rahmen, ja, willst du
auch haben. Das heißt, die einzigen Leute,
die du wirklich absolut gar nicht haben
willst und unbedingt rausfiltern musst, sind
Leute, die scheiße motiviert sind,
aber planlos.
Kein Investment, Entschuldigung, ja.
Bei denen ist alles verloren, ja.
Das sind die einzigen, die du gar nicht haben willst.
Laut der Präsentation, die ich gesehen
habe. Und es
klang auch alles nachvollziehbar.
So, wie bin ich jetzt darauf gekommen?
Keine Ahnung. Zumindest darf
ich das demnächst präsentieren.
Und ich finde das wichtig, dass man ab und zu
auch mal erzählt, was man Tolles
gemacht hat, weil auf lange Sicht
nutzt es einem einfach.
Aber überleg mal, stell dir mal vor,
du hast jemanden, der komplett
lernresistent ist, keinen Plan hat
und super motiviert. Der macht dir alles
kaputt. Und außerdem, willst du
wirklich einen der
anderen wirklich guten Leute abstellen,
dass er permanent drauf guckt, was der
andere Typ macht? Ja, ich
hab's jetzt so genannt.
Ich hab's, ich, Leute,
ich hab das jetzt,
einfach mal so genannt. Ich mein, ich
muss ja da irgendwas dran schreiben an die Felder.
Wir haben das übrigens immer noch nicht
fertig geguckt, kann das sein?
Sidetracking Deluxe?
Aber jemand Schlaues, der richtig Bock hat,
der ist auch schnell jemand, der Ahnung hat.
Ja, die hätte ich ja auch woanders.
Die hätte ich ja auch nicht bei keinem Plan. Ja, ich hätte
es nicht kein Plan nennen sollen.
Ich hätte es einfach
keine Ahnung, Low IQ nennen sollen.
Ja?
Dumm, lernresistent, Low IQ und
motiviert. Das ist eine schlechte Kombination.
Ah, jemand, jemand, der Bock hat
und, und Plan hat. Die kannst
du schnell einladen. Ja, das war, das war vielleicht nicht so
schlau, oder wie ich die Felder genannt hab.
Also.
Lass uns doch jetzt mal kurz den, den
Kram hier fertig angucken.
Also.
Das hatten wir schon.
Genau, hier. Hier hab ich mich sidetracken
lassen dabei.
Bei der Sicherstellung der Systemverfügbarkeit
und bei der Erweiterung der
Unterstützung der Entschädigung. Das ist wieder so ein
Business.
Das ist
Kek-Business-Satz.
Du bist Teil unserer
Operations-Community
und wickelst unsere
Zürich-Engineering-Culture weiter.
Aha.
Das bringst du mit. Okay, lass mal
gucken. Du verfügst über Kenntnisse in
Linux und Cloud-Infrastruktur, zum Beispiel
Azure und AWS.
Ja. Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt,
wenn man ein Operations-Engineer
OpenShift-Data-Experience-MWD
ist. Die Job-Bezeichnung
macht mich immer noch fertig, Alter.
Operations-Engineer OpenShift-Data-Experience.
Würdest du bei SAP arbeiten?
Also, ich würde prinzipiell bei fast allen
arbeiten, wenn mir der Job halbwegs zusagt
und die Bezahlung richtig gut ist.
Auf SAP hält sich mein Bock aber echt in Grenzen.
Dementsprechend müsste die Bezahlung schon
wirklich enorm gut sein.
Okay, Linux-Kenntnisse und Cloud-Infrastruktur,
Erfahrung im Aufbau und Nutzung von Containers
Integration, Containers Delivery, Pipelines mit GitHub,
Software, Systeme und mehr..
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao!
Bash rein, dann macht er...
Ich finde Jenkins einfach super easy und
unkompliziert. Du kannst natürlich Jenkins
auch total over-engineeren
mit 30 Milliarden Plugins und Zeug
und Dingern. Aber ich mag Jenkins.
Außerdem hat Jenkins
so ein Logo, das ist irgendwie einprägsam.
Diesen Butler da.
Das kann man sich irgendwie merken.
Der übrigens
eigentlich
von dem geforkten
Projekt kommt, die
ursprüngliche Software hieß Hudson
und das war auch so ein Butler
und das haben sie dann so hier beim
Fork umgewurstelt.
Okay, den Atlassian Stack
Bitbucket. Gibt es das überhaupt noch
zum selbst hosten? Also von
den drei Dingern muss ich ehrlich sagen,
Bamboo kein Plan.
Jenkins ist eine super Sache. Jenkins
ist simpel. Jenkins funktioniert. Ich mag Jenkins.
Am besten gefallen
tut mir allerdings GitHub Actions. GitHub
Actions ist nice. Gerade weil es halt
einfach dabei ist und du nichts extra
irgendwie betreiben musst.
Brauchst du nicht mal extra Runner
wie bei GitLab, wo du dich drum kümmern musst.
Bei GitHub geht es halt einfach.
Du kannst bei GitHub
auch eigene Runner
betreiben,
aber musst du ja nicht bei den meisten
Anwendungsszenarien. GitHub Actions
ist einfach so simpel
und
stressfrei,
dass ich von den ganzen Sachen
tatsächlich GitHub Actions immer bevorzugen
würde. Natürlich ist bei GitHub Actions
immer so ein bisschen ein Ding. Möchtest du
wirklich deployen von
Git in der GitHub Action,
dann musst du irgendwie gucken, dass GitHub
Zugriff hat auf deine Infrastruktur
und so. Nee, das ist alles
dann immer nicht so ganz easy.
Aber rein
für so Sachen wie
wir bauen die Software, lassen
vielleicht ein paar Tests laufen, wobei man
das eigentlich schon eher beim Pull-Request,
bauen daraus ein Container-Image
und pushen es in eine Container-Registry.
Dafür ist GitHub Actions
einfach nice.
Ist die Pflege auch bei GitHub Enterprise
so einfach? Ich habe GitHub Enterprise noch nie
im Einsatz gesehen, weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil du dich dann um
Runner und sowas auf jeden Fall selbst kümmern musst.
Aber Software bauen und als Container-Image
verpacken und in die GitHub Container-Registry
pushen, das ist einfach super
gemacht in GitHub Actions. Alles
kostenlos dabei. Du musst dich auch
nicht um irgendwelche Build-Infrastruktur kümmern
oder sowas. Es geht einfach.
Also GitHub Actions ist wahrscheinlich das,
was mir davon am besten gefällt.
Wünschenswert sind Erfahrungen mit Container-Befriedigungen.
Vortrieb Docker OpenShift. Ja, von OpenShift
habe ich, ehrlich gesagt, keinen Plan.
Mit dem Rest könnte ich dienen.
Warum eigentlich nicht Kubernetes?
Wenn sie
was von Helm Customize schreiben.
Weil ohne...
Gut.
Ist OpenShift immer gleich
Kubernetes? Ich habe von OpenShift keine Ahnung.
So viel Kenntnisse, gängiger
Projektmanagement-Methoden und Werkzeugen.
Scrum!
Ah, sehen Sie wieder. Super agile
Diagonalschrift.
Skalierende Teamplayer.
Persönlich lernen wir dich Teamplayer
in guten Netzwerken.
Wisst ihr? Das ist so ein Teil.
Auf der einen Seite,
da sind die HR-Leute
und die eigentlichen IT-Leute, die sind da immer
im Konflikt.
Weil, mal so mal seriously, die richtig
Hackerman-Leute,
die du da eigentlich haben willst,
das sind nicht automatisch
schlechte Teamplayer,
aber das sind in der Regel
nicht unbedingt die sozialen
besten
Netzwerker und
ich freue mich auf das nächste
Team-Event, Leute.
Die meisten Leute, die gut in Technik sind,
sind aus einem Grund gut in Technik geworden.
Nämlich,
weil das ihnen eine gewisse
Sicherheit gibt.
Ich kenne das ja von mir.
Oder eine gewisse
Planbarkeit
auch.
Du hast sicherlich die einen oder anderen
Leute, die gute Techniker sind
und super krass extrovertiert und lustig
und sich da hinstellen und
den einen oder anderen Gag nacheinander reißen
auf der nächsten Firmen-Event-Feier.
Ich denke mir eher so, Alter, lass mich mit
Firmen-Event in Ruhe. Ich habe da keinen Bock.
Ich will mich lieber vor den Rechner setzen, eine Runde streamen
oder eine Runde Kreisel-Crime machen.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl habe,
Weihnachtsfeier,
Chat,
also,
machen wir mal ein fiktives Beispiel.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt
ein, ihr spielt ein richtig
cooles Action-RPG-Game,
sowas wie Diablo oder irgendwie
Path of Exile 2 oder so.
Also, ihr habt ein Game oder ein MMO.
Denkt euch einfach irgendein Game aus,
das ihr richtig gerne spielt und richtig gerne
grindet.
Und jetzt steht die Weihnachtsfeier an.
Und ihr habt die Auswahl.
Gehe ich nach der Arbeit zur Weihnachtsfeier
oder gehe ich nach der Arbeit zur Weihnachtsfeier?
Gehe ich nach der Arbeit, heim und spiele
fünf Stunden noch mein
aktuelles Lieblingsspiel.
Kreisel-Crime in meinem aktuellen Lieblingsspiel.
Was mache ich?
Wir müssen mal eine Abstimmung machen. Moment.
Also,
Weihnachtsfeier,
Firma Weihnachtsfeier vs.
Kreisel-Crime.
Start.
Weihnachtsfeier vs. Kreisel-Crime.
Ja, man könnte sagen, es geht ein bisschen
entgegen dem, was ich gesagt habe.
Manchmal muss man auch gut über das reden, was man gemacht hat.
Aber das kann man an anderer Stelle auch machen.
Muss man nicht zur Weihnachtsfeier.
Auf der Weihnachtsfeier ist eh meistens
nur firmenweite Selbsthuldigung.
Das glaube ich euch nicht, Chat.
Ihr stimmt doch wieder nur so ab,
dass am Ende möglichst 50-50 rauskommt.
Das glaube ich euch nicht,
dass 44% zu 57%
Weihnachtsfeier vs. Kreisel-Crime sind.
Also, Kreisel-Crime gewinnt, aber nur knapp.
Ich glaube euch aber nicht, dass so viele
von euch zur Weihnachtsfeier lieber gehen wollen.
Aber wenn ich das gewusst hätte, Chat,
ich würde sagen,
demnächst
Twitch-Wobblos-Chat-Event
im Kletterpark. Auf geht's!
Mit Teambuilding-Workshop dabei.
Geht es darum, was man will
oder darum, was man macht?
Darum, was du willst.
Es gibt ja Leute, die überwinden sich dann
entgegen dem, was sie eigentlich wollen.
Was du willst,
ist eher die Frage.
Dann mach die Abstimmung nochmal.
Okay.
Dann haben wir hier Firma-Weihnachtsfeier
vs.
Kreisel-Crime.
Also, was ihr wollt.
Nicht, was ihr wirklich macht.
Also, wo ihr mehr Bock drauf habt.
Wollt ihr lieber Kreisel-Crime machen
oder Lieblingsspiel spielen
oder auf die Firma-Weihnachtsfeier gehen?
Also, ich kann ganz klar sagen,
ich würde den Kreisel-Crime bevorzugen.
Das ist gar nicht die Frage.
Das ist...
Das wird nicht so sein.
Ich glaube es doch nicht,
dass irgendwelche BWL-Leute auf einmal dort
irgendwie CS mit ihrem Notebook spielen.
Weil ich das gerne mal sehen würde.
Habt ihr keine Kollegen,
mit denen ihr euch privat gut versteht?
Doch.
Aber auf der Weihnachtsfeier sind 2000 Leute oder so.
Die meisten davon kenne ich nicht.
Okay, das ist...
Das sind schon eher das, wo ich...
Aber Hitspringen sind immer noch so viel.
Ja, es gibt viele Leute,
das hätte ich vielleicht vorher
ehrlich anders sagen sollen.
Mir ging es darum, was ihr lieber machen würdet.
Ich weiß, dass viele Leute sich zwingen,
obwohl sie keine...
keinen Bock haben,
auf die Weihnachtsfeier zu gehen.
Ja, das ist wieder was anderes.
Da bin ich mittlerweile weg von.
Ich zwinge mich zu keinen Events mehr.
Ja, aber du hast das ganze Event drumherum,
was abfuck ist.
Vor allem geht das drei, vier Stunden.
Da sitzt du dann mit Leuten in der Ecke,
die da auch keinen Bock drauf haben.
Super.
Kannst du auch gleich sein lassen.
Weil ich weiß,
die meisten Leute,
wenn ich mich nicht gut verstehe,
die hätten auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hab's geschafft, Leute.
Ich war über zehn Jahre,
in der alten Firma.
Ich hab zwei Sachen gedodged.
Ich war fast elf Jahre,
in der alten Firma.
Ich hab zwei Sachen gedodged.
Das erste ist,
mein zehnjähriges Jubiläumsessen
hab ich gedodged.
Es gab da immer,
für alle zehnjährigen Jubilanten,
nennt man das so,
gab es immer ein tolles,
zehnjähriges Jubiläums-Event
mit dem IT-Chef,
dem Oberchef
und da gab's dann immer so ein tolles Event
in irgendeiner Location mit Essen und Zeug und allem und so.
Das hab ich geschickt gedodged,
in dem Jahr, wo ich mein zehnjähriges hatte,
war Corona.
Da hat diese zehnjahres Jubiläums-Event
nicht stattgefunden.
Und das Jahr drauf hab ich gekündigt,
bevor sie mich wieder einladen konnten.
So.
Das hab ich geschickt,
geschickt,
äh,
evaded.
Und das zweite war,
ich war über zehn Jahre da
und ich war nicht einmal auf der Weihnachtsfeier.
Und der Grund war,
also erstens war das halt so ne,
die haben sich super krass immer selbst gefeiert,
so mit Reden halten
und alle müssen klatschen
und alle flippen aus.
Das ging mir eh schon immer auf den Sack.
Aber der hauptsächliche Grund war,
dass die gesagt haben,
ich hab mir gedacht,
einmal gehst du auf die Weihnachtsfeier.
Also ich wollte eigentlich beim ersten Mal
wirklich auf die Weihnachtsfeier gehen.
Und mir hat jemand erzählt,
Max,
auf der Weihnachtsfeier müssen die neuen Leute
immer mit dem Chef zusammen auf die Bühne
und ein Weihnachtslied singen.
Hab ich gesagt, okay,
ich geh nicht auf die Weihnachtsfeier.
Und seitdem war ich dann auch nie wieder auf der Weihnachtsfeier.
Also noch nie, also nie wieder ist das falsch.
Seitdem bin ich dann auch nicht mehr auf die Weihnachtsfeier.
Oder was ist das?
Nie wieder auf die Weihnachtsfeier.
Ich war nie da, ja.
Ich war nie auf der Weihnachtsfeier.
Ich hab das das erste Mal absichtlich,
nicht hin und danach hab ich mir gut,
war ich letztes Jahr auch nicht da,
hast du nix verpasst,
hast eh keinen Bock drauf,
gehst du auch nicht hin.
Wie das auf Twitch mit dem Urheberrecht aussieht.
Genauso wie überall anderes.
Du darfst Copyright geschütztes Material
hier auch nicht groß ausstrahlen.
Bisschen, bisschen Grauzone ist Gaming-Musik,
weil Twitch ist ja nochmal eine Gaming-Stream-Plattform.
Und wenn du Game, also Spiele-Musik hast,
das ist streng genommen wahrscheinlich nicht erlaubt,
juckt aber keinen.
Ähm, also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise den Dark-Soul-Soundtrack
anmachst oder sowas, ne, das ist ja auch kein.
Filme aus, Filme senden, bist du relativ schnell weg.
Es sei denn, das sind so alte Dinger,
wo schon jegliche Copyright-Sachen abgelaufen sind.
Was könnte man als Projekt zum Go-Lernen nehmen?
CLI-Tools, CLI-Tools sind gut.
CLI-Tools sind immer gut.
Nein, hab ich nicht geschaut.
Soll ich mal gucken?
Aber ich gucke jetzt nicht im Stream.
Ich gucke mal nur nebenbei rein.
Da wird South Park ausgeschaltet.
Da wird South Park ausgestrahlt.
Viele rerunnen aber auch ihre alten Streams, ja.
Ja, also viele von den Channels kann ich mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es die lange gibt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, dann nimm halt nicht Rust, wenn du Go lernen willst.
So ganz einfach.
Einfach nicht Rust nehmen und das gleiche in Go machen.
Dann lernst du auch Go.
Ich muss mal kurz nebenbei gucken.
Die wichtigste, die wichtigste Info,
die mich auf Twitch natürlich jetzt brennend interessiert.
Wie läuft denn gerade Pools, Hot Taps und Beaches?
Was?
Mal aufmachen.
Oh, da gibt's jetzt sogar eine Warnung.
Möglicher Inhalt sexuelle Themen.
What the fuck?
What the f...
Alter.
Bin ich da gelandet?
Bin ich denn...
Alter.
Ich muss es wieder ausmachen, ey.
Okay, läuft immer noch gut.
Haben wir, haben wir doch schon.
Haben wir doch schon gemacht.
Muss man aber aufpassen.
Da muss man aufs Klo bei dem Wassersound.
So, jetzt muss ich aber endlich mal dieses...
Ich muss gleich was essen, Leute.
Ich muss...
Diese...
Stellanzeige fertig.
Ich krieg's ja heute echt nicht gebacken, ey.
Okay.
Flexible Arbeitsform und...
Fitness, Bike Leasing, Vergönzelt.
Okay.
Zum Gehalt steht hier nix, oder?
Und hier von Remote und Homeoffice steht hier auch nix.
Ja, nee, ganz ehrlich.
Wär bei mir unten durch.
Wenn zu diesem Thema so gar nix drinne steht...
Gut, hatten wir eben bei der anderen Stellenanzeige auch nicht.
Aber die andere Stellenanzeige war halt wirklich mehr, mehr kurz, äh, mehr kurz und knackig.
Hier hatten die genug Platz, was reinzuschreiben, deswegen würd ich mal einfach von ausgehen,
sie wollen nicht.
Und das wär für mich schon mal gar nicht attraktiv.
Arbeitgeber komplett ohne Remote-Work- und Homeoffice-Möglichkeit.
Der Rest deckt sich so ungefähr mit dem, was hier oben drinne steht.
Aber es ist jetzt, ja, fünf von zehn.
So.
Und das letzte für heute.
Glaub ich zumindest, hoff ich.
Rheinmetall haben wir noch am Start.
Universität-Partner.
Das gucken wir uns heute mal alles an.
Guck, ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich bin seit über vier Stunden on.
Jetzt Pepo, Pepo-Fett machen gleich.
Wird Zeit.
Übelst Hunger.
Chat, ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich jetzt das halbe Hähnchen noch futtern soll.
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich hab heut Mittag...
Ich hab heut Mittag schon Nudeln mit Lachs gefuttert.
Und morgen futter ich auch wieder Nudeln mit Lachs.
Aber das halbe Hähnchen muss weg.
Hol dir mal koreanisches Fried Chicken.
Das ist richtig gut.
Es gibt in Frankfurt jetzt...
Sorry, was soll das?
Frankfurt Korean Fried Chicken.
Ähm...
Und zwar...
Warum ist das eigentlich so, so, so schrottig geworden mit Google Maps, dass man da nicht mal draufklicken kann?
Not now. Keine Location.
Wir rejecten alles.
Es gibt einen neuen Laden.
Der ist, na ne, so neu ist der nicht.
Aber der ist nicht schlecht.
Und zwar...
Ähm...
Willy-Brandt-Platz.
Kann eigentlich nur der hier sein.
Von der Ecke her.
Ja.
Ich glaube auch, dass die das...
Bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Gibt es da noch mehr?
Aber das Essen sieht...
Sieht schon...
Ein bisschen danach aus.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ja, das ist der Laden.
Ja, ja, das ist der Laden.
Das ist wirklich nice hier.
Da war ich jetzt schon ein paar mal Mittagessen.
Die haben auch Mittags...
Die haben auch ein Mittagsmenü.
Das ist preislich im Rahmen.
Ich glaube, ihr habt das ja auch gesehen, oder?
Äh, hier.
Mittags...
Ja, guckt mal hier mit.
Ah, ne, Moment, das ist M.
Sie haben auch ein Mittagsmenü.
Die Karte liegt dann auf dem Platz.
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine...
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine gescheite Foto...
Hier gibt es eine gescheite Fotoübersicht.
Ja.
Das ist nice.
Also, da war ich jetzt schon ein paar mal.
Das kann ich echt empfehlen.
Das hier ist die Mittagskarte.
Wie ist das denn gleich?
Das ist ein Mittagsmenü, was man hier kriegt.
Du kannst hier einmal zwischen irgendwie
fünf, sechs verschiedenen Sorten Fried Chicken
und Soße und Schärfekrat aussuchen.
Dann gibt es immer ein bisschen Salat und Reis
dabei. Doch, das ist
sehr knusprig und es ist
auch, je nachdem, welchen Schärfekrat
man wählt, mega scharf.
Das schmeckt
richtig gut. Also, wenn man in dieser Ecke
ist in Frankfurt, das kann ich euch echt
empfehlen. Das schmeckt gut.
Und es ist nicht so teuer.
Hier mittags bezahlt ihr irgendwie 14 Euro.
Für so ein Menü. Das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit
echt nix.
Sehr, sehr
pog.
Alter, wie viele Bilder es da gibt.
Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Es hört wirklich
gar nicht mehr auf, Mann.
Guck mal hier, ich scrolle mich
hier. Ich scrolle mich kaputt.
Oder ist das
Endlesscrolling? Die Bilder wiederholen sich immer wieder.
Hier, Mittagsmenü 14,
20. Also, es ist wirklich nice.
Wo wir uns gerade von
Fried Chicken hatten.
Bleibt jetzt auch noch 5 Minuten knusprig.
Ja, das war die ganze Zeit knusprig.
Okay, letzte Sachen, die wir uns noch angucken.
Ein klassischer IT-Administrator.
Dass man sowas noch sieht hier.
Was ich cool finde, ja.
Endlich mal wieder was Oldschool-mäßiges.
Bei uns
erwartet dich weltweit
verteilte internationale Teams.
Flachie, okay, bla bla bla bla.
Diese, diese, diese, ähm.
Wir sind die geilsten.
Sprachen lösen bei mir meistens
nicht unbedingt das gleiche Gefühl aus,
wie wahrscheinlich der, der Schreiber
hatte. Ich habe selten das
Gefühl, wenn ich diesen, diesen
Intro-Satz lese, so, boah, geile
Firma, Alter, da wollen die schon immer mal hin.
Die meisten Einleitungsdinger
sind immer so, boah, boah,
kann man skippen.
Kommt doch mal zum Wesentlichen, so.
Das Wesentliche wäre zum Beispiel,
was gibt's denn zu verdienen?
Als Docuware-IT-System-Administrator
mit dem Schwerpunkt IT-Security. Okay,
du stehst da oben gar nicht.
Verantwortest du zusammen mit dem Team als zentrale
Anlaufstelle die Sicherstellung der reibungslosen
IT-Abläufe im gesamten Team und arbeitest dabei
mit den neuesten Technologien.
Ja, das, was die als Neuität definieren.
Du antwortest, du verantwortest aktiv
und eigenständig IT-Pro... Ach ja.
Also.
Nee.
Also, als IT-Administrator bist du kein
IT-Projektmanager.
Beim besten Willen nicht.
Da kriegst du gar nicht genug dafür bezahlt.
Oder sagen die, du arbeitest in
mit. Wollen die das vielleicht damit sagen?
Dann ist okay.
Aber so wie die es schreiben, ist es Fail.
Und hast dabei stets die
besprochenen Meilensteine im Blick.
Nö. Also, meine,
wenn ich mitarbeite, ja.
Aber nicht die vom Projekt.
Aber da steht, du verantwortest aktiv und eigenständig
IT-Projekte. Nee.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist nicht das,
wofür man als IT-Administrator
irgendwie zuständig ist.
Da bist du
so ein Admin-Projektmanager-Hybrid.
Das kann man ja durchaus machen.
Gerade wenn der Laden nicht so groß ist.
Aber dann muss das auch
in der Jobbezeichnung sich widerspiegeln.
Und vor allem dementsprechend dann auch im Gehalt.
Zu deinen Aufgaben gehören
die Unterstützung bei der Konfiguration, Wartung
sowie aller internen System-Applikationen.
Das wird kein so großer Laden sein.
Du übernimmst die Administration... Ach so,
auch noch. Okay, ja.
Wartung von Firewalls, Backups,
Implementierung
neuer Systeme. Übernimmst die operative
Verantwortung. Du hast eine hohe
Qualität für das Thema IT-Security,
welches gleichzeitig dein Schwerpunkt ist.
Du arbeitest hands-on mit unserem
Security Operations Team.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Du bist Admin.
Dein Schwerpunkt ist
Security. Aber du bist nicht Teil
des Secure Operations Teams.
Du bringst mindestens erste
fundierte Kenntnisse mit.
Ja, Moment. Ein bisschen mehr als erste
brauchst du dafür ja schon.
Wenn du IT-Security als Schwerpunkt hast.
Dann musst du dich entscheiden. Außerdem bist
du ja auch Projektmanager.
Du hast bereits Erfahrung in der aktiven
Mitarbeit und Leitung von... What the fuck?
Ist das denn Ihr Ernst?
Außerdem verfügst du über sehr gute
Kenntnisse in der Administration und Netzwerken.
Welche Betriebssysteme wären
ja mal gut? Und Netzwerksachen.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse
im Bereich IT-Sicherheit, Firewalls,
Monitoring sowie Backup und
Virtualisierung. Auch noch. Okay.
Du hast ein
grundlegendes Interesse an der
IT-Sicherheit. ISMS.
Was ist ISMS schon wieder? Warum muss man
das schon wieder abkürzen?
Information Security Management.
ISMS. Das hört sich an wie eine Terrororganisation
oder so, Alter.
ISMS. Deine Arbeitsweise
zeichnet sich durch eine aus...
Warum muss alles abgekürzt werden, Mann?
TOGAF. Ja, es gibt so viele
abgedrehte Abkürzungen.
Deine Arbeitsweise
zeichnet sich durch eine ausgeprägte
Kommunikation und Teamfähigkeit aus.
Ein hohes Maß an
Verantwortung ausgeprägt.
Okay.
Darauf kannst du dich freuen.
Wenn, da steht nicht drinnen mit
es gibt einen Arsch voll Geld.
Weltweit verteilt in nationale Teams.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum mich das so geil freuen sollte.
Flexibler Arbeitsort und Arbeitszeit.
Du arbeitest mobil oder in einem unserer
modernen, gut ausgestatteten Büros.
Das ist ja schön und gut. Es ist halt die Frage,
ob ihr das auch ernst meint.
Ob die Sache mit du arbeitest mobil
nicht so ein Ding ist, so nach dem Motto
wenn wir dich an den Arsch der Welt schicken,
irgendwohin was nachzugucken, dann darfst du auch
mobil arbeiten, sondern ob das da auch wirklich
einen festen Anteil gibt, dass du sagen
okay, eine Woche die Woche kommst du ins Büro
ein Tag die Woche und vier Tage darfst du daheim bleiben.
Weiß ich nicht. Das wäre interessant.
Individuelle Förderung.
Ja, wohlverdient.
35 Urlaubstage.
Okay, das brauchst du wahrscheinlich in dem Job auch.
35 Urlaubstage
ist wirklich nicht schlecht. Das ist bestimmt noch
eine 130% Stelle.
Gesunde Ernährung zusammen
genießen wir Fairtrade Kaffee mit
Snacks und frisches Obst.
Da ist er, Leute.
Wir hatten ihn heute noch nicht. Da ist er.
Versteckt. Seht ihr ihn?
Ein bisschen versteckt, aber da ist er.
Der Obstkorb
ist da. Endlich mal eine
Stelleanzeige mit Obstkorb heute.
Sowie
bezuschussten Lunch aus dem
Fuji
Kühlschrank.
Was ist das?
Was ist ein Fuji Kühlschrank?
Das ist quasi so ein Essensautomat.
Das so das
geilste ist.
Regelmäßige Mitarbeiter und Teams
Events. Virtuell
oder vor Ort. Jawohl!
Gute Erreichbarkeit auf
allen Wegen.
Stackshare. Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an.
Wir gucken uns jetzt
mal an, was die so einsetzen.
Okay,
die haben alles. Okay, was haben sie denn?
JavaScript, Python, NodeJS, HTML,
MySQL, TypeScript, Redis, C-Sharp,
Vue, ASP.net, Azure,
Swift. Alter!
Kotlin, die haben, also, fuck!
Die haben wirklich alles.
Fullstack, Leute.
Fullest stack.
Hyperstack.
IOS,
Angular, Android,
Errorstore und Windows.
Ist sie auch am Start? Okay.
Ah, naja.
Ja gut, also.
Die Stellenanzeige
finde ich nicht gut.
Die ist gar nicht mal schlecht
geschrieben oder so. Die ist sehr 0815
vom Aufbau und auch wie es
geschrieben ist, aber
die Sachen passen einfach nicht zusammen.
Die wollen zu viel in einer
Person. Nicht nur, dass
du Ahnung haben, also nicht nur, dass du
dein Schwerpunkt IT Security
sein soll,
dass du Netzwerk,
also quasi, wenn man sagt,
ey, dein Schwerpunkt ist Netzwerk
und Security, das würde ich ja noch irgendwie,
das passt doch irgendwie
zusammen, ja. Aber,
du kümmerst dich um alle Server, alle internen
Applikationen, Netzwerkinfrastruktur,
Firewalls,
du kümmerst dich um alle Backups,
du bist dabei, wenn es
darum geht, komplett neue Sachen
aufzunehmen und bist dann auch danach
dafür verantwortlich. Du bist
Security Pro, allerdings
irgendwie nicht teils des Security
Operation Teams und das
was mich am meisten abschreckt dabei
ist,
dass die Leitung von IT-Projekten
wollen von dem Admin.
Also,
aktive
Mitarbeit in IT-Projekten,
da sag ich gar nichts dabei,
aber Leitung von IT-Projekten,
das gibt für mich diese Stelle
nicht her.
Du kannst ja auch nicht sagen, ey, ich will an der Technik
voll Plan hatten, das alles macht, was du haben musst,
weil das ist ein ziemlich umfangreiches
Feld, was hier unten ja sogar noch ein bisschen,
erweitert wird,
mit Virtualisierung, aber
dann sollst du nebenbei nochmal, wir leiten
auch mal noch irgendein Projekt,
nee, das passt nicht. Das passt nicht zusammen.
Finde ich nicht gut.
3 von 10 Punkten kriegt
die Stellenanzeige.
Bezahlung steht doch gar nichts da, oder?
Hast du irgendwas von Bezahlung gesehen?
Bezahlung steht doch gar nichts da.
Wo hast du das her?
Freaky XP?
Also, wenn das der Fall ist,
das kann ja durchaus sein,
dann hätten sie es anders schreiben müssen.
Wenn in der Stellenanzeige drin steht,
Leitung von IT-Projekten,
dann ist das für mich,
also für mich ist es kein IT-Projekt,
wie ich installiere einen neuen
Linux-Server,
das ist Daily Business für einen Admin.
Ich verstehe unter Leitung
IT-Projekte, wir suchen,
was weiß ich,
eine neue
neue
CMDB-Software
und jetzt müssen wir Produkte auswählen
und uns mit Herstellern in Verbindung setzen
und wir haben noch drei Mitarbeiter in diesem Projekt,
die einen gucken das und machen hier und da
und du koordinierst das.
Nö, das sehe ich da gar nicht.
Und das schreiben sie ja.
Sie schreiben ja hier explizit.
Leitung von IT-Projekten
und du verantwortest
aktiv und eigenständig IT-Projekte.
Das steht explizit da.
Und wenn sie das nicht so meinen,
dann sollten sie es vielleicht nicht so schreiben,
weil das die Leute abschreckt.
Also mich würde das abschrecken.
Es kann durchaus sein,
dass das eigentlich ein super Arbeitgeber ist.
Das muss ich ja immer dabei sagen.
Die Stellenanzeigen ist das erste Mal,
wo wir hier mit diesen Unternehmen immer in Kontakt kommen
und das ist ein bisschen wie das Anschreiben in der Bewerbung.
Das ist der erste Eindruck,
den ich habe, den ihr davon habt
und
das kann sein, dass es ein super Arbeitgeber ist
und dass es ein ganz toller Job ist.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Was ich in der Stellenanzeige sehe
und was es für einen Eindruck auf mich macht.
Und was ich hier lese ist,
du verantwortest aktiv und eigenständig IT-Projekte
und ich finde, das passt nicht zu einem IT-Administrator,
der übrigens nebenbei sich auch noch
um so ziemlich alles andere kümmern soll,
was der Laden hat.
Wenn die das anders schreiben würden,
kein Problem.
Aber so wie es da steht,
finde ich, braucht es nichts.
FreakyXP arbeitet dort als fulles Stack.
Okay,
dann hat er Insider-Informationen hier.
Chatge,
schön,
dass ihr so zahlreich am Start wart
heute.
Wir sind jetzt 4 Stunden 30 on.
Ich gehe jetzt runter, was essen.
Morgen früh,
so zwischen 8 und 10 bin ich wieder da.
Aufwachen-Stream, wöchentlicher Aufwachen-Stream.
Wer dabei sein will,
lässt jetzt sein Follow da
und sein Prime-Sub, wenn er Bock hat.
Und
ich gehe jetzt was puttern.
Pepo-Fat-Time.
So,
gerade mal hier im Vorschau-Rechner
noch was umstellen.
Bin ich weg.
Ähnlich wie der regelmäßige Stream.
Ja, mir hat das auch ein bisschen gefehlt.
Einfach mal 4,5 Stunden reden,
bis einem der Hals weh tut.
Ich glaube,
das ist ja meine Theorie,
YouTube-Kanal. Ja, dieses Wochenende
neues Video.
Ich habe ja so eine Theorie.
Ich glaube,
mir macht es mittlerweile Spaß,
Präsentationen zu machen,
auf der Arbeit, aus einem ähnlichen Grund,
wie das mit
Streams und YouTube-Videos ist.
Und zwar,
dass mir das
in irgendeiner Art und Weise gefällt,
nicht näher definierbare
Art und Weise,
gefällt mir das,
wenn mir Leute zuhören
und ich
meinen Senf zu Sachen habe.
Also,
dass ich meinen Senf zu Sachen
dazugeben kann und mir Leute dabei zuhören.
Das ist eine Kombination,
die gefällt mir und ich glaube,
das ist sowohl bei YouTube-Videos der Fall,
bei Twitch-Streams der Fall,
als auch bei Präsentationen der Fall.
Das ist so diese Gemeinsamkeit dabei.
Ich kann meinen Senf zu einem Thema geben,
was mich ja persönlich auch meistens interessiert
und Leute hören mir dabei zu.
Was kann es eigentlich
Besseres geben, als
man kann sich zu einem Thema auslassen,
wenn man sich dafür interessiert?
Und es hören auch noch Leute zu,
die sich auch dafür interessieren.
Das ist eigentlich super, oder?
Eigentlich ist so ganze Streaming-Geschichte
echt eine super Sache.
Ja, schön, dass ihr am Start wart, Leute.
Jetzt aber genug. Außerdem habe ich eh den
highest IQ Twitch-Stream.
Jetzt aber gehe ich wirklich was futtern.
Wir hören uns, Leute, morgen früh.
Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.